hey everyone welcome to this video on
seo full course
today we'll begin this full course video
with what is seo and how seo works
then we will be looking at a bunch of
on-page and off-page elements
after this we will learn how to analyze
and measure website metrics using google
analytics tool
we will also see how to use google tag
manager then we will discuss some of the
important techniques to rank number one
on google and youtube
simple ways to increase website traffic
basic knowledge of seo tools and finally
we will conclude this video by
discussing the important tips and tricks
of seo for this training with me i have
our experienced aws specialist rob and
rahul
together we will take you through the
various topics of seo
so let's start with an exciting video on
seo full course before we begin make
sure to subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update from simplylearn
rachel is a baker who runs her own
bakery
to expand her business she decided to
create an online presence by first
setting up a blog she began posting on
her blog regularly
however even after regularly posting on
the blog there were barely any visitors
showing up
deciding not to give up rachel began
searching for a solution on the internet
that's when she came across seo or
search engine optimization a term she's
never heard before
so let's take a journey together and
help her learn about seo
search engine optimization is a method
that could improve the quality and
quantity of the audience coming to
rachel's website from search engines
it could increase brand awareness
attract local customers and build
credibility and trust
and all of this is possible without
having to spend a single penny
to bring visitors to our website rachel
would have to take advantage of the two
types of seo on-page and off-page seo
rachel first decides to tackle on-page
seo and get that sorted
on-page seo involved rachel optimizing
her website both in terms of content and
the technical aspects including the html
source code schema meta tags and more
she started off by using tools like
google adwords all ref and semrush to
identify popular search terms associated
with the recipes she planned to publish
on her blog she began to look for search
terms related to the broader area of
baking cooking and related topics
once she found these search terms she
began to incorporate them into her
recipes
she started off by providing an
introduction to the recipe with this she
could provide an engaging beginning to
her story like how the dish reminded her
of her childhood and enabled her to
naturally include the search terms into
the blog she also included these
keywords in the actual recipe as well
additionally she added pictures videos
time lapses and more to increase
credibility and engagement for her
content and subsequently persuading
search engines to show her content to
more people
after this she moved to the website meta
content that search engines display when
her blog appears in search results
she optimized the meta tags alt tags
header tags and more this completed the
on-page aspect of seo
thanks to this she saw a significant
increase in the number of visitors
coming to her page
having done all she could on her web
page she now decides to explore what
could be done off page to improve her
page's visibility on search engines
off-page seo involved rachel doing
things outside her site page to help
increase its search engine rankings
making optimizations outside the site
would improve the site's popularity
relevance trustworthiness and authority
this is possible with the help of
reputable websites vouching for your
content with backlinks social media
marketing guest blogging linked unlinked
brand mentions
influencer marketing and much more
rachel also understood that for her
content to reach people she would have
to promote it on social media platforms
like facebook twitter and instagram as
well as niche platforms like quora
reddit and medium
these could help her achieve greater
reach for her website by sending
stronger social signals to search
engines
leading to the page being shown as
highly relevant for related searches and
audiences
and even after understanding and
implementing all of this
rachel had just scratched the surface of
what was possible with seo
before we find out what she did next
let's have a look at a quiz
which of the following is the most
effective way to improve off-page seo
one creating plenty of web pages of a
content
two
getting backlinks from relevant and
authoritative sites
3. acquiring backlinks through link
buying
4. none of the above
let us know your answer in the comments
section below for a chance to win an
amazon voucher now let's go back to
rachel rachel decided to take up
simplylearn's digital marketing
certification with classes covering just
about everything she needed to know
about seo it was only a matter of time
before rachel began to implement her
learnings on her website and see a
massive uptick in the number of viewers
coming to her website
in time she could even earn money off
the site by setting up an online shop
and with that we've covered an
introduction to the concepts of seo
welcome my name is rob sanders i'm a
course instructor at simplylearn today
we're going to talk about why you would
want to rank using seo and seo is search
engine optimization also known as
organic search you also may just hear us
say organic listings we're going to talk
a little bit about why you'd want to
rank your website in organic search okay
what is search engine optimization then
we're going to follow that up with how
does google rank websites so
why does it rank one website over
another and how do we get our website to
rank number one then we're going to talk
about the different types of seo or
search engine optimization techniques so
you can get your website ranked number
one and then we're gonna finish that off
with the do's and don'ts of seo so let's
get right to it and talk about why seo
so we're gonna use a basic example and
let's just say you have a blog you're a
food blogger you're passionate about
food and your niche is ice cream and
let's just say you have a lot of ice
cream recipes you want to get traffic to
your blog you want people to read your
blog and you're curious why am i not
ranking for my blog
why when people type in ice cream
recipes and say google my blog posts
don't appear at the top of organic
rankings and there's a number of reasons
why you wouldn't be ranked for your blog
post or your ice cream recipes and the
main reason would be your competitors so
there could be somebody else out there
who is also passionate about ice cream
and has been blogging a longer longer
than you and they have more content and
more blog posts and more pages for
google to rank so that's usually the
number one reason the other reason is
improper usage of keywords and we're
going to talk a little bit or it's
actually a lot more about you know
keyword usage in
your content so what kind of keywords do
you want to rank for that's really what
we're talking about when we talk about
usage of keywords what keywords do you
want to rank for and how do we work
those keywords into the content another
reason is port link building practices
and really that means our other blog
posts or other websites linking to you
also are you linking to other pages on
your website and so it's all about link
building and with link building it's
internal linking so are we linking from
one blog post to another and it's
external linking are other websites of
high quality linking to us and so that's
what we talk about when we talk about
link building and then another reason is
web page load time so you could be
running your blog post on say wordpress
for example and
your blog post isn't loading fast enough
well if you look at it this way think
about it if you're google would you
really want to rank a website or blog
post in this example number one on
google rankings if that particular page
loaded very slow no you wouldn't because
when somebody clicked on that link in
organic search and went to your website
they're going to have a bad experience
because the page is going to load slow
so google doesn't want their users to
have a bad experience you don't want
your users to have a bad experience and
so that's why web page load time is a
critical factor for ranking so we need
to make sure that our web pages load
fast and then your user experience is
not good enough so
google again based on my example about
the web page load time google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page load time but also
you know google doesn't want any spam
content google doesn't want any pop-ups
or overbearing ads on the web page they
want people to are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is the indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
is google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a blog with a hundred recipes you want
google to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on google organic search so
let's move on to what is seo so sticking
with our ice cream blog theme really seo
search engine optimization really is the
practice of increasing your pages that
google has indexed up the rankings so
the end result is we want all our pages
to be ranked number one for particular
keywords so if you want to be ranked for
ice cream recipes well there's certain
things you need to do so that's
generally how it works we need to apply
search engine optimization to increase a
page for keyword we want to be found for
so let me give you an example so let's
just say there's a hundred students that
participated in an essay competition and
so the competition in this particular
case is evaluated on the basis of is the
content relevant are they using suitable
titles for their essay do they have
structure when they're participating in
this essay or talking about the essay
and do they have a suitable synopsis and
is the content neat and readable these
seem all logical for an essay
competition well guess what they seem
logical for seo because that's exactly
how seo works it's exactly all those
points i just may mention about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in seo and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our pages
google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called the meta
description and then again the content
needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
site speed because site speeds important
okay and when we talk about responsive
design when i say responsive design that
means your site your page needs a load
both on desktop and also on mobile and
so all these things are important just
like an essay competition google is the
judge and they need to be able to
determine what page is best to rank
number one number two number three etc
on google search and then link building
remember i mentioned link building a
moment ago well link building internally
and externally also plays a vital role
and so we're going to talk about that a
little bit later in the class when we
talk about off-page seo how does google
rank website and basically google
follows three basic steps to rank a
website they need to crawl your website
they need to take what they call back to
their servers and when they take it back
to their servers your your web pages
they need to
you have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to
basically rank the those pages that
they've indexed from number one to
infinity depending on how many pages are
relevant to that search query so really
it's about crawling indexing and ranking
so crawling is simply a process done by
which google has bots and
what these bots do is they go to your
web server and they're going to crawl
every page that they can find and how do
they find these pages well they
basically follow links you might have
heard the term spydering but that's what
they call search engine spidering so
basically what google's doing is they're
building a web so to speak all the links
that they're following and so when they
can follow all these links on your
website they're going to be able to
crawl them and when they crawl them
basically they're going to take that
content and store it on their servers so
it's available in their index so based
on this method google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed into google because if
they can't crawl your website you're not
going to be found and if you can't be
found they're not going to show up for
relevant keywords so we need to make
sure your site's available to be crawled
and we'll talk about that a little bit
later okay but let's show you an example
so let's just go to google search and if
i type in the keyword simply learn okay
i could see i have one million ten
thousand results okay and that's how
many results are showing up for simply
learn okay now they may not all be
simply learned pages but nonetheless
simply learned is ranked number one here
organically and there are 1 million 10
000 pages related to the keyword simply
learn now when it comes to organic
search we don't want to get it confused
with paid search so anytime you see paid
search you're going to see
something that says add next to it okay
so we could see that there are paid ads
here but when it comes to organic search
those are generally below paid ads and
so that's where google counts the 1
million 10 000 results and so that's the
whole idea behind crawling and indexing
google's able to cross simply learn's
website and based on all the pages that
they gather they're going to make those
pages available in organic search so if
you type in a keyword and your web page
is not available for indexing then
you're never going to show up for that
keyword so that's why it's important to
make sure your website is available for
crawling and indexing and so when a user
types a query on search google search
the most relevant websites that are in
google's index are going appear in the
search results so in the example i gave
was simply learn well simply learn is
the brand name of the company simply
learn so there's a lot of relevancy
there so that's why you see simply learn
show up here organically number one like
we mentioned about what is seo and why
seo we talked about that user experience
so there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learn example simply learn
is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned pages because that's who they
are simply learn however
simply learn also needs to make sure
that you know for their pages the page
load time is fast meaning these pages
load very fast for the end user and
google also takes into account other
factors like how long someone is staying
on a website or are they bouncing
meaning are they going to one page that
they land on and then leaving the
website okay and so the user experience
is very very important there are other
factors also like language and location
and so for example location if you do a
search say in india the results are
going to be a little bit different than
say the results in the united states why
because google is indexing as many web
pages as they can find so if somebody's
doing a search in india
their results may be a little bit
different than the results show up in
the us because google has different bots
and these bots are crawling different
pages at different times and so google's
index is updating continuously but it's
not real time syncing so if you do a
search in india you may not see exactly
the same thing because both search
engines the google and india and the
google in the us are may not be exactly
synced up so an example would be you
know if you're looking for cafe so if
you search a cafe and say san francisco
you're going to see different results
now if you do a search for cafes in
mumbai you're going to see different
results there's going to be local search
here at the top there may be some paid
search but again you may see different
results because one location but two
google search engines in india and
united states google.com aren't exactly
synced up exactly at the same exact time
you do that search so location is
important language is important and
relevancy is important along with user
experience so all those are important
factors in how google ranks websites
okay so we're going to talk about the
types of seo now so if we want to rank
for a particular keyword on google we're
going to have to apply search engine
optimization and so there's two
strategies to search engine optimization
on-page seo and off-page seo so first
we're gonna talk about on-page seo so
on-page seo is nothing more than
optimizing your own website and so when
we say optimizing your own website
there's certain elements on your website
and on your web pages that we need to
take into account and so some of those
elements are headers meta descriptions
title tags linking so all of those
elements are something we can control as
an end user who wants to rank our web
page and our website on google and
before we do anything with our website
the first thing we need to do
is understand
what keywords we want to rank for in
order to understand what keywords we
want to rank for we need to do keyword
research and if you do anything in seo
keyword research is the most important
activity that's the most important thing
you can do for seo and why do i say it's
the most important because you need to
understand if you choose a keyword that
you want to rank for you need to
understand how much traffic you're going
to get from that keyword if you're
ranked organically say number one on
google so how much traffic will you get
if you're ranked number one on google so
you need to understand what the volume
is and then number two we need to
understand what the competition is for
that keyword that you want to rank for
so if you choose a keyword and there's
not much competition for it then chances
are you can rank for that keyword for a
web page on your website quicker than
say a keyword that has a lot of
competition so we need to understand
those two basic factors volume and
competition before we choose a keyword
and it's it's simply the practice of
going through the motions of getting
your volume and getting your competition
data so you can choose the keywords you
want and then once you choose the
keywords you want then you can go and
apply on page seo you can change the
title tag the meta descriptions the
headers all those elements can be
changed but first you need to choose
your keywords and so again the primary
components we're looking for are how
much traffic you can get or the search
volume how much competition there is for
that keyword and of course relevancy
okay you need to be able to choose a
keyword that's relevant to the web page
you're trying to rank for and so let me
show you example how to go through this
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to use a tool and the tool i would
recommend is google keyword planner and
why do i choose google keyword planner
because if we're trying to rank on
google.com or google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so google's going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if i want to use google's
keyword planner and i want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then i'm going to
type that keyword into google's keyword
planner and what google is going to do
is they're going to give me some trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword i can
see that there are trends that that
appear for both desktop and mobile so
mobile is important because people start
their search process a lot of times on
their mobile device so we want to be
able to get data from mobile as well as
desktop and so we could see a trend here
that for each particular month over the
last 12 months we can see how much
volume this particular keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
gets per month and so on average on
average over the past 12 months i could
see how to become a digital marketing
specialist is averages 30 searches a
month and this is on google.com and so
google gives us the volume what they
also give us is the competition and so
here i can see google says for that
particular keyword the competition is
medium and so in the google's keyword
planner what they also do is give me
other relevant keywords that i might
think about optimizing for because you
don't want to optimize for just one
keyword so how to become a digital
marketing specialist they're going to
also offer up other types of keywords
that are relevant so just digital
marketing specialist social media
marketing specialist so for those
keywords i can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist i
can see the average volume is 1000 per
month on average of the last 12 months i
can also see the competition is medium
but for some other keywords i can see
the search volume being high like
digital marketing course at 2 900 per
month but also the competition is high
and so what i would recommend as a best
practice is to collect all your relevant
keywords okay and put all your relevant
keywords in a spreadsheet and when you
put all these relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet you want to get the data on
those keywords and the data i'm
referring to is the volume and
competition so in this case we have
volume from google planner google's
keyword planner and i have competition
from google's keyword planner and so if
i go into a spreadsheet and i put all
that information in here i'm going to be
able to see the volume and competition
and so that's important however one
thing to note here is that google's
keyword planner if we go back just gives
us low medium and high and if i want to
compare numbers to numbers maybe i want
to be able to get exactly the
competition number for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
what i can do is go into google and i
can type in that keyword so if i type in
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist i can see there's
76 million results so i could see 76
million results 76.1 actually and for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now that's a whole
lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30 uh per month on average and so
what i want to do is get a more clear
picture of the competition and so what
you could actually do is type in the
syntax all in title and then colon and
then your keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist and when i
do that i get a different result here i
can see only 136
listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136.
with that particular keyword that we
want to rank for
in the title tag okay so the title tag
is what you see when you type in a
keyword or search query in google search
and the title tag is what you see at the
top of every search result and so now i
can see i typed in how to become a
digital marketing specialist with the
all in title syntax and now i can see
every listing every one of these
136 results have that particular keyword
in it so i could see every one of them
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and why is that important
because now that tells me i only need to
climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from google's
keyword planner but you want to get your
competition from google search and again
that's simply typing in the syntax hall
in title and then your keyword in this
example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page seo so
again you want to
create content for
say a keyword like digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use google search see first
when they type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page seo it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
google will truncate the title tag so if
i go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag google
truncated it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because when we have the
right keyword
in the title tag and somebody types in
that keyword then chances are it's going
to be relevant they're going to see it
and they're going to click through to
your website and that's the whole idea
behind ranking we want to get clicks so
that's how the title tag appears so when
you optimize it you're going to update
the title tag and this is how it shows
up it's going to show up at the top of
your listing okay and it's going to be
bigger and bolder than anything else
google displays so the second thing you
want to optimize is the meta description
and the meta description is simply just
a brief description up to a hundred and
fifty five i would say about a hundred
and fifty five to 60 160 characters but
probably no more than that and so the
meta description is nothing more than a
summary of the web page itself so if i
go back to my google search results i
see my title tag and i see the page that
this particular listing belongs to and
underneath that is where i can see my
meta description so in this particular
keyword query how to become a digital
marketing specialist i see the meta
description an ultimate guide on how to
build a career in digital marketing and
the skills required to become a digital
marketing specialist note that it's a
well-written meta description within 155
characters and it includes the keyword
digital marketing specialist so we're
trying to rank for how to become a
digital marketing specialist and here
you can see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description in the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave the
meta description blank then you're
leaving it to google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
seo we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal it gives us more characters
to work with it gives us more to talk
about so for that particular page and so
if the title tag is only 60 characters
maximum it's not a lot of information to
try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us in identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the two working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the url and url stands for uniform
resource locator and why is the url so
important because that's what people see
so if i go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the url also includes how to
become a digital marketing specialist
article okay so it's very relevant the
url is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's relevant to the keyword query and
that's important for the end user and
google google wants to know hey is this
the page that's relevant to the user's
query and if it is then this user is
likely going to have a good user
experience after they click on the
listing so the url is an element that
helps not only with the click-through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
url structure doesn't help at all
because not only does google not
recognize the url as being relevant but
the end user
may not want to click on that page given
the the way the url looks so you want to
try and avoid a poor url structure so
the rule of thumb is this if you don't
understand what the url is then google
is likely not going to understand what
the url is and so we want to try and
keep our url structures clean and when i
say clean ideally you want to make sure
that whatever keyword you're trying to
optimize that's the keyword that's
included in the url nothing included
that is not understandable so again
going back to our example how to become
a digital marketing specialist it's very
clean the title tag is the keyword the
meta description is cleanly written has
the keyword and then the url is the
other element that the end user can see
and that url includes the keyword in it
so after we've done those three elements
the title tag the meta description and
the url then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organizational
structure to the content and with
headers there's a hierarchy so you have
anywhere from h1 which is the top of the
hierarchy to an h6 and so you're free to
use any one of those headers when
building out a page in order to organize
the content but ideally you probably
want to stick with an h1 or an h2
because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to google that hey
this header with this particular keyword
in it is important so if you use an h6
with the keyword in it it's telling
google hey this is an h6 but it's not as
important so an h1 and an h2 tag show
importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is so here you can
see an h1 is going to be at the top of
the hierarchy so that means it's going
to be bigger and bolder then you have an
h2 which is going to be bigger and
bolder than an h3 but not as big and
bold as an h2 so with headers not only
are you organizing the content
accordingly but you're also signaling to
google how important that particular
header is and of course the header needs
to include the keyword we're trying to
rank for so let's take a look again at
that example so if we go to how to
become a digital marketing specialist if
i click on that page i can look at the
content and i can see that there are
headers in here so the headers are there
to organize the content and that's what
we want we want to be able to organize
the content and if you look at the other
example i'm showing here how to become a
digital marketing specialist a learning
path explored you can see that's an h1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an h2 and so we're not stressing to
google that that's more important than
h1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to google
what's important and also to organize
the content because google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on
is internal linking and so internal
linking if you remember uh earlier in
the presentation it's basically links
from one page on your website to another
and so here we can see on this
particular article how to become a
digital marketing specialist there's
also links to
other pages on
simply learn's website and so for this
particular content it also links to seo
specialist ppc specialist social media
marketing specialist and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their website that are
relevant to becoming a digital marketing
specialist and so this is a best
practice when you're optimizing a web
page so you want to be able to have
internal linking on your site and the
whole idea behind internal linking is it
also allows users to navigate through
the site naturally so when i say
naturally they don't always have to
refer back to the top navigation they
can naturally and seamlessly go from one
relevant article or page to another and
so that's the whole idea behind link
building and internal link building it
allows google to identify you know pages
that they want to crawl and index
because they're linked to one another
but it also helps the end user because
it allows the end user to go from one
page to another and it's signaling to
google hey this particular page is
linked to this page so we're going to
also index that page and so that's the
whole important part of internal linking
it's about the end user experience and
it's about allowing google to find the
pages on your website so they can crawl
them and index them so you can be ranked
for them and so also in addition to
internal linking we want to be able to
use natural language and so what do i
mean by natural language or natural
language processing so what google does
is in terms of natural language
processing they're looking for the
content and the keyword it needs to be
relevant so when your website is about
digital marketing you don't necessarily
want to rank or try to rank for the
keyword digital marketing one it's too
broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more natural and so that's
what we mean on natural language
processing we want to choose keywords
that are more natural to the content
you're writing so instead of the keyword
digital marketing maybe we want to talk
about the types of digital marketing or
digital marketing examples or what is a
digital marketing strategy or how to
become a digital marketing specialist so
those are all relevant keywords to
digital marketing and more relevant to
the content because if you try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing again
it's probably going to be a little bit
broad probably more competition and not
as relevant to your content and as a
result probably not a good user
experience so think about some other
keywords that you could optimize and
rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify
other keywords and the natural language
process what keywords are more relevant
for the content and then another element
on page seo is the sitemap and so with
the sitemap it's basically a list of all
the pages on your website and the whole
idea of listing all the pages on your
website in one document is it helps both
users and search engines understand the
structure of your website so there's two
types of site maps one's an html site
map and that's designed for humans so if
you have a website with a lot of content
at the footer or the bottom of your web
page you probably want to have a link to
sitemap so if somebody clicks on that
site map they're going to be able to see
all the pages on your website structured
in an organized manner well an xml
sitemap and xml is just a different
format it's designed for crawlers and so
the whole idea remember is google likes
to crawl content when they crawl content
they bring it back to their servers and
index it and so we want to be able to
create a sitemap for google or other
search engine crawlers and so xml is the
format so
let me show you example of how that
looks so if i go to simplylearn.com and
simply type in say sitemap.xml just as
an example i'm going to get this
particular page and this particular page
displays two xml sitemaps so these site
maps are there for google to go ahead
and crawl and nothing more than a list
of all the pages on your website and so
this is a quick and easy way for google
to get a hold of all those pages so that
they can index them and that's the whole
idea behind seo you want to be able to
have google index all the content you
want to be found for for the keywords
you want to be found for so it all
starts with the site map so let's go
from on-page seo which in recap is
basically optimizing certain elements on
your website so that you are relevant
for a particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag the meta
description the url the headers choosing
the right keywords to put into the
content having internal linking and also
updating the sitemap well those are
elements that you can do on your website
so we're going to switch gears and talk
about a different strategy off-page seo
because without on page or off page you
can't have a page ranking so the two
work together so you can do as much as
you want on on page but you still need
off page seo and you can do all the off
page seo you want but you still need on
page so both of these strategies have to
be in full effect in order for you to
rank so let's now switch gears to off
page seo and so off page seo is simply
the process of linking or promoting your
website using link building and so if
you remember i talked about this earlier
on there's two types of links internal
and external linking and so for on-page
seo we used internal linking for
off-page seo we're going to talk about
external linking and external linking
allows us to improve our website's
recognition or relevancy or credibility
and why do we want to improve our
relevancy and credibility and
trustworthiness and authority because we
want google to know that our web page is
trustworthy it is recognized by other
websites and it is relevant for a
particular keyword and so if we can do
that using off-page seo methods then
google's going to rank our web page for
the keyword we want to be found for so
it's really off-page seo synonymous with
link building and there's plenty of
opportunities to do link building it
just comes down to creating a strategy
so again some of the benefits to off
page well we talked about you know being
credible and trustworthiness and
relevant we need to do that in order to
rank but there's some other benefits
there so if we have a link on another
credible website then it's likely going
to increase the traffic to our own
website it also creates high domain
authority and so what i mean by high
domain authority is if we have basically
links to other web pages pointing back
to us then basically our domain
authority is going to improve and when
our domain authority improves other
websites are going to want to link to us
so the higher authoritative we are for
our website then other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain authority so it all starts
with linking to
other high domain authority websites so
linking to a high domain authority
website for example having a link on
wikipedia that points back to our web
page creates high domain authority for
us and it helps drive traffic so some of
the other benefits of off page seo are
credibility so if we're linking from
wikipedia to our web page it does create
credibility for us it also helps us
increase our page rank so remember that
external linking helps build domain
authority helps build credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
page and then certainly not last having
a good off-page seo link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high
authority websites wikipedia or say a
social platform it's going to increase
our brand awareness and increasing our
brand awareness increases our
trustworthiness and so if somebody is
looking to say become a digital
marketing specialist then likely instead
of typing in digital marketing
specialist on google they may type in
our brand name in this case simply learn
and so these are all the benefits to
off-page seo so it's nothing more than
having links on other websites that are
pointing back to ours and again there's
lots of benefits it's drives helps drive
traffic and increases our authority so
those are things that we want to take
advantage of when we want to rank and
the key behind off page seo or link
building is always going to be content
so from an on-page seo perspective
having quality content allows that
content to be optimized for relevant
keyword and ranked but also from an
off-page seo strategy having high
quality content allows us to have other
sites and it doesn't necessarily have to
be a website it could be a social
platform or can be another blogging
platform or blogging website linked back
to ours why because the content is
original it's natural it's well
structured it reads well and so that's
the whole idea behind off page you can't
have links on other websites if you
don't have quality content so one of the
ideas behind off-page seo is not only do
you want to create good content but you
probably want to
spend a lot of time or a bit of time on
others websites so remember the example
i used earlier in this presentation
about having an ice cream blog and ice
cream recipes well it probably wouldn't
be a bad idea to say spend some time on
other blogs related to desserts related
to cakes related to food in general
related to vegetables or other items
that people could link from so the whole
idea is understanding who else is out
there who has relevant content that you
could share so you could share your
content with them they can share their
content with you and generally that's
how it works naturally anyway in the web
sphere if somebody likes your content
they're going to link to it they don't
necessarily have to wait for you to ask
them but it might not be a bad idea to
understand who else is out there that
has content similar to yours so that you
can you know get a link on that
particular website or blog post and so
some other ideas behind
having external links pointing back to
your website is social media so social
media is not just facebook or twitter
but it expands beyond that there's
there's core there's medium there's all
sorts of content generated websites like
reddit so the list goes on and on you
just need to find what's relevant for
your content if it's relevant for your
content then it's worth putting or
trying to get the external link on that
social media platform and then again
going back to my ice cream blog recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog that you want to have an external
link on there's nothing wrong with
reaching out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant then why not it's only going to
help your end user experience if you add
somebody who has a say a blog about
cakes having their link on your blog
post so there's nothing wrong with it
because it also adds to the user
experience and if you're going to ask
somebody to put an external link on
theirs you might want to be open-minded
and make sure that you're are able and
willing to put an external link on your
blog post or website pointing to their
content that's how the web works
especially if the contents of quality
relevant and of good nature okay so
let's move on and finish up with the
do's and don'ts of seo so we talked a
lot about
why seo what is seo you know how do we
rank for seo
what is on page seo what is off page seo
and so
let's just wrap up with some of the
things you again want to do to rank your
page for a particular keyword and some
of the things you don't want to do so
the first thing on the list is optimize
for white hat techniques and what i mean
for
opting in for white hat techniques is
basically everything i just mentioned
today you want to do keyword research
you want to choose a natural language
processing form format so you could
choose keywords that are going to be
relevant natural to the content and you
don't want to opt for black cat
techniques and blad hat techniques are
probably not even worth going into
detail but one example is choosing a
keyword arbitrarily like say digital
marketing and just stuffing that keyword
into the content so that's probably not
something you want to do because again
it's not going to be good for the end
user so stay away from black hat and
focus on some of the techniques we
talked about in today's presentation the
other do we want to do is get backlinks
from relevant sites so that's off-page
seo again it's what i mentioned earlier
it's about linking your quality content
to another person's website that also
has quality content we don't want to
have a backlink from an irrelevant site
why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then google
is going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore you know we're
not going to look at you in the same way
as if you were on a quality website we
do want to use our keywords naturally
because title tags are what people see
first on organic search but you don't
want to use the same title tag on every
page of your website so we want to stay
away from doing that so you want to have
a unique title tag
for every web page on your website and
ideally what does that mean that means
using our keyword research to choose one
or two keywords per page and optimizing
your web page for those one to two
keywords so you ideally what you want to
do is have one to two different keywords
for every page on your website we
definitely definitely definitely want to
write engaging content so the content
should be engaging remember user
experience we want users to stay on our
website we want them to enjoy the
content that they're reading and we want
them to go from one page to another
naturally we definitely don't want to
leverage or plagiarize or just copy
content from others websites because
it's not one probably going to be
relevant to what you're writing about
two it's duplicate content and it's
somebody else's so that's a black cat
technique we want to stay away from i
can't emphasize this enough we need to
do keyword research first before you do
anything else you need to find relevant
keywords and not only that you need to
understand the volume and the
competition for each of those keywords
okay you don't want to choose a keyword
that has low volume high competition you
want to choose a keyword that has high
volume low competition but above all you
want to choose keywords that are
relevant to your content we want to
avoid keyword stuffing so don't take a
keyword and just stuff it everywhere on
the page it's not going to be natural
and google's going to be able to pick up
on that so we want to maintain some
level of quality with our content and
quality with the keywords that we choose
so reminder when you have quality
content it's always going to link
internally to another page on your
website with quality content but it's
got to be natural and don't just build
site-wide backlinks meaning don't just
have an internal link to the home page
or don't have every page on your website
linking to just one page so internal
linking should be natural naturally
linking from one page to another not
only does it help google understand
and crawl all the web pages on your
website but it's good for the end user
it's good user experience and certainly
last but something i didn't talk about
does take time to rank your content so
remember the process you're going to
write your content you're going to
choose keywords you're going to change
the elements on that page for those
keywords and all the while you're going
to make sure google can crawl that
content and when they crawl they're
going to index it the process takes time
especially if you choose a keyword
that's competitive so just be patient if
you have quality content and you've
optimized for on-page seo and off-page
seo then you will rank for that keyword
and then make sure your website's
user-friendly and mobile friendly so we
talked about responsive content earlier
so remember most users today start the
process of search on mobile so we want
to make sure your websites are mobile
friendly well to get this conversation
started
here's a preview of what matt will be
talking about today keyword research and
search trends
seo friendly copywriting content
optimization website and landing page
optimization content trends analytics
and of course we'll be answering your
questions throughout so feel free to
chime in so with that i would just like
to
hand the mic over
for a bit here to to matt so take it
away mr bailey all right well thank you
dan and as you can tell by the agenda it
seems to be content heavy
and that is certainly uh without an
accident there that
if you've been in seo for any length of
time you can see where things are moving
in the digital marketing industry
or social media content marketing those
types of things
and so
the role of the seo is becoming more
critical than ever in being that
connection
from what are people searching for
and then
what do we publish seo is that critical
link between the research and the
development of content and that is only
going to increase more and more over the
next few years so that's why there's a
little bit more emphasis on that content
side that you'll see there
but just
you know a little bit more in detail on
that that the role of seo
has primarily been as that the first
line of understanding what the search
engine is doing what do they require
what are the new technologies coming out
of search and what are the trends coming
from search
how is google changing results
so seos first and foremost are on those
front lines of
seeing what especially google google is
pushing the the envelope more than
anybody and they're testing more things
and so understanding
what is google doing what are the
implications of it uh is this just a
test or are we moving what's the bigger
picture of what they're attempting to do
and
so understanding
that role there of being that early
predictor of what's going on with google
and then being able to translate that
inside your organization or inside your
agency
that is really becoming part of
you know the the representative role of
the search engine optimizer is
understanding here's what's happening
and here's how we're supposed to react
to it
at the very base level it's
understanding those keywords it's
understanding
what are people searching for
and what is their intent
and how do we then apply that into our
content strategy
so that has been really kind of the
foundational part of what an seo does
but it's also going to
be a little bit larger into looking at
the larger trends of what is google
attempting to do what are the
implications and how do we respond to
that
now of course
with part of that keyword research is
understanding the long-term trends uh
over a year two years three years
because if something has a trend and
it's predictable
well then that's something you can bring
into your organization
because i i love to say if it's
predictable it's monetizable you can
make money off it if you know that it's
going to happen every year because you
can prepare for it you can help your
organization prepare for those increases
in traffic especially if you're able to
tie those trends into specific events
if you can come up with causality what
causes those to happen how do we react
to it how can we develop that and how
can we incorporate that into our
strategy again that is
more of a planning and prospecting
work that a search engine optimizer
would do
and those
skills of doing keyword research and
understanding the long-term view of
keyword research of trends throughout
the year
creating those connections
that is a valuable skill which is only
going to increase
and of course
those keywords are important for
anyone in a marketing field or also
customer service we've seen more and
more
of this
cross-marketing view across an
organization where marketing is getting
more involved in customer service
they're getting more involved in loyalty
they're getting more involved in
many different aspects of nurturing
customers the customer experience
and so
whenever you're planning any of these
things for social media and what are we
doing with social media are we educating
are we rewarding are we trying to look
for new customers
well all of that requires content that
content is going to have to be
researched as to when do we talk about
certain things and how do we talk about
certain things
keyword research gives you that agenda
it keyword research tells you when
people search for certain content and
also the associated words that they have
and so
that applies to your content marketing
your social media marketing it also
applies to when
people become customers and if you do
any amount of
crm marketing email marketing or email
automation or even triggered your
keyword research can help in developing
the content that will be in those emails
because you'll have done the research
and find out what do people want
after they make a decision after they
purchase a product what are the needs
that they have what is the information
need that they have
and how do we write towards that so
again seo is influencing the content
that is generated by the entire
organization in nearly all
communications
this gets back to seeing the trends that
are happening within the search engine
and you've probably seen this lately i
love this example here so if i want to
make a latte and i type that into google
this is what's interesting the answer to
my question is at the top of the page
now without even going to the website
i can have my answer
for the question
and now there's a couple implications to
this
yes it's great we can be at the top of
the rankings we can have our answer
there
but if the answer completely answers the
searcher's question
it doesn't generate a page view they
don't see much of our brand
they aren't in
really they aren't engaging with us at
all they're engaging with google
and so
this gets to the point of how do you
then bring this to the organization as
far as a strategic view of this how do
we approach it how does this change what
we do with our website or with our
content
you can also see here that
people are asking different questions
and this gets to the copywriting of the
website are you generating content that
answers questions because this is where
google is pooling this information as
well as pulling the related questions
that come from that type of content
this also is critical because this then
leads into voice search
and so if you've got a home assistant uh
you use any of the phone assistance or
hey guess what this is coming in cars
that you will have a voice assistant in
cars and your search result will be read
back to you
and this is
the beginning stages of that that if you
have a question or a search you would
speak your search and then the first
result would be read back to you and as
you can see it's not coming from the
site it's coming from google so this is
where again we sit down we look at the
strategy what are we trying to do
what is our strategy as far as
visibility in the search results
and
what's going to happen and what's
happening now with this is you could be
answering people's questions and never
knowing it
simply based because google is
delivering the result they're not going
to your site now the possibility of them
going to your site exists
but as more voice searches are being
generated
google is going to deliver a result that
doesn't require a click through because
it's all happening through audio
so hopefully this uh doesn't uh
all the changes in seo i would say over
the past uh
15 years have been largely external
driven by google uh as google has taken
away keywords taken away uh keywords and
analytics uh done numerous things here
that have caused seos to have to react
uh and again this is one of those
changes uh that causes us to sit and
figure out how are we going to deal with
this change we have some questions
already one of which is google's not
spending so much time focusing on
keywords specifically even though
they're still important where do you
suggest that marketers look for keywords
oh i think the the typical
keyword research tools are still very
viable in fact you'll probably get
better information out of keyword tools
than you will google's keyword tool
google has been combining
keyword concepts under a single
keyword so for example um a great one
that uh we've seen in the keyword
research uh pool table and pool tables
plural and singular
google puts that all under pool table
whereas anyone who
you know does any amount of e-commerce
can tell you there was a world of
difference between people that search
for plural and singular
before the the changes in keywords i
could tell you with numerous sites that
we had that if people searched with the
singular
version
uh they were about three to five times
more likely to purchase than if they
searched for the plural version
the plural version meant that they were
shopping the singular version
pointed to they were ready to make a
decision
so
google won't show you the data however
between the plural and singular for pool
tables
other keyword research tools however
will show you that
so
even though
you know
even though it's getting more difficult
with the keywords from a marketing
standpoint
absolutely still do your keyword
research write as if you would
uh
you know
you're gonna have to do additional
research maybe you know customer
research
uh you know face to face
asking them to describe how they would
search or what they were looking for or
what problem you solved
because you're going to need a wider
variety of input for keywords
yeah and if you have any way to look
into your competitors i know there are
some tools that lets you let you do that
you can see what uh your competitors are
or at least in their or their sem you
can learn a lot yes
because
you can you can tell a lot by what's a
valuable keyword by learning what your
competitors are paying for
and
uh also check your checker analytics to
see how people are actually finding you
uh what's interesting is how is uh how
is right i know right brain is one of
the most influential parts of google now
and i know that that's basically a
lumping instead of creating separate
pages for
plurals and
other iterations of words rankbrain is
sort of
including all of that and looking for
those words in general content is that
how is rankbrain affecting
search terms and
seo with just keywords
um
you know it's really trying to learn
more of
what exactly do people want
uh from an intentional standpoint
uh so
trying to put together
uh
unfamiliar searches or unfamiliar
phrasings or i think i read the other
day
um i'm trying to think whose name it was
but it was oh matthew mcconaughey
his name in one week had
like 8 000 misspelled variations
so
somehow
you know
a search engine has to figure out over 8
000 misspellings who did you mean you
know who are you trying to figure out um
you know so it's it's trying to figure
out the intent and deliver the right
result and
you know i think part of this is yes
they don't want seos to be focusing on
individual words
um
and by taking away all that data
you know in a way they have accomplished
that
so
you know what rankbrain is attempting to
do is trying to tie those things
together of
how do we figure out now they're looking
at the minutiae of the difference of
words but they do not want to show it to
us
right so it's not a whole lot you can do
it it's just
you know it's from their standpoint the
best thing you can do is just continue
to write
great content that people want
that answers their questions using a
variety of
using a variety of words that explain
uh you know a great example is you know
if you're writing an article uh you know
baseball season started here in the u.s
if you're writing an article about
baseball you're going to use words like
umpire like balls strikes bats teams
those are all words that build
context and so
they're going to count just as much as
the primary term baseball and in fact
google's going to look for all those
other terms
that that build that context
and so it's it's not so much that single
word anymore it's that variety of
i would call those second tier words
that support the context of what you're
writing about
rows are coming more into play
yeah and and of course putting that in a
and a more natural language type of uh
type of phraseology in your content
rather than yes the old days of keywords
you know how many keywords can we stuff
in the first paragraph uh what's the
optimum number of words in the in the
meta tag blah blah blah
i mean because now it really
if it looks like you're i mean these
google's been penalizing people for
doing stuff like that for years but now
especially with rank brain
the more you can do to look to write
like a conversation that people are
actually thinking and asking about i'm
sure is a better way they've always
wanted that i mean that has always been
google's goal from the beginning they
have told us to write for humans
uh
but the problem has been it you know
there are a lot of seos there that would
rather take the formulaic approach
and
you know why should i write for humans
i'm just trying to get people to my site
you know i wouldn't they're gonna buy uh
and so they you know try to reverse
engineer everything to come up with this
formula
of use this keyword this many times in
this part of the page and
you know
whereas google has always said write for
humans first and so by taking away some
of those
other options or taking away the
keywords
it's really guided the industry to do
what they wanted to do and honestly i
think it's
it's a good thing
because the quality of content has to
increase it has to get better uh
and that is one way that they've
enforced that what exactly what they
they've imposed their will
on on people who desire to have better
rankings right
the uh i just have one one more question
that people a lot of people are asking
if you have any specific recommendations
for for keyword research tools before we
wow
there are a lot of them um so if you've
got like
raven or
um
trying to think what are some of the
others raven seo tools
um there's one right on the edge of my
tongue
tracker still word tracker yeah um
oh
i've got a list of them somewhere here
you could you can yeah we could figure
that out
yeah just look just google out and look
at some of the keyword research tools um
there are a lot of them many of them
offer free trials and so
yeah just get in do the free trial take
a look at what's there
um
yeah yeah some come with full service
site management you may not want all
that you may you may want that others
are more stand-alone independent they
just do keyword research
never choose a keyword research tool
that
doesn't show up at least on page 10 of
the serps
[Laughter]
but yeah and and honestly the more you
do keyword research i i have always felt
this way and it's it's the more you do
keyword research
the better equipped you are to do your
job
uh and and by that it's dissecting the
keywords what are people looking for
what are the trends what do they
associate
what are
uh the people places and things
so as you're looking at the keywords
you're not so much looking to see the
volume that someone searched for you
know buy uh you know buy a pink car
that's that's a great you know that's
good but they talked about cars they
talked about buying and they talked
about color that's more what we're
looking for is let's start slicing and
dicing this down
what words are they associating what
colors what
uh
features and
by understanding the breadth
of how people search and the questions
they have it helps you write better
content because now you understand not
just optimizing for one word
people have questions across an entire
breadth of type style color uh place uh
city uh
you know all these types of things and
so that's really what i challenge people
to get out of keyword research is
understanding
the full breadth of what people want
rather than just a single word or a
single phrase
this gets into copywriting you see like
i said when you when you get into
you know are people looking for colors
are they people looking for locations
sizes i want to understand the breadth
of what they're talking about and that
helps me become a better copywriter i
can understand intent if i know the
questions that they have
then we can write answers
and so
you know i want to see how people are
searching you know a great example is is
now we've seen searches increasing for
people searching for you know the best
or the top rated or
uh the reviews i think is yeah
oh yeah for me uh people are actually
typing in what is the best car for me
and i think what they're doing
essentially is is directly asking google
you know based on the two million things
you know about me who would be the best
car for me
um so people are looking for more
personalized information
uh so what you can do is get into the
you know the how to the why
the
you know what it means all these
different
cues that people are giving in their key
phrases
develop your content to answer those
questions
yeah i had actually seen a statistic
that 82 of smartphone users use
and this is for businesses
looking for businesses used specifically
the term near me after their search so
even geographically
i don't know if that's anything you can
include in the content but uh well no
you know it's it's blows my mind because
um if they're on their smartphone
they're automatically going to get
results near them
that that's kind of interesting so
it's more of a cue for google than it is
for a website because to use that phrase
and any of your
optimization really wouldn't make a lot
of sense
uh
because you don't know who's near you
um and if anything especially on a
mobile search google is pretty much
going to ignore that near me because
you're going to get the results near
where you are anyway
yeah so yeah getting into the search
data people search for what they need
they
they figure out what they're looking for
but now here is where the role of the
seo is going to come in organizationally
is that when you have people writing
content generating content for content
marketing for social media uh especially
if you're working with
you know like a publisher who is
constantly developing content
now you need to help them come up with
ways to measure success
and also to motivate them to implement
seo tactics in their writing
so rather than
developing catchy headlines
that may have a double meaning that may
not play well in search
you need to help copywriters understand
that well your headline while that might
look great on print
in search it's actually going to cause a
problem and so you turn into an educator
for your content developers uh you're
teaching them what works well what's
going to click well what's going to look
well in the search engines versus what
might be confusing
also
uh
it's also helping them to understand you
know a great example of this um
before i move on someone
um
gave me a great example is they were
writing an article about holiday time
travel and that was the title of the
article that they put out there and they
couldn't figure out why this article was
consistently getting
hundreds or thousands of visits a month
well after it was published and when we
went back and started looking at some of
the rankings and some of the keywords
and things like that we found out that
the article was ranking really well for
time travel
uh even though the headline was holiday
time travel
so it's helping your writers understand
um you know
what makes a good title uh but then also
one thing that i worked with one
publisher and one of the things we did
to motivate the writers
was to develop like a a leaderboard of
whose content is generating the most
visits
uh and not only that whose content is
generating the most new visits to the
website uh and then you can carry that
through to
you know for how for different writers
how many visits or views have you
generated in a month or over the past
six months how much has your content
performed compared to other content and
you can carry this all the way out to
you know which writers had the highest
amount of ad clicks uh in their
articles uh which articles uh led to
people to
uh
subscribe again or you know even get
into customer lifetime value there's so
many things that you could implement so
from an seo standpoint you understand
already how to look at the success of
game rankings and what it generates in
terms of page views click throughs time
on site uh click depth uh
you know all those types of things that
you can then develop into helping others
in the organization who publish content
start to measure the impact of their
writing
organizationally and then especially if
you're able to tie that to a financial
implication
that shows that this is what it's
contributing towards the business in
terms of revenue
then you become the all-around hero
because you're able to help others
tie revenue to activity
that's great we have someone asking can
this backfire on you for example if
you're starting every headline with
one weird this one weird trick dot dot
dot
um
if you find that you have a lot of
if your bounce rate immediately starts
going up yeah you have because if you're
waiting for time travel or star wars or
something
that everyone's going to be looking for
then
could that actually negatively affect uh
how google sees you if it's if you have
all these bounce rates they might see
you as
no longer being relevant absolutely and
it's not just google with the bounce
rate it damages your brand it damages
your credibility i mean it's it's click
bait and
i mean
it doesn't take long for people to
realize clickbait is clickbait
you can just look at some of the data
but yeah i mean
when you see
articles or headlines that are
obvious click bait people are you know
you get caught a couple of times you get
fooled a couple of times
it's not always going to work and so
this gets to
you know
how are you positioning your brand
are you positioning your brand as a
trustworthy source of information that
answers people's questions are you
positioning your brand as we give people
what they need what they want
uh
or are you fooling them
to click on an article based on what's
popular right now
uh you know there's a couple questions
that get to how the brand wants to be
perceived in the marketplace
based on tactics like that
but great question great question
because
clickbait is powerful um but you've got
to ask yourself are we giving people
what they want or are we fooling them
into it and how will that reflect on the
brand
right
uh from another keyword standpoint
one thing that i found is very valuable
to do is go out and look and see how
people are searching for the brand and
content associations they make with that
brand uh now this can also get into
other areas you may find that there's
some crossover uh where
there's another company with a similar
brand name uh and so this will help you
understand a little bit more if you get
some of that crossover traffic but also
from a pr standpoint
do people associate content or ideas
with your brand that you would rather
this will help you become aware of
something that might be out there that
may not be getting picked up uh so i i
enjoy doing these kinds of searches
because i want to know what other words
associations are people making with the
brand right that you may need to deal
with
yeah and also look at your analytics and
what is linked in your crm to see uh how
people actually converted because if you
have some long tail keywords in there
that would be good to generate content
on uh that your best customers are
finding you through that can be super
valuable and at least compensate for
having some super clickbaity
words
in there accidentally what's interesting
is that people people are are a few
people are really wanting to hone in on
this uh
back track a bit here too
ways to capitalize on certain things
that um
i know people are looking for quick
answers to rank high on google uh but
the question keeps coming up about for
example if there are any ways why
you could restructure your content to
capitalize on things like
near me like should you put in your
opening paragraph you know if you're
looking for a near uh
that's that's almost i i personally
would would shrink from doing that
because i know that that's something
that that seems that a google
i don't want to put words in your mouth
it seems like hey google is already
doing that automatically based on if
you're searching mobile but two
if
pretty soon they're going to catch up to
people putting
best and near me and because that's the
other question like should i should i
use terms that are
when i when i see the results of most
commonly searched terms and mobile
should i put those in my
in my copy
so
what do you say about that like are
there ways to that you can legitimately
without being uh penalized capitalism
yeah well
okay if you're legitimately publishing
an article that is well researched
comparing
different products and you title it best
pet food products or something like that
that's a legitimate
case i have no problem with that do your
homework and create something of value
and
it will do well
if it's good content that people like
now the the near me
is
a bit more sketchy because even though
you may put on your website something
about near you or near me
uh
not everyone who visits your website
remember this is more of a mobile
uh phenomenon these are people on their
phone looking for something near them a
drugstore
a car wash uh you know something like
that a restaurant
and
that's being computed based on distance
based on
uh you know past preferences things like
that
so it has nothing to do with the content
of your website what i would work on
more is your local business listing in
google
and
developing
more reviews for your business
and
working with that
uh listing to
add more pictures like i said reviews uh
they have a function there now where you
can add promotions the more you develop
that google listing that will do a
hundred times more to increase your
visibility when someone is looking for
something near them and they are near
you
than adding words to your website
great would that sound smart
i may come across a bit forcefully on
some of these things
uh mainly because i it's it's
it has never bothered me when people out
and out try to
fool google with some really intelligent
things uh i
somewhat tend to admire it uh but when
people try to fool google with what i
would call amateurish things that are
poorly executed
that's where i you know that's where i
get
i get a little ticked off at that
because it's
it create a quality experience that's
what people want
quality experience uh and and that's
really what it gets down to when you
know we with content marketing you're
answering people's questions and so
as people are generating that content
you're also sending them back to the
site you're sending them back to get
answers to register to do things like
that so all those web pages from the
content marketing that they're linking
to they need to be optimized for your
inbound strategy
and what's interesting is also from a
paid search standpoint the landing page
from paid search you know it needs to be
optimized just like any other page
that's part of the quality score
algorithm does the landing page reflect
the paid search headline does it also
contain the keyword that you're bidding
on so
you've got to look at how people are
developing their landing pages
internally and maybe you can contribute
to that as well in helping improve the
quality score because the optimization
of that landing page is very similar
where i see
employment and industry trends now this
is interesting because talking with the
director of omcp
and some of the surveys he's been doing
of hiring managers hr managers and
technology
uh
or in marketing across the across the
the globe here one of the things that he
has seen is there is becoming more
demand
of people who can manage the entire tech
marketing stack
not the single channel specialists
because more and more automation is
handling that
uh more and more you know and this is
where we're going to see the entrance of
ai and machine learning is adjusting
your paid search campaign
with those minute
methods of increasing your click-through
rate uh you know it's going to be
managing those bids so eventually you're
just going to focus more on the content
and eventually ai's going to take over
the content
so
the demand is for
who were the single channel specialists
of seo paid search social to move into
understanding the entire omnichannel
digital marketing
and can run and can change and can make
recommendations across the board for the
entire stack of digital marketing
this is where we're seeing more of the
employment trends uh going as well as
the skills demand
is
getting away from that single hard skill
to understanding the entire campaign
uh and that's going to go into all
different types of things that's going
to include email crm social display
and seos i think are probably
very well positioned in all of these
things
because of the foundation of keywords
the foundation of keywords and
understanding intent and then developing
content that answers those questions
that's needed in email it's needed in
automation it's needed in social and
display you know especially in the crm
automation is someone has to write the
content that needs to be automated and
so again this then gets into
looking at the trends uh because
automation you not only need to write
the content but you need to
then plan the content when is it sent
when is this completed when is this done
and so understanding the
the sales cycles and how long they go
and when people need certain information
at what times it takes that planning
strategy of being able to do that
and i think seos are well positioned to
understand that full stack of marketing
and the implications as well as the
management of it
and then we get to analytics uh this is
my favorite
um
so as an seo or if you're taking on more
of the the omni channel burden here uh
you've got to develop those measurements
that show how effective
not only seo has been but now content
management content management is big
everyone is moving towards it it has
become a significant piece of strategy
however what is lacking in content
is the measurement how do we know that
this content piece that went out whether
it was a video uh whether it was an
infographic whether you know regardless
of what it was number one how do we
track performance number two how do we
know it affected anything
number three
what was the pathway where were we
driving people and what did we want them
to do and how successful was that and
then also from an attribution standpoint
did this lead to other things you know
where did this content piece or where
does this channel help us overall in
attribution in driving new leads or
nurturing people along the path and so
it's getting more than just getting you
know measuring clicks it's it's
measuring actual hard dollars that were
generated based off specific channels or
specific pieces of content uh and then
you know it's developing an
understanding of sales goals what did
the sales department need uh
information to enhance the crm so that
they can nurture people along in the
path
so it's more than just marketing it's
understanding that full scope that a
company has
yeah that's a it's an excellent point
and i think another thing to keep in
mind too is is use actual conversation
with your sales people
as a one of the few things it's funny
that that marketing and sales often are
their own little silos and
i i think one of the best things a
marketer can do is just go and talk to
your best salespeople and ask them
what
why are people buying us
what are the what are they what are the
questions they are asking you to answer
i think that can be a because those
questions
since they're legitimately people that
are that are engaging with your sales
people and making purchases i think
those are the most valuable questions
you can answer in your copy oh
absolutely i mean
short of talking to a customer talking
to your sales department is the best way
to get information
um it now my
before i got into seo i was in sales i
took sales training and and you know
dealt directly with people so it kind of
i had that uh
you know that view of things
but
i i'm amazed at how much people don't
interact with their sales department in
order to learn
uh you know what do people need how do
we answer their questions what you know
what do they respond to but then also
your sales people are the first in line
entering information into the crm
and when leads are created through your
marketing efforts
it'd be good to ask them what additional
information do you need that would make
a better lead
you know
there and there are many times where we
have changed the site
on the recommendation of the sales team
and
you know we we may not have it we didn't
improve conversions but we what we
improved were
the
the
the scenario through which the sales
call then came
after the conversion
and increased the close rate just based
on changing the landing page or the
thank you page after the registration
right and it's it's a good conversation
to start having with your sales field
too so that they know what kind of
questions to listen to because a lot of
times they're just not paying attention
you ask a sales person
they made the sale because i was a great
sales guy
but the more you the more you
work with them as a team and say that
hey you know to get them thinking about
actually listening to what the customers
are asking for and passing that on to
you
you know that of course will will help
lead attribution and and
all the things you said so yeah
definitely
don't forget the human element in seo
well and this gets to
you know this really gets to it
if the trend now is moving more towards
you know someone who can manage a full
stack it's also moving towards people
who understand how to align sales and
marketing goals
and beyond that it's not just you know
like the example i gave before it's not
just okay we increased the conversion
rate of our registration
okay that's great would how did that
contribute to revenue
but now it's understanding that there
are things that we can do
to increase a close rate
that don't always take place on the
website but it's a process
and so now we're analyzing processes
that can be done electronically
and then how do we create a better
revenue stream that way how do we make a
better nurture process
now we're getting into the effectiveness
of content and producing a result
rather than
just you know a conversion uh a sale or
a lead now we're looking at well how do
we make more money based out of this uh
and that's really it's that big picture
of understanding that
you know our job is not just to get
leads it's to create better
profitability which rewards everybody
so it's understanding those touch points
from content uh you know so as content
is being pushed out does it answer the
question does it lead people to the next
stage how quickly does it lead them
there uh can you measure influence from
your content and you know through depth
of visitor to the depth of the page that
they got to
and then again it's
the experience based on motivations
can you understand that can you
tie together what a customer was feeling
at a specific point through their
nurture stream uh or through this
process as i said if it's getting away
from more just stuff that happens on the
site it's communications throughout the
entire process the entire life cycle of
a customer that's all coming under
the the management really of the
marketing team right now is that entire
customer life cycle communication and
management
uh and finally this is something a trend
that i've been seeing as well in terms
of
jobs and hiring and also business
function
omcp did a survey at the beginning of
the year asking people where they spent
the most amount of their time
and specifically an seo and seo managers
uh and
uh
anyone who dealt with seo
nearly 40 percent of their time was
spent
uh presenting their research
presenting strategy
as well as
uh
as well as explaining their the
reasoning for that strategy
and so seos you need to become a lot
more comfortable in front of people
presenting your findings making
recommendations presenting opportunities
trends
and presenting it in a persuasive
format
that shows not a bunch of data charts
but shows how smart you are
in creating new revenue opportunities
for the company
and that is really where we see a lot of
things going are the presentation skills
are becoming part of the demand
for companies
when they're dealing with tech if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
keyword research so
what are we going to talk about when we
talk about keyword research we're going
to talk about why we would do keyword
research for seo we're going to talk
about the types of keywords that we need
to research we're going to talk about
some methodologies best practices on how
to do keyword research some alternate
suggestions we're going to talk about
keyword clustering and then we're going
to talk about some tools that you can
use to do your keyword research so let's
start with the why we would do keyword
research so jessie is planning to
publish a blog of pizza recipes so
she was doing pizza recipes step by step
piece of recipes with sausage homemade
pizza toppings pizza dough recipes thin
crust pizzas she's doing a lot of
different topics on pizza recipes well
what jesse needs to do is understand
what's going to drive traffic to these
blog posts if she's writing about you
know different topics around pizza
recipes so
she's unsure how
these blogs are going to drive traffic
so she really needs to
understand that hey you need to choose
the right keywords to drive traffic so
the question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keywords to use maybe
maybe not so you need to take uh care
and choosing the key words to align with
your content so that's really the idea
why we would do keyword research because
some of the issues with keywords that
are poorly chosen are they could have
slow search volume for example you may
choose a keyboard that just a lot of
people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very broad or
popular it could be very competitive and
take you a long time to be found for
that keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyboard that
isn't aligned with your content or you
can choose keywords but use them
incorrectly with your content so these
are some of the issues that you can
encounter if you just go about choosing
keywords randomly without due diligence
without the proper research so low
search volume will lead to less traffic
high competition you may not even rank
at all okay if somebody finds you
for a keyword that's not relevant to the
topic they're just going to leave the
page and if you're not using the right
keywords and or if you are using the
right keywords and not using them
correctly in the content then your pages
may not even be found in organic search
so you really have to take care in
choosing keywords to me that's the most
important step with seo is keyword
research so we're going to talk about
the types of keyword research then so we
have short tail keywords and we have
long tail keywords so if you write a
blog post about pizza recipes well what
are you going to choose a short tail or
long tail so let's talk about short tail
keywords first so short tail keywords
are keywords that are usually three
keywords and a phrase or shorter in some
cases it may be two keywords in a phrase
or shorter so short term keywords
usually have high search volume which
means likely means higher competition
but what it also means it could be
lower conversions because short tail
keywords like for example pizza recipes
could be considered a short tail keyword
but maybe somebody's looking for
homemade pizza recipes or pizza recipes
from their favorite italian restaurant
so
short-term keywords may not be as
relevant so if we compare with long-tail
keywords chances are you're going to
have lower competition that's one of the
benefits but you're also going to have
lower search volume but with longer tail
keywords the keyword is probably going
to be more relevant with the content
you're writing about so therefore the
conversion rate's likely going to be
higher so that's really the difference
between short-term keywords and long
tail keywords if you want to look it
simplistically short tail keywords are
broad in nature it's going to capture a
lot of eyeballs but those eyeballs may
look at your content as not relevant
versus long tail keywords that may be
very relevant but not as many eyeballs
on them so short tail keywords the
characteristics they're not as specific
usually they're less than three words
they have high search volume and high
competition so if you just choose pizza
recipes could take you a while
to rank for that keyword but when you
rank you're going to get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the
keyword is broad in nature so pizza
recipes is a short tail keyword that may
not be exactly what you're writing about
in your blog post so it may draw a lot
of traffic but the traffic may not do
anything so the longer tail keywords are
very specific they consist of more than
three words in the search query they
have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long ticket
keyword is probably going to be greater
because not many other websites are
trying to rank for that same keyword and
so the benefit of that is if you have
let's just say homemade pizza recipes
with mushrooms that's a long tail
keyword but if somebody's looking for
that type of pizza recipe then you know
you're gonna track the right traffic and
chances are that traffic is going to
engage or convert based on the type of
conversion you have in place so example
would be homemade pizza dough recipes
that be another example more than three
key words in the phrase very specific
we're talking about homemade pizza dough
recipes so we're not talking about just
pizza recipes so it's a little bit more
specific in nature longer tail so these
keywords are used for targeted pages
including blog posts if you're writing a
blog post specifically about pizza
recipes with homemade dough then this is
the keyword you likely would want to use
versus just pizza recipes so let's look
at an example between a short tail
keyword and a long tail keyword and to
accentuate the differences we're going
to use google's keyword planner tool so
google's keyword planner tool is located
in google ads the google ads platform
and when you're in the google ads
platform you can simply click on tools
and then keyword planner and so what
keyword planner allows us to do is get a
sense of the type of volume that a
particular keyword has so what google's
keyword planner does is they show you
the average monthly searches this is the
average monthly search volume of a
keyword over the past 12 months and so
in this example we're going to choose
pizza recipes and homemade pizza dough
recipes so one short tail and one long
tail so we enter those keywords in we're
going to click get results and what
google's going to do is it's going to
show us the volume of those keywords so
for pizza recipe we could see the
average monthly search volume is 33 100
for pizza recipe so note that pizza
recipe and pizza recipes are closely
related keywords and so what google does
is they consider that a close variance
so meaning if somebody ties some piece
of recipe then they're also in google's
eyes looking for pizza recipes so it's a
close variance and so for the keyword
pizza recipe which is short tail we
could see on average over the past 12
months this keyword received 33
100 queries and so if we hover over the
graph we could see basically the volume
the average volume per month so here i
could see for this particular keyword
here the volume per month is 33 1000 and
then i can see the actual volume over
the past 12 months and then for the long
tail keyword i can see homemade pizza
dough recipe again close variance
homemade pizza dough recipes i can see
over the past 12 months what the search
volume is for this on average is 2400
but i could see here in december the
volume went up to 3600. but for example
in may it was 1900 so it's gonna
fluctuate a bit over the past 12 months
but on average it's about 2400. so
shorter tail a lot more volume longer
tail not as much volume but nonetheless
there is volume here and so these are
the difference between a short tail and
a longer tail and so what google's
keyword planner also does is allow us to
get a sense of what the competition is
and so here i can see the competition is
low for both of these keywords fair
enough so we now know that if we want to
optimize or choose the keyword homemade
pizza dough recipe for our blog post we
know for ranked on page one of google
even in the top spot we can expect about
2 400 search queries for that keyword
now whether you get all 2 400 clicks for
that keyword remains to be seen chances
are you're not going to get all 2400
you're going to get a lion's share of
those clicks but you're going to at
least get some volume on it so even the
longer take keywords have a lot of
promise because there is some search
volume here for this keyword how to do a
proper keyword research so we looked at
google's keyword planner tool in google
ads and we typed in two keywords and we
were able to get a sense of what the
average volume is so we definitely want
to choose keywords based on the
following factors we want to choose it
based on search volume search volume is
a good indicator of the potential
traffic we can obtain so again for the
keyword homemade pizza dough recipe we
know that it averages 2 400 a month in
search volume again we may not get all 2
400 but are we gonna get a line share
that we also need to look at competition
and so google's keyword planner gives us
a high medium or low in terms of the
competition but if you're somebody who
wants to get a better sense of what the
competition is and you should because
competition is a key component in
choosing keywords and so what i want to
do is get a sense of how many people are
actually optimizing for that keyword so
google's keyword planner tool is going
to give me a low medium high really what
i want to do is get a better sense of
that numerically so what i can do is go
into google search and i could type in
pizza recipes and i could see there's
about 1 billion results that's a lot of
results however that means that every
potential web page out there on the
internet that mentions pizza recipes is
going to be included in this number here
and so i want to get a better sense of
who's optimizing for pizza recipes so
i'm going to put in the all entitle
syntax and so what that is going to ask
google to do is tell me all the websites
that have pizza recipes the keyword
pizza recipes in the title tag so if i
do all in title colon space then pizza
recipes my result drops down to 336 000
so what that tells me is that there are
336
000 results with the keyword pizza
recipes in the title tag now if i want
to focus in on my other keyword if i
choose uh my other keyword was a longer
tail keyword homemade pizza dough recipe
so if i type that keyword in the
homemade pizza dough recipe or recipes
remember close variance and i just click
enter or type the keyword in and hit my
enter key i'm going to get 35 million
results but again is that really an
indicator of the type of competition i
have no because every listing that
matches homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so i'm going to type in my all
in title colon space and then i'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and i get
2
160 different results so here i can see
the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites and web pages that have that
keyword in the title tag so now i have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about seo
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for seo and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close variance here is
pizza recipe what was the volume well we
know the volume was 33 100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 683 thousand so i'm going
to type in 683
000. what was our next keyword well it
was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes
so if i go back for this particular
keyword is 2400. so i'm gonna put 2400
in under my volume column and then what
was my competition well my competition
was i typed that keyword back in
2160. so i'm going to put
2160. so now i have an idea of what kind
of volume and what kind of competition i
have now you want to do this for a
number of different keywords and when
you do it for number keywords what you
do want to do is obviously choose a
relevant keyword that has high volume
and low competition so another way of
saying it is the volume or ratio of
volume to competition and so basically
what we could do is take volume divided
by competition if i make that a
percentage i can see it's 0.35
is the ratio between volume and
competition if i do the same for my
longer tail keyword 2400 divided by 2160
i can see that 111
so this just kind of proves the point
that yeah i'm still going to get some
volume but i have a better chance of
ranking for this longer teal keyword
homemade pizza dough recipes so you want
to be able to do that for a number of
keywords and examine the volume the
competition and the ratio between volume
and competition for your themed keywords
in this case pizza recipes so relevancy
you want to choose keywords that are
very relevant to the content that you're
writing and then again commercial intent
what keywords are going to drive more
conversions and revenue for the business
so when we talk about commercial intent
we're talking about you know are you
choosing keywords that are going to get
somebody to do what you want them to do
so we could say
you know download pizza dough recipes so
if somebody's typing in the keyword
download pizza dough recipes then
chances are they're going to find you
come to your site and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the keyword is it going to
help you drive conversions and revenue
if you're an e-commerce site so search
volume is the average monthly search
volume made for a particular keyword and
phrase
so we can get that number using google's
keyword planner tool in the google ads
platform we want to target keywords with
high search volume that will help bring
traffic to the website we want volume
but we want to take into account
seasonality as well so that's where the
google's keyword planner tool comes in
place because if we go back again we can
just hover over and we can get a sense
of any particular trend going on or
seasonality so for example if i saw
large growth in the winter months and
not much volume growth in the summer
months then that might indicate to me
that this keyword is more popular during
the winter time so pay attention to the
graphs that you know the keyword planner
tool gives you use them to your
advantage to take into account
seasonality so a good example would be
funny halloween costumes well we know
that for halloween you're going to have
a spike probably towards the end of
september all the way through october
and then it's going to drop after
october 31st which is halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza recipes during maybe the summer
months versus the winter months so pay
attention to seasonality it will affect
search volume so competition based on
our example it's one of the most
important key metrics you don't want to
choose a keyword that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
google's keyword planner tool to find
the volume we use the all in title
syntax to find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but always relevancy always
trumps ratio so always go with a keyword
that is going to be relevant to your
content don't choose a keyword that's
not relevant if you choose a keyword
that's not relevant it's not going to
bode well for user engagement so the
difficulty of a keyword ranges from 0 to
100 in google's keyword tool so it's
going to be easy it's going to be medium
it's going to be hard but my
recommendation is also to get the
numerical factor and that's the all in
title syntax and again relevancy is what
drives the traffic to your website and
keep the traffic there on your website
and also not only will keep the traffic
on your website but hopefully get that
traffic to engage and convert so that's
the key about relevancy you always want
to choose keywords that are relevant to
your content even if it's sacrificing
volume relevancy again trumps volume and
competition so always choose relevant
keywords first so when you do that
you're always almost guaranteeing that
at some point somebody's gonna find your
content because somebody out there might
be looking for it and if they do you're
gonna get found and then the
engagement's gonna be better so
understand your business find keywords
that are relevant to your business and
then focus on those keywords
that'll help you with getting the right
traffic to your site always keep in mind
the commercial intent so these keywords
are more specific and result in
conversion rate for example buying is a
good commercial intent keyword so if you
really want somebody to come to your
website and buy then focus on those
types of keywords in the case of the
pizza recipes maybe its download could
be our commercial intent keyword again
there may be low search volume but those
are the type of keywords you want to
focus on because that's the type of
traffic you want to drive to your site
so some other examples are commercial
intent keywords or discount deal your
coupon shipping you don't be afraid to
use some of these keywords as part of
your longer tail keyword phrase again
the volume may not be high but the
traffic quality is probably going to be
better so keyword research is the
foundation for seo so if you have chosen
your keywords properly then if you do
get ranked for those keywords then it's
going to lead to better engagement with
some conversions and so when we talk
about keywords we also want to talk
about our primary and secondary keyword
so every page should have at least a
primary keyword and then a second carry
keyword to work with so primary keywords
are really defining the nature of your
content the secondary keywords are
relevant to the primary keyword so why
do we choose a primary and secondary
keyword because you may choose a keyword
as a primary keyword that is relevant to
the content but may not necessarily rank
very high or have a lot of volume that
secondary keyword is also relevant to
the primary keyword but also relevant to
content and you may rank for that
secondary keyword so you always want to
go with two keywords versus just one
keyword you want to give your yourself a
chance to rank for at least two
different types of keywords of relevant
nature so for web page there can be
several secondary keywords but only one
primary keyword so your primary keyword
is always going to be relevant to your
content secondary keywords can be
relevant to the keyword but and you may
have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary in search okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if a primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
these secondary keywords are also
related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want to
do is go to cool google's keyword
planner tool and get an idea of the
volume for healthy diet plan and then
also the volume and competition for some
of these secondary keywords like healthy
diet for weight loss healthy diet food
low carb diet healthy meal plans and
diet plan weight loss so if i go in to
google's keyword planner and type those
keywords in i'm going to choose get
results and now here i could see healthy
diet plan keyword i'm focusing on is my
primary keyword has an average monthly
search volume of 9900
and then some of my secondary keywords
healthy diet foods diet plan weight loss
low carb diet you know google will give
me a number of different keywords to
work with so i'm going to look at the
search volume of those as well and so
ideally what i want to do is be able to
then look at the volume and then look at
the competition so healthy diet plan i
go into my keyword analysis here that's
my theme so that's my keyword what's my
volume for healthy diet plan
9900 what's my competition so my
competition is 74
700 and that's going to give me a ratio
of volume to competition of 13 so that's
what my contents about that's a
considered a short tail keyword because
it has a lot of competition and so my
ratio is 13
and what i want to do is i want to be
able to put these other secondary
keywords in here as well maybe even go a
little longer tail because i want to be
able to
find two key or at least two keywords i
want to be able to find my primary
keyword that's relevant to my content
and then i want to be able to find my
secondary keyword which is again related
to the primary keyword which is also
related to the content and so i want to
be able to choose two keywords basically
and i want to choose two keywords that
are relevant that have good ratio
between volume and competition so that's
the whole idea again on how to do
keyword research you want to be able to
find your keywords use the tools
available to you and get a sense of what
the volume is what the competition is
look at the ratio between the volume and
competition and then based on the
content choose that primary keyword and
then again based on the keyword you
chose choose some secondary keywords as
well because you want to be found for
not just one keyword but multiple
keywords okay let's look at some
alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account lsi
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like cora or reddit we can use
google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like reddit so there are
lots of suggestions that we can obtain
from various sources so let's start with
lsi keywords and lsi stands for latent
semantic insect indexing and so
basically what it is it's just keywords
that are linked to your primary keyword
and so when you're choosing keywords you
always want to choose that primary
keyword and then secondary keywords that
are similar to the primary keyword and
usually those are lsi or latent semantic
indexing type keywords so they're used
to drive relevant traffic to your page
so if you're focusing on one keyword we
want to have other keywords that are
similar to increase our visibility on
the search engine result pages so we
could find latent semantic indexing
right in search so if we use the term
healthy diet if we go to google search
for example if i type in healthy diet in
google search all i need to do is scroll
to the bottom of the page and i can see
searches related to healthy diet so
healthy diet menu healthy diet essay
what does a healthy diet look like
notice at the top google's also giving
me some other suggestions here so
they're saying low-fat diet veganism
gluten-free diet so there's lots of
different suggestions right in google
search bar so all of these are lsi
related keywords so if you're optimizing
a page for a healthy diet then you could
choose low-fat diet as a secondary
keyword you can use gluten-free diet as
a secondary keyword it really depends on
what the content is but you always want
to support your content with as much lsi
keywords as possible so you can be found
for as many different keywords as
possible in google search so it's
important because if you have a blog
that you know talks about python so how
do the search engines know if the
website python is about the programming
language or the snake so google for
example uses lsi keywords to understand
what the page is specifically focusing
on so if you're just focusing on python
and your content you want to support
that with lsi keywords and so that will
allow your web page to better
communicate with google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you could certainly
found for a feature snippet for example
maybe you know healthy diet recipes if i
type that in you can see here there's a
featured snippet so if i'm talking about
recipes that's a keyword i may want to
use and if i use that then google has an
opportunity to see what my contents
about and place my information at the
top in this featured snippet you can
also again see what some of the
questions are being asked what males are
good for weight loss what is a good
healthy diet plan all of these can be
keyword phrases that you can use so the
answers are right here in google so core
is a great platform because core is a
platform that people go and ask
questions and a community responds with
answers or responses to that particular
question or topic and so the great thing
about core is it's a good i it's a good
place for you to go to get some ideas
about a specific topic so if we're
talking about healthy dieting so we can
find keywords with high search volume
right in cora so the whole idea is you
can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topic like
healthy dieting and find relevant
keywords to healthy dieting so if you
just type in that particular keyword in
quora you're going to probably get some
responses to questions or responses to
somebody else's question and so if we
take a look at core for example so if i
just type in healthy dieting what i'm
going to do is i'm going to get some
responses to the topic healthy dieting
so what's the best diet for healthy
living what are the top five tips for a
healthy diet habit so all of these could
be keyword phrases that you could take
away with for your own content and so
the benefit here is you're getting kind
of an idea of what's trending what
people are talking about and if you use
tips for a healthy diet habit for
example and you optimize for that well
again that could turn around and bode
well for you because you could be
featured in google as a featured snippet
at the top here you can also turn around
and use lsi related keywords for healthy
diet habits and you can simply just look
for those lsi keywords right in google
remember at the bottom or at the top if
i scroll down i can see some related lsi
keywords at the bottom so right in
google as well you can see in the google
search bar that google provides some lsi
related keywords to your query so if i
go back here and type in healthy diet
recipes i can see here google suggesting
some other related keywords healthy diet
menu healthy diet for men healthy diet
foods healthy diet for women so these
are all lsi related keywords that you
can use to support your primary keyword
and the content you're writing about so
we've talked about lsi keywords where to
find them so they're found right here
they can be found at the top of google
and they can be found at the bottom you
can also then go to core as well and get
some ideas for the types of questions
they're being asked so if you ask a
question and use that as your keyword
phrase then again you have an
opportunity of showing up for a featured
snippet in google just by doing some
additional research within google itself
or on quora so according to google the
autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for a term so google
collects all the keyword queries that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if i go back to
google again if i start to type in
recipes i could see some of the other
queries that somebody else has typed in
or some of the most popular queries
related to that topic so if you enter
the keyword healthy diet google's going
to suggest multiple keyword suggestions
that users have asked in the past and
you could certainly get the search
volume of those keywords just by looking
in google itself i could see for healthy
diet recipes billions of pages related
to healthy diet recipes i can also get
the search volume by going into google's
keyword planner so if i type in healthy
diet i'm going to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword and in
addition i can see the seasonality of
that particular keyword and in addition
to that google is going to provide some
other related keywords to my search
query so if i'm looking for healthy diet
google is going to suggest hey maybe you
should choose healthy food or healthy
eating or how to lose weight so those
are lsi related keywords that google
provides in the keyword plan which is
built into the google ads platform
another option for you is wikipedia so
wikipedia is a vast platform of content
so we could turn wikipedia into our own
assets and use it to our own advantage
by finding relevant keywords in an easy
fashion so with wikipedia we can
identify a list of keywords in the meta
description itself we could choose
keywords from the first paragraph of
wikipedia it has many relevant keywords
or we could take a look at keywords from
the wikipedia content section so we can
also see additional pages like the see
also section that gives relevant
keywords that you're looking for we can
also look at the references section as
they contain relevant keywords so we go
to wikipedia as an example and i type in
healthy diet into wikipedia here i can
get just in the first paragraph alone i
can see some additional keywords that i
might choose to use like micronutrients
i never knew that micronutrients was
related to healthy diet but wikipedia is
providing some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe i can use
that as a keyword an lsi related keyword
to my content so if i scroll down i get
to see also section so it might give me
some information food information
consumers for example dietary guidelines
i can look at categories like dietetics
and diets i can also look at the
references section so i can also see
what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
i can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to
my main keyword healthy diet so the
answers are right in here on the
platform they're just all over the page
so wikipedia has an abundance of
information you just need to know where
to look so again with wikipedia you can
look no further than the first paragraph
you can look no further than the see
also section the references section
category section there's lots of
information right on the page itself to
help you get ideas for keywords so if
you google your keyword with wikipedia
term in the search query and get
relevant keywords from the title tags on
the serp so you can also do that as well
so if i type in healthy diet wikipedia
and search i can also get some
information here as well so people also
search for healthy food advantages or
healthy food habits essay or information
about healthy food all of these are
related to
my keyword healthy diet so again another
bit of information for you to choose or
look to choose some additional keywords
for so reddit it's a popular community
where people post content discuss a
variety of topics so that's what reddit
is so with the help of subreddits an
individual can find relevant keywords
with with high search volume so in
reddit there's an easy way to find out
keywords they have a keyword tool called
keyword it so key wording is the average
monthly searches for a particular
keyword so if we type a word in key
reddit and choose keywords from the
auto-generated list this tool will
extract the keywords and give us those
relevant terms with search volumes so if
we go to the keyword it and show an
example of that for example healthy food
if i get keywords i can see what
keywords are relevant and the search
volume of that keyword so if i just type
in healthy food keyword tool is going to
tell me some relevant keywords and what
the volume is so if you don't have the
keyword planner tool and google ads
available to you this is a good
alternative solution to finding keywords
so it's free you just need to go to
keyword.com
type in your keyword click get keywords
and what it's going to do is give you
some relevant keywords related to your
primary keyword with the search volume
let's talk about keyword clustering now
so
the whole idea about keyword clustering
is to
really take advantage of the keywords
that we're optimizing for to gain higher
ranking so if we can cluster keywords
together in a theme and
that theme of keywords is relevant to a
specific page of a website then we have
a better opportunity to rank so in other
words why do we have to target just one
keyword when we can target many so keep
in mind you know lsi keywords we want to
group a bunch of keywords together that
are similar for content so for example
after some keyword research you can
thematically group keywords into a core
topic so for example we can cluster
these group of keywords together like
for example what is seo how does seo
work intro to seo what are the basics of
seo all of those are related to the core
theme what is seo another cluster of
keywords for example could be seo
techniques seo best practices tips and
tricks website optimization on-page seo
techniques etc so those are clusters of
keywords okay that we can group together
in themes and if we group keywords
together in themes we can apply that to
a particular content on our website so
the whole idea behind clustering
keywords it's going to provide more
diversity more of an opportunity for us
to be found so that's the whole idea
behind clustering so some additional
steps remember stay up to date on
industry news to brainstorm your ideas
first and identify a list of keywords
i.e a theme of keywords that you can
cluster together and then you could
determine the keywords that your
competitors are already ranking for so
for example if we want to rank for the
keyword seo best practices for example
we can use a tool called keyword moz if
i go to keyword the keyword explorer
tool in moz and just type in seo best
practices
what it's going to do is it's going to
give me some volume related to that
particular keyword but more importantly
what it's also going to do is going to
show me what pages are already ranked
for that particular keyword so therefore
i can get a sense of who is already
ranking for that keyword so here i can
see mozmoz medium.com alexa.com
so i can get a sense of what web pages
are ranked for particular keyword or
group of keywords i want to rank for
myself so if we look at tools for
keyword research look no further than
moz that's the mods of the tool i would
just use but you could also use google's
keyword planner which we used in the
example so for example if i go back to
the google ads keyword planner if you're
in google ads you click on tools you
click on cleveland planner and what
keyword planner does is it provides you
for a particular keyword the average
monthly search volume over the past 12
months it provides you information on
seasonality so if i hover my mouse over
a graph i'm going to be able to see the
volume per month over the last 12 months
what the keyword planner also does is it
provides me some additional ideas for my
particular keyword and in addition to
that it's going to provide me some sense
of how competitive that keyword is by
telling me whether it's low medium or
high in terms of competition so there's
sem rush there's also other additional
keywords tools out there like word
stream or href or the reddit tool
keyword it and then moz is another tool
i particularly use so if i go to moz
again here i can just type in a keyword
that i'm interested in it's going to
give me the search volume of that
keyword it's going to give me the level
of difficulty so 50 out of 100 so it's
halfway between difficulty and easy and
then it's going to give me some
additional metrics like for example what
my expected organic click-through rate
would be if i were to rank for this
keyword but more importantly what i like
about this is we could see exactly what
other sites are linked to this
particular keyword we're interested in
so here i can look at the top 10 list so
this is moz's key word explore tool so
that's what this tool is and it's part
of moz.com so there's a lot of tools at
your disposal i particularly use moz i
particularly use google's keyword
planner and those are the tools i use
but there are lots of tools out there
google analytics i'm very excited to be
with you today because google analytics
is one of my favorite google platforms
and my favorite topics so let's talk
about
what we're going to cover today and
we're going to start out with how to set
up a google analytics account and so
we're going to talk about everything
that entails including creating your
google analytics account we're going to
talk about setting up a property in your
account and what a property is we're
going to talk about setting up a
reporting view in your property and
we're going to talk about installing the
tracking code so those are the series of
steps we're going to go through today in
terms of setting up a google analytics
account so let's get right to it and so
really the prerequisite here when it
comes to setting up a google analytics
account is to have a google login and id
so when you actually go to google
analytics you need to be able to sign up
or sign in and so
once you actually sign in then you're
gonna go walk through a series of steps
but really that's really all you need to
get the account going is a google id and
login so if you have a gmail account or
another email account that you use for
other google products then you're good
to go that's all you need to do so when
you actually go to sign up for google
analytics you're going to be asked to
set up a new account and these are the
series of steps you're going to walk
through or go through to set up a new
google analytics account so you're going
to choose an account name and then
you're going to choose a property name
okay so the account name can be anything
you want it to be the name your company
your name whatever you want to name it
the property name is really the website
name so what website are we talking
about so here i'm going to set up a
fictitious website name for now it's
called demo simply learn so the url for
this website demo simply learn is going
to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
and analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the
most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and i'm gonna talk about why that's
important here in a minute and then
you're going to choose your time zone
and the time zone is also important
because
that's when the day starts and analytics
then the day ends based on that time
zone so the data that google analytics
collects starts and ends with that time
zone so very important to choose the
time zone your business is located in
okay and then you have some additional
options here okay so you have some
settings and so the first setting is
to allow google products and services so
if you opt into this then basically what
google's gonna do is share some products
and services with you via email i would
go ahead and opt into that that's of
course recommended by google it doesn't
hurt to hear from google on related
products and services that may enhance
your business the second is benchmarking
so benchmarking to me is something you
should opt into so going back to that
industry and category we chose jobs and
education so by opting into benchmarking
basically what google is going to do is
share your data that it collects on your
website in this case
demo.simplylearn.com it's going to share
that data anonymously
with others in the industry in this case
jobs in education and because you've
opted in it's going to do the same exact
thing for you it's going to share
anonymous data on other websites in the
same industry and the benefit of that is
we get to see
what other websites or how other
websites are performing compared to ours
what's the benchmark in our industry and
so the benchmarking to me is important
and i'm gonna go over that in a few
minutes when we go over the different
reports but to me i would always opt
into benchmarking because this is the
only report google provides in analytics
about how others in your industry is
performing versus your website okay so
it's a way to compare your website
performance against others in the same
industry the other options here
technical support and account specialist
i would also recommend you opt into
those because then it allows you to
basically uh google allow google access
to your account and they'll be able to
help you if you occur or run into any
issues so these are the options in
setting up a google analytics account
it's very simple very easy to do you're
just entering in a few fields note that
we talking about a website right now so
i'm talking about demo.simplylearn.com
but just know that if you want to track
a mobile app google analytics will allow
you to do that as well you just choose
the option mobile app so we're tracking
a website we want to know how users
behave when they get to my website and
that's what google analytics is going to
allow us to measure and look at we just
need to do a couple more steps in the
process so once we fill out these fields
here we're going to click get tracking
id now i'm going to accept the terms of
service i'm going to accept another
terms and service in relation to data
protection i'm going to click accept
once i accept i'm gonna be able to get
some tracking code the tracking id is
the id associated with your account and
so
this number is going to be associated
with your account so your account id
starts with ua and it's gonna be this
number here now the dash one is the
property you set up so in this case i
set up demo.simplylearn.com
if i wanted to track multiple websites
under that same account then i can
certainly set up multiple properties
just know that every property i set up
in that account is going to have a dash
1-2-3-4
etc depending on how many properties i
set up so by default i set up one
property so my first property id is dash
one if i set up a second property the
same account number it's just gonna have
a dash too and that's important because
that id that account and property id is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking id up here
notice the tracking id and the snippet
of code now this snippet of code needs
to go on every page of your website that
you want to track and you don't have to
put it on every page but if you want to
track website behavior on every page
your website then it needs to go on
every page of your website so if you're
using a
you know platform like drupal or joomla
or even more popular platform like
wordpress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
google analytics plug-in to wordpress
for example and then just simply plug in
in the id now there's an alternative to
adding the google analytics tracking
code to your site and that's google tag
manager so google tag manager is the way
i would recommend going so if you're not
familiar with google tag manager i would
recommend watching the
youtube video we have on google tag
manager you can just go to youtube
type in simply learn google tag manager
and this will give you a nice overview
of what google tag manager is and how it
works but basically this is the way i
would go and i would recommend that in
addition having google analytics you set
up a google tag manager account and then
that way you can put the tracking code
in google tag manager so if i go to
google tag manager and i just go into an
account on tag manager i can just simply
put in the google analytics id
right into tag manager and so if i have
it in tag manager then tag manager is
going to be the place that holds the
code and fires page view when somebody
comes to my website so that way i don't
have to add the tracking code to my
website if i do it in tag manager so
that's the recommended method for me is
to add the google analytics id
associated with tag manager if you can
associate it with tag manager then
that's the easier route to go versus
putting code on your website okay so
again take a look at the video we have
on youtube for google tag manager that's
the route i would go now once you do get
the tracking code on your website
whether that be through google tag
manager or through a plugin or you know
just simply adding the script to your
site to pages on your site then what's
going to happen is you're going to start
collecting data so that's ideally the
way it works you need to add this code
to your website now if you're not ready
to do that and you simply want to
basically understand how google
analytics works then i would recommend
getting access to google analytics demo
account and so if you just type in and
search google analytics demo account
basically what you're going to do you're
going to choose the first listing there
and you're going to go to demo account
so if you have a google analytics or
google login then all you need to do is
click on access demo account and so what
google is going to do is put this demo
account into your account and so it's
going to look something like this so if
i click on demo account here it's going
to add to my google analytics account so
i'm gonna have then access to the demo
account from google and google analytics
so i would recommend going this route
here if you're not familiar you're not
sure what you're getting yourself into
so think of the demo account as kind of
a test drive you're test driving google
analytics before you even add any code
to your website so again all you need is
a google account and if you have a
google account and you add the demo
account to your google analytics account
you're going to be able to see how
analytics works okay and so that's what
i would also recommend so if you're not
ready to start adding code to your
website then what you can do
is just simply add the demo account and
then once you add the demo account
you're free to peruse around google
analytics to see the different types of
reports it has to offer now when you do
actually set up a google analytics
account you're going to have some
settings that you're going to want to
pay attention to so when you set up the
account you have the account name and
then you have a property so under each
property you have by default you're
going to have one view and so here you
can see this view here so if we look at
the account we set up we set up a demo
simply learn account property is demo
simply learn so that's associated with
the website we're going to track and
then again by default under each
property you're going to have a view and
so by default the name of the view is
going to be called all website data and
so in that view is where all your
analytics data is going to be stored so
you can see my screen here there's a lot
of different settings you have you have
settings under the account you have
settings under the property and you have
settings under the view so we're going
to talk more about these settings in
future webinars for advanced google
analytics users but for now know that
there's a bunch of settings that you
have that you can play around with when
it comes to google analytics anything
from adding users to your google
analytics account your google analytics
property or view you can actually set up
goals you can set up filters you can set
up segments you can link up google ads
you can
you know set up remarketing lists
there's a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to google
analytics but so no those settings are
there they're located right down here
and this little sprocket icon that's the
admin icon so if you need to get to
these settings at any time you could
simply just click on the sprocket or the
admin icon and then you'll be prompted
to choose any one of these settings here
that you want to edit or alter so now
let's take a look at some google
analytics reports so once you've
actually set up your account you have a
number of different reports that you
have available to you in google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in google
analytics so if i'm an admin and i'm
looking at the google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
i click on the real time report and i
just click on overview so basically what
this is going to do is show me at this
point in time how many users i actually
have active on the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here i can see that 79
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent are coming
from tablet here i can see how they
actually came to the website so this is
the referring source if they came from
say search or social i can see the
source there and i can see what pages
they're active on and then here i can
see what locations where they're located
and so if i want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview i can
certainly do that if i go to locations
under real time i could see a majority
of my users are coming from the united
states okay where are they coming from
i'll just click on traffic sources and
here i could see the different sources
and mediums medium is the means in which
the traffic was driven so if it's google
it's either paid search or organic
search so i can see here it's organic
then i can actually see what contents
they're looking at on my website so i
could see currently have three active
users on the home page two active users
on the google's women's white tee page
so forth and so on now most importantly
if you have event tracking set up so if
you taking a look at our google tag
manager webinar you know that you could
set up event tracking in google
analytics to measure engagement on your
website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if i click on
events i'll be able to see what events
are firing so here i can see we have
event tracking set up and i can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here i can see
e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
gonna be able to see them highlighted so
if something gets fired it's gonna get
highlighted and i could see
that these are the current events that i
have currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if i
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes i can
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look at what
conversions are happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now i can see
i had one active user who entered the
checkout so that's goal number four so
in analytics you can have up to 20 goals
and so here i can see
we have goal number four has already had
one active user and so if i look at the
last 30 minutes i can see i still have
only one goal over the last 30 minutes
and that was somebody who entered the
checkout so that's real-time reporting
in summary it just gives you an idea of
what's currently happening on your
website and so for me ideally if i'm
launching a campaign or let's just say
you do a new website redesign and you
want to see how users performing and
behaving then real time is a good option
for you so you can see how things are
happening in real time now let's jump
down to audience reporting so if i click
on audiences it's just right underneath
real time i'm going to see a number of
different reports available to me under
audience and so let's click on the
audience overview report so
audience reporting basically allows us
to get a sense of who is coming to our
website when i say who is coming to our
website it doesn't necessarily have to
be a specific person in fact google
doesn't allow personally identifiable
information in google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name a social security number
credit card information etc however we
can still paint a nice picture on who is
coming to our website meaning what
country city or state did they come from
what language what device did they get
to our website from how old were they
okay were they male or female or other
what interest did they have what browser
did they use so we can paint a nice
picture based on all this information
that google analytics is providing us
under audience so if i go to audience
overview here i can see i have all these
different options available to me to get
a basic understanding of who is coming
to our website so for example i could
see a majority of the people coming to
our website speak english and are from
the united states okay in fact that
represents 61
of the users and so google analytics
does a great job of giving me an overall
percentage so
if i have a 100 of the users i could see
61 of those users represented english
speaking users from the united states
seven percent represented english
speaking users from great britain and so
when it comes to analytics we have users
and users are broken down into two
categories they're either returning or
they're new so when you add the google
analytics tracking script to your
website what's going to happen is if a
user or when a user goes to your website
they're going to get cookied if it's the
first time they've been to your website
what google analytics is going to do is
store a cookie in the browser so when
that same user comes back another day in
the same browser analytics is going to
recognize that that cookie is in the
browser and so then analytics is going
to categorize that user as a returning
user okay so that's how analytics is
able to differentiate new versus
returning so if that user doesn't have a
cookie in the browser then analytics is
going to recognize that store the cookie
and then count that user as a new user
and so when you're looking in analytics
you're going to be able to see a
breakdown of new versus returning so
here i can see over three quarters of my
traffic over the past week here i can
see april 6 through april 12th three
over three quarters are new users to the
website here i could see about 23 24
are returning users okay so i can get a
good breakdown of what type of users are
coming am i driving new traffic am i
driving traffic that's been to my
website before what language are they
speaking okay i can also paint a bigger
picture how old are they are they what
gender are they do they come from mobile
so let's take a look at some of these
different reports under audience so if i
skip down now to demographics i can
click on overview and when that report
loads i can see now under demographics
overview i can see the breakout of age
ranges and so here i can see the
majority of the traffic coming to my
site again over the past week now if i
want to change this date range i could
simply do that i can change the date
range just by clicking on the date range
and then maybe going say the last 30
days and i can even compare it to the
previous period or the previous year i'm
going to choose the last 30 days i'm
going to click apply now i'm looking at
data over the last 30 days and again you
can change the date range to any range
you want you can only go back as far as
when you actually created the google
analytics account you can't go prior to
that so here i'm looking at the last 30
days and i can see almost 47
of my users were in their age range of
25 to 34. now when it comes to gender i
can see
66
represent males so i can get a breakout
of gender and age as well as interest
and click on interest and look at the
overview there and see what the interest
is of the users who are coming to my
site based on in-market segments or
affinity i can also choose language and
location so if i want to know exactly
where my users are located when they're
coming to my website i can click on
location and here i can get a breakout
43
of the users of the last 30 days were
from the united states more importantly
i can align my audience with goals and
we'll talk about goals here in a minute
but here i can see if i have an
e-commerce website i can see of those 43
0.29 of those converted or purchased
something and that equates to 94
transactions so i can get a good sense
of not only how many users are coming
from a specific country but are those
users converting if i click on mobile
and mobile to me is one of those reports
i tend to spend a bit of time on because
i want to know what devices users are
coming to my website and so for my
website here or this is the google demo
website i can see mobile represents
approximately 27
of the traffic so desktop still
represents a majority of the traffic so
for you you want to keep an eye on
mobile because mobile is definitely a
majority of what people use nowadays
that's how people start their day that's
how they transact via mobile whether
that's purchasing something
communicating or searching it all starts
with mobile so you want to keep an eye
on mobile and more importantly you want
to keep an eye on behavior so google
analytics is telling me that yes i have
approximately 27 of my traffic of the
last 30 days came from mobile how are
they interacting with my website so if i
look across this report i'm going to be
able to see different metrics so if i'm
measuring specific metrics against my
dimension in this case the dimension is
what we're measuring and in this example
we're measuring mobile i can see that
the bounce rate is approximately 48 and
bounce rate means that if a user in this
case from mobile landed on a page they
left the site without going any further
so they consider it a bounce if they
don't go to another page if they leave
the site from the page they landed on
and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so bounce rate is
the percentage of people who come to the
site and leave the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48
bounce rate that's almost half of our
users who come from mobile leave the
website from the page they landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's open
to interpretation is definitely
subjective but you want to keep the
bounce rate as low as possible you want
to keep people on your site especially
if you have an e-commerce website you
want people who come to your website to
purchase and so here we can see 48
mobile in desktop it's a little bit
lower at 41
now if i look a little bit further at
engagement i can see how many pages on
average do mobile users look at so
versus desktop it's a little bit lower
you can see 3.86 on desktop it's 4.5 now
if i look a little bit further in
engagement i want to be able to measure
how long somebody from mobile stays on
the website if they're bouncing at 48
but they're also looking at 3.8 pages
3.9 almost four pages per session then
that means in this report analytics is
telling me they're spending about two
minutes on the site and interestingly
enough i can see that mobile over the
last 30 days had more transactions so 51
transactions versus 34 transactions from
desktop and interestingly enough the
commerce conversion rate is at 0.29
percent that's higher than desktop at
0.07 it's lower than tablet but it's
higher than desktop and mobile has the
most transactions and since they have
the most transactions they have the most
revenue at 2 380. so yes the engagement
isn't exactly as great as it is as
desktop but we can see that people are
still purchasing with their mobile
devices so it's something to keep an eye
on and mobile is something i definitely
look at in fact since it's such an
important report one thing you can do in
analytics is if you actually like a
report and you think you're going to
look at that report multiple times then
you can simply just go ahead and click
save at the top here so if i click save
i'm going to enter a name for this
report i'm just going to call it mobile
report and click ok and then what's
going to happen is it's going to be
located under save reports and save
reports is located under customization
customization is located above real time
okay so if i close that up you can see
audience real time customization if i
click on customization if i click on
save reports i should be able to see my
save report here and i do so here i can
see mobile report if i click on it i can
simply go to the report i was looking at
before i saved it so save reports to me
is a good feature in analytics because
it allows you to quickly access a report
that you've saved in the past so let's
take a look at one more report under
audience and let's go to benchmarking so
remember when we were setting up our
analytics account we had the option to
opt into benchmarking and i recommended
you do so and so if you did actually opt
into benchmarking then you're going to
be able to see
how your site compares to others in the
same industry so if i click on
benchmarking and then click on channels
what i'm actually able to do now is
compare my website with others in the
same industry so if i go back to say
jobs in education and i choose education
all education as my industry vertical i
should be able to see
websites that are in the same particular
industry and how i compare with those
websites so i'm choosing all countries i
can narrow that down if i wanted to i
can just search for the united states i
can choose a specific state and then i
can choose a particular
site size so here i'm choosing sites by
daily sessions so these are sites that
have an average of 5 000 to almost 10
000 sessions a day and so in this
vertical education in the united states
sites that have 5 000 to
999
sessions per day that means that there
are approximately 310 web properties
contributing to this report okay based
on this criteria i chose now if my site
is similar meaning if i'm in the united
states if i'm in education and i'm
receiving 5 000 to
999 sessions per day then i'm able to
compare my site against 310 other
websites now google sharing this data
anonymously from the other websites and
they're doing the same with your website
to those particular websites
benchmarking reports okay so it's a
shared data anonymously in particular
industries and verticals and so now i'm
looking at a channel report so if i want
to see how i compare to others in my
industry then i can go ahead and see by
channel for example am i driving as much
traffic as others in my industry and you
can see i'm not in fact i'm 76 77
percent worse in terms of the amount of
traffic being driven from organic search
so anything in red is going to
show as a negative result a negative
comparison whereas something in green is
a positive comparison so if i look at
engagement i can see that i might not be
driving as much traffic but i can see
that the pages per session are better
than the site average or the industry
average i can see if i go over again
looking just at organic search i can see
the bounce rate is better than the
industry average so the channel report
under benchmarking allows you to measure
how you compare to others in your
industry and you could do so by looking
at location and devices so if you opted
into benchmarking when you set up your
account then you'll be able to compare
your website against others in your
industry in your country region and
based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is who is coming to your website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic was driven to your website so
how did these users get to our website
and so under acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to see an
overview of how users whether they're
returning or new came to our website and
so what analytics does by default
is they have a number of default
channels and when we say channels we
mean analytics is grouping different
channels based on how users got to your
website meaning how did users get to our
website did they come via organic search
meaning do they type something into
google and find you in the organic
listing analytics also groups users
based on whether they came to your site
directly meaning did they type in the
url directly into the browser or did
they bookmark your website and come back
via the bookmark so they're grouping
users under direct they also group users
under referral meaning do they come from
another website they group users by
social do they come from a social media
platform like twitter or facebook if
you're running paid search
meaning if you're running paid search on
say google then do they come from paid
search ads now if you're running display
ads on say google's network google's
display network that's a default channel
so analytics will group users there so
if they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default google analytics groups users
on how they came to your website via
these default channels and so i could
see how many users came to the site from
each channel now if i want to drill down
on this report i can click on all
traffic and then if i click on all
traffic i can go to channels i can look
specifically at the channels report and
so now i can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic and they
represent approximately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users i can see
that number is about 56
so 56 percent of my traffic over the
last 30 days came from organic search
and so those are the number of users
again as a metric you're also going to
have sessions and you'll see sessions a
lot as a metric so users are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so
just like we looked at with the
audience reports when it came to mobile
we can also look at engagement by
channel so just like mobile we looked at
bounce rate pages per session average
session duration we can do the same
thing here with our channel report more
importantly in addition to behavior we
can see conversions and since we're
running an e-commerce platform we could
see what the conversion rate is by
channel so organic search did drive the
most traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is 0.17
okay so how google determines the
conversion rate they basically take
the number of transactions and divide
that by sessions so that means that over
the last 30 days organic search drove 38
123 sessions and of those 38 123 64
actually
turned into a transaction which equates
to 0.17 which also equates to 3 000 in
revenue so i'm able to determine not
only how users are getting to my website
by looking at the channel report i can
actually see if they're engaging and if
they are converting and notice when you
look at a report in analytics you can
look at it by channel you'll also get a
summary so here i can see a summary or a
total based on my date range so i could
see over the last 30 days i've had 54
000 users 49 000 of them
were new okay that meant that at those
54 000 users i had 70 000 sessions i
could see my average bounce rate was 43
the pages per session were just over
four and the average session duration
how long did somebody stay on my website
on average about two minutes and 55
seconds the average conversion rate was
0.14 and at a total 97 transactions
totaling fifty five hundred dollars okay
and that's all over the last 30 days so
any report you look at in analytics is
going to have a summary and note that
any report you look at in analytics is
going to allow you to save it so if it's
a report you think you're going to go
back and look at at a future date then
you simply just have to click on the
save button conversely if you don't want
to save it you can simply just export it
so you can export it as a pdf if i click
on pdf it's going to allow me to export
that as a pdf now you have other options
available to you as well you can do a
google sheet you can export it as an
excel or you can export it as a comma
delimited file so here you can see i can
save it as a pdf if i want to and if i
click ok it's going to save to my
desktop or location of my choosing and
then i can go back and look at it in
that format at a later time so that's
the export feature available to you in
analytics again if you you could save it
as well or you can export it okay some
other reports under acquisition if
you're running google ads note that you
can connect google ads to analytics and
this is key because now i can see
how many people are coming from google
ads to my website and are they
converting now this is important because
with google ads i'm actually paying for
the click so you can see here i'm
running a report based on campaign data
so i could see what campaigns are
driving traffic how much i'm paying per
click and you can see on average i'm
paying 34 cents per click and then more
importantly i want to be able to see if
they're converting so you can see i've
spent 810
over the last 30 days and received 850
in revenue so you want to make sure that
you link up your google ads account to
your google analytics account for this
very reason you want to be able to see
how your google ads campaigns perform
once the users get to your website and
so i want to see if they're engaging and
i want to see if they're converting so
there are all sorts of reports under
google ads so you can look at it by
keywords by search queries by hour of
the day if you're running display
campaigns you can look at display
targeting so there's all sorts of
reports under google ads you just have
to link it up and you link it up under
the admin now there are other reports
that you can look at so if i go to
campaigns i can look at all campaigns so
if you're running all sorts of different
types of campaigns whether that be on
facebook whether that be email whether
that be you know other types of
advertising let's just say twitter or
instagram you're gonna be able to see
those campaigns here and that's under
all campaigns and again you'll be able
to see the campaign name and you'll be
able to see metrics associated with
those campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your e-commerce if
you run an e-commerce platform or if you
have goals set up so you'll be able to
look at how your campaigns are not one
not only driving traffic but two are
they converting let's go from
acquisition reporting to behavior so
behavior reports are going to actually
show you
how users behaved once they got to your
website once they landed on a page on
your website how did they behave so when
we looked at audience we got a sense of
who is coming with acquisition we get a
sense of how the traffic got to our
website did they come from organic
direct social etc the behavior reports
allow us to actually measure how that
traffic behave once they landed on a
page on our website and so if i go to
overview under behavior now i'm looking
at this graph here it's showing me how
many page views i've had and a page view
is simply once a page is viewed it's
counted as a page view so if a user
comes to my site they're initiating a
session and if they look at a page then
that page is going to have a page view
okay so a user can look at a page
multiple times in a session and every
time they look at that page it's going
to count as a page view so here i can
see in this graph how many page views
i've had again over the last 30 days and
if i look further at my overview report
i can see the specific pages and how
many pages they've had and i can also
look at some other metrics okay the
average bounce rate the average time on
page i can look at the exit rate which
means how many people actually exited or
the percentage of people who exited from
that page so i can dig deeper into my
behavior reporting so if i click on site
content and i click on all pages then
i'm going to look at a report by page
this is my dimension this is what i'm
measuring my page and now i can see how
many page views each page had over the
last 30 days now note you also have
something called unique page views so
unique page use is equivalent to one per
session in other words if a user came to
my site and looked at the home page then
the home page is going to have one
unique page view and one page view now
if the user in that same session looks
at other pages then every page that user
looks at is going to have one unique
page view however if the user goes back
to a to the same page in the same
session then it's still going to be one
unique page view but in this case the
home page if they look at the home page
a second time then the home page is
gonna have two page views if they look
at the home page five times in one
session then the home page is gonna have
five total page views and one unique
page view okay so that's why unique
pages is equivalent to one per session
where page uses accumulation of how many
times the page was viewed in the same
session so in other words you're always
going to have more page views than
unique pages okay so this gives me a
sense of how my page is performed so
again i can look at total page views and
then engagement so ideally what you want
to do with a report like this is if a
user is not engaging on the page then
that should tell you something about the
page itself if they're not engaging if
the bounce rate's high if the time on
page is low
if the exit percentage of exit rate is
high then you probably want to do
something with that page now these are
all pages but if i jump down to landing
pages my landing page report is showing
me how many people actually landed on
that page and so here i can see under my
landing page report i can see the home
page had thirty six thousand seventeen
sessions in the last thirty days that's
how many people landed on the home page
so here i can see seventy one percent
were new sessions meaning that i had a
lot of new users who landed on the
homepage in fact 25 000 or 52 percent of
the people who landed on the homepage
were new i could see the balance rates
about 42 percent but of those who didn't
balance they went on to look at about
4.5 pages per session and spent about
three minutes on the site and the one
thing i like about the landing page
report is i can also see whether that
particular page in this case the home
page did it help contribute to a goal or
conversion and in this case i can see of
those 36 000 sessions i had 22
transactions totaling 1200 in revenue
and that's an e-commerce conversion rate
of 0.06 percent so the home page over
the last 30 days contributed to 0.06
of the revenue so this gives you an idea
of when somebody lands on your website
and they land on a page is that page
helping to move that person along
meaning are they not bouncing and is
that page helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under behavior including site
speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed's
important because what google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they sampled 2 835 page
views and of that sample they came back
and said the average page load time is
about 4 seconds now ideally you want to
keep it as quick as possible i would say
even under three seconds okay now there
are other factors involved with page
load time the browser you're using the
country that you're actually browsing
that page from might not have the best
infrastructure you may not even be on
the best internet network meaning you're
on a cell network or the wi-fi is not
that great or you can be on a page that
just has a lot of images or a lot of
code that may slow it down so there are
other factors involved and so what
google analytics does is show you what
those factors are so here i can see
by browser what the average load time is
if i want to look at country i can see
what country is contributing to the low
time now the great thing about the site
speed report is if i go to speed
suggestions okay what speed suggestions
is going to do is it's going to show me
the page load time by page and then it's
actually going to provide a link where i
can actually click on to get suggestions
on increasing the page load time so for
example i can look at this particular
page here this google redesign shop by
brand slash youtube page line number
five if i look at line number five i can
see the average load time of this page
is eight seconds almost nine seconds
okay that's an eternity to some people
now notice this link next to it so
google's recommending seven total
suggestions so if i click on seven total
what it's actually gonna do it's gonna
open up a new window and it's going to
open up another google report called
page speed insights and page speed
insights is going to give me some
information about what i can do to
create correct correct the page load of
that particular page so look at
site speed report it's important because
there is a correlation between site
speed or page load time and user
behavior of that page and there's also
correlation between page load time and a
page ranking organically on search so
page load time is very important it's so
important that i'm even going to save it
so i'm going to click save and click on
speed site speed suggestions as my name
and click ok and now that report is
going to be saved under customization
under save reports let's jump from
behavior to conversions now conversion
reporting is arguably the most important
section in google analytics because what
the conversions reporting allows us to
do is see how people are converting or
if they're not converting on our website
and so in google analytics we have the
opportunity to set up goals now you have
the opportunity to set up 20 goals in
your google analytics view and so to set
up a goal okay so you're going to click
on admin and under the view you're going
to see goals and so if you don't even
have goals the first step is to create
goals and so you have four different
goal types and analytics so you have
pages per session so how many pages per
session is so if your goal is set to say
three or two if somebody actually looked
at two or three pages per session it's
going to count as a goal okay so if i
look here i could see i have pages per
session set at 10. so that means that if
a user came to the site looked at more
than 10 pages per session then it's
going to count as a goal another goal
type is destination so destination means
that if somebody actually went to a
specific page then it's going to count
as a goal and in this case i can see
here that the goal is set to this
particular page here and so when
somebody actually lands on that page
it's going to count as a goal now there
are two other goal types we can look at
one is duration so just like pages per
session in our previous example if
somebody looked at 10 pages per session
it's gonna count as a goal with duration
it's based on time so in this particular
case if you set up a duration goal and
the duration is set to say one minute
and 30 seconds then that means if a user
comes to my website and they spend at
least one minute and 30 seconds then
it's going to count as a goal okay and
then the fourth type of goal in google
analytics is an event based goal so when
you set up event tracking you could turn
that event into a goal so if somebody
clicks on say the submit button of a
form you can turn that event into a goal
so here you could see the category
equals contact form so you can always
verify if a goal works just by clicking
on verify this goal and in this case
this event is turned into a goal so
anytime somebody fires this event it's
gonna count as a goal so you have four
different goal types in google analytics
you have pages per session destination
event and duration and so once you've
set up a goal then you can measure goals
under conversions so now if i look at
goals overview i can be able to see how
many total goal completions i've had so
if i want to look at it by goal i can
just choose the goal option here so if i
want to look at for example
goal 2 engaged users this was the pages
per session i can see that i had a
conversion rate at 10 percent meaning
that i had 7 000 of all the users who
came to the website 7 000 gold
completions meaning 7106
users looked at 10 pages or more on my
website and so that's how you want to be
able to measure whether users wherever
they're coming from whoever they are
whatever pages they look at you want to
be able to look at the conversion
reports to see if they're actually
converting based on the goals you've set
up whether that's pages per session
duration destination or event goal
conversion tracking reports can help you
measure who is actually converting and
the great thing about google analytics
here is that i can actually see
by segment so the default segment in a
segment is just looking at a specific
user sets so the default segment is
always all users however i can choose a
different segment so if i want to choose
instead of all users if i want to choose
mobile traffic i can select mobile
traffic hit apply so i'm actually now
looking at a subset of data i'm looking
at mobile traffic so if all the mobile
users have come to my site i can see
1400 engaged or looked at 10 pages or
more okay and that's a seven percent
conversion rate so the great thing about
google analytics is you have the
opportunity to set up four different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals overview and
look at the conversion rate
of each goal but you can also change the
segment of that particular goal to see
who exactly converted okay another
report i like under conversions is the
multi-channel funnel report so if i
click on multi-channel funnel basically
what this allows me to do is see how
different channels work together to
convert so remember the channel
reporting we looked at under acquisition
here i can see now how different
channels work together to drive the
conversion so if i look at three
channels direct organic and referral i
can see all three together drive two
percent of the conversions if i look at
direct and referral 12 and a half
percent if i look at direct and organic
12.24
so i can see how different channels work
together and so if i look at top
conversion paths as an example i can
actually see
what channels how channels work together
to drive the conversion so in this
example i can see over the last 30 days
that my top channel grouping was direct
times two meaning that somebody came to
the website directly meaning they typed
in the url in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination is my top conversion
combination of the last 30 days my
second best conversion grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that a
user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
converted so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website via
referral or referring website and
converted then the referring website's
gonna get the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so a channel may drive a lot of traffic
like organic search but that traffic may
not convert the first time around for a
number of different reasons whether it
could be brand recognition price
shopping reading content whatever the
case analytics is able to measure if
that channel actually did contribute at
a later point and in this case we could
see organic search drove traffic that
didn't convert but that traffic came
back a second time via direct and did
convert so that's our second best
channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only a channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns from different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance now if you have any comments
or questions about any of the reports we
covered feel free to comment underneath
this video we're definitely going to
have more webinars in the future about
specific analytics settings that we
didn't get to today and other types of
analytics reports and features that we
didn't get to today the concept of
linking is foundational to good rankings
and understanding the internet at large
it starts with the premise that good
content will be cited by others
recommending it to other people
how we cite and recommend information
online is by linking to it
we link to information that we find
valuable
based on that the search engines assess
content by how
websites link to one another
so we are going to cover the definition
and purpose of links
and the different functions that links
serve
we'll also look at how links mirror
human judgment
we'll look at how search engines
evaluate links by mirroring human
judgment
and how that affects what's called block
level analysis
and how where the location of different
links and how they are used will greatly
affect their relevance
we're going to look at how visitors from
different linked sources will behave
differently based on where they came
from
and also how you can measure the
effectiveness of links and finally we're
going to look at both good and bad
linking practices
now links serve a number of purposes
from a functional standpoint
they usually are our primary means of
navigation online
we click on links we go to different
pages and from those pages we find links
to other pages
links are also a method of citing other
content when we quote somebody when we
use information that we have found
somewhere else
we cite that information to give credit
to the original author
typically online we do that with the
link so that if someone wants to see the
original source document it's available
to them that also helps to provide
credibility to you
credibility to the author of the
original source
as well as assigning importance to the
knowledge that came from that original
source and the authority of the original
source
links also provide us with a clear
structure of how our websites are built
how the pages relate to one another and
how organized the information can be
so let's break down the functional part
of a link
this is important if you're going to be
developing anchor text and linking
to understand the structure
the ahref
equals is the start of the link tag
what you are doing is developing the
reference
of where
the document is contained
that's the href reference is what it is
short for
what comes next within the quotes
is the location of the document now this
can be a full url
or you may just be linking to
a document that's on the main root level
of your server
this is the full location
where you can access the document
and so you're putting the name of the
document the extension
so that it will be linked
the next part
is what i have in caps you'll notice off
to the left i have something in all blue
text and underlined which most people
will recognize as a link
you see when it is in between the
document location
and the closing of the link tag the text
you have in there is what's called
anchor text
you see instead of publishing
the document location
and the full url of the document
we can
put the link within text
and create anchor text so all someone
has to do is click on the link and the
document loads for them
this anchor text is vitally important to
understanding
how we can add additional relevance
to linking content
then we see the closure of the link tag
this is what makes the internet
the internet is millions of pages
connected together
by links
so when we look at the functional side
of links and we look at this example
here
as you can see the title of this article
is not the url address of the article
it's a title and the title is the link
that is the anchor text of the link
and so from a search engine standpoint
search engines look to see what words
are being used in the link
and how relevant those words are to the
document that is being linked
it also looks to see where is the link
is it in the editorial information in
the article
is it part of the navigation
is it in a sidebar or is it an ad
and then also search engines are looking
to see if this is a text link or an
image link
how long has that link been there
what type of link is it
does it go
somewhere within your website
does it go to another website
or is it a reciprocal link which i will
explain more later
they also look to see the text in the
link
and the context to the page
with the link directs you to
we utilize links a little differently
you see from a human standpoint whenever
we refer information to another person
when we provide reference material to
another person or even if someone asks
us for a recommendation
we provide this information
you see offline we mirror the same
behavior as we do online when we link
people ask us for information and we
provide it
we just mirror that online by making a
link
offline we recommend we refer
we provide information to each other in
much the same way
the way i want you to think about it
from a human standpoint
is that if you asked another person for
advice or directions or a referral
are there certain people that you would
trust more than others
i'm sure the answer to that is yes and
maybe you have some people in mind that
you are thinking about
you see we run across the same issue
with search
the search engines know that there are
some websites that are much more
trustworthy than others
just like if you were to ask someone for
information
i'm sure you would ask the right person
for the information you would ask the
most knowledgeable trustworthy person
you knew
who had authority in that subject area
the search engines are trying to do the
same thing with the links that we
publish on our websites
they're trying to determine who is the
most trustworthy and relevant
based on the recommendations referrals
and citations of other websites
to other websites
who are the websites that are trusted
that are authorities
the search engines are trying to do from
a technical algorithmic standpoint
what we do naturally from a human
standpoint
now from the human side as i had said
before we need to think of links as
information that we receive from other
people
word of mouth advice information
directions recommendations
this is where we need to think about
links not from the standpoint of
building false relevance for a search
engine but being a helpful resource for
our readers how can we help them how can
we provide information and how can we be
a credible source
of information
how can we develop our authority within
the industry
and so that people who have questions
about this content will see our websites
as authoritative and credible resources
the best way to develop links as you'll
see
is good content
when people like what they read when
they like what they see
when they are willing to recommend it to
others
it's because you have created something
of value
and they'll link to you
when they
feel that you are credible
and that you are authoritative
with this information
only then will they share it with other
people
because you have earned that right
for them to share it with others by
providing content that is informative
educational
entertaining and you've provided that
service only then
will people then want to recommend it to
others by linking to it
now links serve a number of benefits
when i look at some of the incoming
links to my site one of the things i
notice is that if i get a link in
certain places that can drive a lot of
brand exposure
i can have thousands of people coming to
the site looking to see an article and
that provides a lot of exposure to a lot
of people
however also
getting a link from a certain website
especially if it's a high
relevant authoritative website
i can see my rankings increase because
of that
but then also
a good link is going to drive people
that will convert and drive sales or
leads
those who become customers
so those are the three aspects of a good
link
a good link will drive traffic to your
site a good link will assist your
rankings
and a good link will bring in business
if you can get a link to do all three of
those at the same time that's what i
call the golden link because it has all
three benefits
usually however you're going to find
that different links will provide
different types of benefits
one of these three or maybe two out of
these three
one of the things i'm usually very
focused on
is the link that drives sales or
generates leads
that's getting links in the right place
that will benefit me tangibly
rather than just getting thousands of
people to see it
why it benefits me financially if i can
get a link in the right place
so from here let's break down the
different types of links we have
navigational links we see these in our
navigation our primary navigation
maybe the footer of our web pages where
we have links to typical information
such as about us or contact us
we also have sidebar links this might be
related information or
offers or calls to action
and then also i would break it down into
outbound or inbound type of navigation
outbound are links going to other
websites
inbound links are links that come from
other websites and that also i might
send to other pages on my own site
now i've used the term editorial
an editorial link is a link that is
found within the content of the website
and by that i mean through an article
so if i am writing an article and i link
to someone else and cite them or
reference them
that is what's called an editorial link
it means that it's part of the content
a great example of this is that
the navigation on your web pages is not
part of the content
it serves a function as navigation
but it doesn't have anything to do
with supporting information
with citing an authority
so information and links that you put
within the content and presented content
of your site are considered editorial
now there's also call to action links
where you're
bringing someone to a landing page or a
registration page or a sale page
then also we have social links
now these can provide a variety of means
but typically a social link will go to a
profile
maybe it's a username that takes you
somewhere else or a comment
or maybe just an image or something that
goes to a social site or that you have
placed on your own site as well
either way it's all contained within
that social network even though the
links are going on and off your site
they tend to be controlled in that
social environment
now i've used the term reciprocal link
now this is
something very specific
a reciprocal link is one where you would
go to somebody else and you would make a
trade such as if you link to me i'll
link to you
and maybe you put those links on the
home page or maybe you create a page
just for that link
you see sometimes
it just doesn't make sense and so the
search engines will see that you've
linked to each other
but if there's no contextual relevance
if there's no contextual relevance
most likely you won't get any benefit
because you've agreed to link to each
other for the primary purpose of
boosting rankings
now this is not to say that two websites
can't link to each other because there
is some relevance
we'll look at some examples of that
later on in this module
also then we have advertising links
these can be ads banners anything on the
page that is an advertising link that if
you were to click on it you would go to
that advertisers page
those links are typically through an ad
server and they take place an entirely
different ecosystem
but they are links and we need to
know
what kind of links are advertising and
which kind of links are functional to
our websites
now when i broke down the different
types of links so we have our navigation
links we have links in our sidebar and
in our footer
what block level analysis does is that
the search engines look at the code of
the page
they break down the page because it's
very easy to figure out which part of
the code has to do with your navigation
which part of the code has to do with
your sidebar and your footer
and which part of the code is calling
ads from an ad server with this leaves
is the editorial content your article
and the ability of search engines then
to break down your page into these
different elements the reason why they
do it is that the links contained in the
editorial space are considered to be
more relevant
in terms of linking to other websites
than any of the other types of links on
your web page search engines don't
consider all parts of the page to be
equally relevant which is okay because
neither do humans we look at the
navigation as
utilization pure utility because it's
just helping me navigate among the
different pages of your website i'm not
expecting to learn anything
i'm using it as a functional means of
navigating your site now your sidebar
might have some calls to action it might
have links to other pages
but it's not an article
it's what you've developed and so it
might be a little more important than
your navigation but it's not as
important as what you may have written
within content your footer navigation is
basically the same
you control that it's the same on every
page and so what the search engines are
looking for are the unique content
the unique article or information that
you've published and if there is a link
within the editorial content
that is highly relevant because it has
to do with content it has to do with
information that you are sharing
and so the links there are going to be
more highly relevant and are going to be
more important for the search engines to
see
you see it's the same way with humans
we're not going to look at navigation to
learn something it's functional the same
thing with the footer and as humans
we're reading the content that you have
in your article and if you link to
another source
well you've provided us with utility
but it's contextual utility because
you're citing where you found
information or you're citing an
additional source
or you are linking to an example and it
enables me as a human
to see that understand it and if i need
that additional information i can click
on it and go to it
so i'm going to look at the information
on the page in that article
very differently that i'm going to look
at the
headings the navigation the sidebars or
the footer
because the article is what is informing
me
and so the links in the article i'm
going to look at very differently
and hold them in a higher level of
relevance
now over time search engines have had to
refine the algorithm about links
you see in the early days of search
engine algorithms they used to simply
count the amount of links then if one
site had more links than another that
made it more credible
however once people started to figure
that out people started accumulating
links by really any means necessary
and they would just looking for the
sheer volume of links because they knew
if they got the most amount of links it
would affect their rankings
and so over the years the search engines
have had to change and adjust and
add more relevance to their algorithm
refine it in order to look at different
aspects of links
in order to properly determine relevance
so over time it wasn't just having a
link
it was then also looking at
how many people cite this site
as an authority so looking at the source
of the link
and the types of pages
then also looking at the text of the
link and matching it with the text of
the page
does it match is it contextual
and then looking at the type of link
doing the block level analysis
and then also the context the relevancy
of your site compared to the linking
site compared to the link
and the information that's being shared
there
also some of the ways that they can look
at it at the age of the link how long
has that link been there
humans do the same thing when we look to
see how long someone has been in
business we're looking at credibility
and then of course there are many many
other ongoing refinements that are going
into the search engines evaluations of
links
sometimes the age of the link isn't as
relevant especially when you're looking
for something that has happened very
recently
an old link could mean that it's old
news or that something has changed since
then
so search engines are in a constant
battle
to ensure that people are not gaming the
system
by falsely creating relevance through
linking
the link relevancy and the algorithm is
all about trying to determine
who is the most relevant
and credible within this area
and that is the focus of most search
engine algorithm refinements over the
past few years and it will be into the
future
now this is where i'm going to start
bringing in some screenshots from a link
management program
as a search engine optimizer a link
management program is probably going to
be one of your best friends as you move
along in this industry
in this example this program link decks
that i'm using will track the incoming
links to my website
and it'll also provide a breakdown as to
what type of website
those links are coming from
so i can see how many links i have from
blogs how many links i have from news
sites how many links from wikis how many
links from directories forums social
media
public relations sites articles or
additional resources
then i can also add my competitors and i
can compare
where i stand in terms of the amount of
links from each source
and where my competitors stand
in this way i can be sure that we all
have a similar link profile you see if
my linking profile looks vastly
different than all my competitors
the search engines are going to see that
as well and know that something might be
different with me
good or bad and that's going to raise a
red flag
so i want to look at the linking profile
because every industry and
almost every business is linking profile
is going to be a little different but
especially among industries we see that
linking profiles that is the amount of
links from different sources is going to
be slightly different
for every different type of industry or
business
so this helps me understand where my
links are coming from which is vitally
important because from a business
standpoint
one thing that i've tracked consistently
in analytics is that people will act
differently
and also i can predict which source is
going to send me the best customers
you see just because someone comes from
a link
doesn't mean they're going to buy or
become a customer or
really become a lead
many times they're going to come look at
your information and leave
and based on how they come to your site
whether it's through a blog a directory
a forum or a new site has a lot to do
with how they view your website
and it's all about the context
you see this is what i've learned over
the years is that people will behave
differently based on how they find the
website
what i found is that people from blogs
news sites and articles
they tend to stay longer do more and
have a higher
chance of conversion of becoming a
customer
or a lead
the main reason is because blogs and
articles they have a lot of context
it's an article someone has taken the
time to write some information out and
then link to my site which means there
is a highly contextual reason for
someone to click that link
also what it means is that there's a lot
less competition for that link
when my link is in that article
compare that with social news
or any type of social site
you see when you're on a social site and
you're looking at your social stream of
information
there's a lot of different people
competing for your attention
a lot of different things and it's not
just in one subject area it's usually
from multiple subject areas
and so the context is very low because
there's a lot of different types of
information and the competition for your
attention is very high
because of that people from social
sites or applications
tend to visit more often
but they only tend to view one page and
leave immediately because they're
looking to see
what was interesting and then they move
on to the next subject
that's the difference between how people
react based on where they come from
and so when i'm measuring links
i'm looking to see which links do i have
what's the source
and then how do those sources behave
differently from one another
and why
you see if i find that i'm getting links
from sources that people are staying
longer doing more and converting at a
higher rate then i'm going to continue
to focus on building links in those
areas because it directly affects how i
monetize my website
so
here's a strategy in building links
one of the things i'm looking at is the
source of links
like i said if i can find a link source
that's providing visitors that will stay
look at my content engage with the
content and eventually convert and
convert at a higher rate than other
sources of content or visitors
then i'm going to focus on that source
and so i'm going to look at some high
authority websites whether they're
industry publications news sites
education sites those are what are
considered high authority
blogs articles news sites
that's what i'm looking to do i want to
find the most authoritative website
and sometimes it happens naturally if
people
that work at those websites or manage
those sites if they find you and they
like your content they'll link to it
and that way you can get more
credibility more relevancy
certain people certain organizations
certain websites have more authority in
influence than others it goes back to
the question that i asked you early in
this module
that how do you know if someone is more
authoritative than somebody else
we also have mid authority websites
which you can get some links on and low
authority websites which are very easy
to get links
but here's what i've learned when it
comes to link building
one link
from one high quality website can be
worth hundreds or thousands
of mid to low quality links
ultimately it's about quality
not quantity
one of the things that i will do
utilizing my link software is look at
the context of the link
i want to see how relevant this is
so as i said if i want to find a high
relevant website
what i'm looking for
in terms of this is i want to see the
influence of the domain
as well as the relevance of the domain
those are two factors that we're going
to look at when we're evaluating the
quality of a domain
now as i'm looking at this report here
what influence means is that it is a
high quality website
that within the linking algorithm these
sites have a lot of authority
however they may not be
relevant
so for example
they may have a lot of sites attributing
authority to them
but they may not be relevant to my
industry which is why we have the next
column of keyword relevance
you see when i'm evaluating my links i'm
looking for the sources that are both
influential
and relevant
that means that i've got a link from a
site
that fits the two standards of high
authority it's authoritative and
relevant
now it's good to have links from
authoritative sites that might not be
relevant
it's still authoritative
however to get the full benefit
i want it to be
influential
and relevant
but not to say that i'm not looking for
links from these other sources this is
just a means of measuring what you have
as well as comparing it to your
competitors and other websites
now here's some best practices
when i'm optimizing anchor text i want
to maintain
contextual relevance
so i want to use text
in the text link
and i want to explain to people what
they're linking to
what they're going to find when they
click on that link
if i use an image as a link i'm going to
use an alt attribute because if that
image doesn't show up
that attribute
is necessary to let people know where to
go
but also i do get a little tiny bit of
benefit by using that alt attribute
within the image link
i also want to look at the relevance of
the source page that i'm linking to and
make sure contextually the link the link
text and the content of the page is
contextually relevant to the destination
page
i also want to be sure that i don't over
use the keywords that i don't make
multiple links
to the same destination that i don't use
the same anchor text over and over
i can be downgraded or even penalized by
the search engine algorithm if that is
found on my pages
so as an example
instead of using click here
for a how-to article
i might use the exact phrase of how to
fix
whatever it is and use that as the link
to the page that has the content
that's a simple way of looking at anchor
text
am i directing someone to additional
information
if i am then how can i present it to
them so they know exactly what they're
going to find
and link it appropriately
i look at as developing the next step
for your readers where do you want them
to go what do you want them to do
what resources do you have available to
them
how can you structure them so that
they're easily understood and you're
explaining the final destination
like i said if you over use anchor text
you can be downgraded or
penalized by the search engines
so what i will tell you to do is number
one avoid overstuffing anchor content
that means
needlessly repeating keywords in the
anchor text
don't do that avoid being redundant
meaning don't have four or five or six
links with the same anchor text going to
the same page
that's a clear way of letting search
engines know that you're going overboard
don't just randomly place links
throughout your text
just to get the link
ask yourself are you really helping the
reader find the information they need
and do it once and then also avoid
extremely overly promotional words
within the linked text such as best
expert cheap number one those types of
things
so a couple examples we can save for
travel advice click here
but i would say
here is my travel advice and link travel
advice
rewrite it be creative
if it were easy everyone would be doing
it
but this is where you can write things
in a better way to get the attention of
the reader and position it as a resource
also utilizing your url as the link
air as the anchor text as well for the
link in order to get that click
as i've got it here i would not
recommend that you use that i would
recommend that you avoid that
also the third line the check out the
best website for iphones and iphone
accessories utilizing overly promotional
words
is one of those ways that you can easily
get caught by the search engines
now for future considerations when it
comes to links
realize that the majority of algorithm
changes are link based evaluation
refinements
because people are constantly attempting
to fool the search engines and develop a
false
link profile
you should
work to create high quality links with
high quality content
i wouldn't chase after poor or low
quality links
now as i've mentioned before there are a
number of tools available for you to
manage and measure your backlinks
tools such as link decks moz raven
advanced link manager majestic seo and
then also you can use your google
analytics as well
however google analytics only shows you
the visitors that have come from links
and what they've done
the basic functions of link management
software and there are many other types
other than what are listed here
but the first thing that it does
is just provide a catalog
of incoming links from other domains
to your site and your competitor sites
they offer tools for comparison to see
which domains are linking to you what
type of link it is and on which pages
those links are listed they'll also
report newly acquired links in the past
30 60 90 days or something similar to
that
the purpose of link management software
is to help you assess
high quality domains versus low quality
domains in terms of importance and
relevance
like i said the first job of a link
management tool is to collect all of
your backlinks
you add your domain and the tools will
usually spider the domain they'll go out
into search engines and go out into many
other formats in order to find and
retrace who is linking to you
what page that link is contained
sometimes what text is on that page and
what text is being used in the link they
will catalog all of your incoming links
organize them
format them and report back to you most
of these link programs provide
additional filters and management tools
so that you can get more insights about
who is linking to you
how they are linking to you and the type
of site
personally i use link decks in order to
monitor and
report on my back linking
so the first report here that i'm
showing out of link decks is that i see
the total amount of incoming links to my
domain
this says i have over two thousand links
and those two thousand links are on
about one thousand domains
on average it looks like i have about
two links from every domain that is
linking to me so this is one way that
you start to look at your links number
one the total amount of domains that are
linking to you and then the total amount
of links available this way you can
isolate domains that are linking to you
consistently and also find those that
may not be the best domains or that are
sending a lot of links that are just not
relevant
the next thing i do in analyzing my
links is to look at the type of link
meaning the type of site that it's
coming from
this report breaks down the amount of
links coming from blogs
news sites directories forums
social sites articles or resources now
it doesn't usually get all of those
links but it does get enough to give you
an idea of how well you're doing any
channel
one of the things that i do like about
this report is it also has a timeline so
i can look and see when new links have
been acquired and maybe when some links
have been
just disappeared that's called churn and
it's normal it's normal because many
times a link is published on social
media and it kind of just goes away or
it's not tracked anymore by your link
management software it can't find it
anymore
and so linking is always dynamic
you are always gaining new links and
losing old links
there's going to be
a normal amount of churn
the next report shows me all of the
domains that are linking to me it also
shows me in the next column how many of
those domains are also linking to at
least one competitor and it will list as
many competitors of i have listed in
here if they list to multiple
competitors
it will let me know the influence of
that site
or the authority that site is seen
because of the amount of websites and
credibility that authority has for that
domain
it also let me know the keyword
relevance how relevant that website is
overall
contextually to my domain and the
content that i have it will also let me
know how many pages on that domain have
links to my website
so i can also go through and i can
filter this list by the type of site
i can filter by those domains that are
using anchor text to see how much anchor
text is being used and what type of
anchor text there are many different
ways that you can filter through all of
the domains that are linking to you
in order to get an idea of what's
happening on your domain
what are competitors doing
and also the relevance of those links to
your site
now when i say that i can add
competitors this is another type of
report very similar to the one i showed
earlier where i look at my own standing
in the different types of sources of
links such as blogs directories forums
and so on
i can also when i add my competitors
look to see how they are performing in
those different areas as well and so i
can compare my link profile to my
competitors
different industries are going to have
different backlink profiles they might
be more heavily weighted towards blogs
or they might be more heavily weighted
towards forums or social sites in this
way i can look to see if my competitors
are actively link building and how
they're going about it i can see where
maybe they are excelling in one area
that the rest of the competitors are not
so i can compare different strategies i
can also compare different timelines to
see if i am acquiring links at a faster
rate than my competitors
this is very important if you are a
newer business or a newer website trying
to compete
now specifically what i can do is look
at an individual domain in this case
this domain has three pages linking to
me and that domain also links to two of
my competitors
i can look at the specific pages and
what i'm looking at here are snippets
this should be familiar to you because
what it's showing is the url of the page
that's linking to my page it shows me
the page title of that page
and then in this report it lets me know
if there are any keywords being used in
the link in the anchor text
as well as the number of links from that
page
now what this tells me is that this is
most likely a directory
something that is listing all the
different places that where you can buy
products
because it's most likely linking to the
domain name
seeing that there are no keywords being
used in anchor text
and also that there are 16 outbound
links from that page
that means that it must be a list of
some sort
and they are linking not only to me but
most likely to competitors as well
so i can track my links at the domain
level
and at the page level i can look to see
which pages might have more influence or
relevance to my content i can also see
the link url the page title
if any keywords are being used in the
anchor text and also within the context
of how many additional links are leaving
from that page
if there are a high amount of outgoing
links on that page then a link from that
page might not be as valuable since
there are so many links the less links
there are coming out from that page the
more it will benefit my site because i'm
getting more benefit from less links
now also what i'm going to do is compare
the link reports to my analytics i'm
going to go to my analytics because
linking software does not show traffic
it doesn't show how many people are
clicking on the link it only shows who's
linking to you but it does not show
visitor activity analytics will show you
visitor activity to see which domains
are most effective in sending visitors
to your site you go back to the primary
benefits of linking visitors
branding and business
analytics show me visitors and business
it shows me which domains are sending me
visitors and which of those visitors are
becoming customers
so what i can do is go to google
analytics
look at all the domains that are
referring traffic to my site i can also
click on the domain and see the
destination page that they are linking
to i can see how many visitors are
coming either monthly or annually how
often they're coming back whether
they're new users or repeat users
how long they stay how many pages they
view and how many conversions as a
result of those visits
this is a great way to get a 360 degree
view of your linking because not only do
you want links that will help you rank
better you also want links that will
send business and customers to you as
well
building links can take many forms
ideally it is through networks
relationships and marketing that other
websites and users learn about you
like you
and recommend you to others
unfortunately there is a lot of bad
outdated and untrustworthy advice to be
found about building links to your
website
in this section
i'll present the best practices as
accepted by the omcp standard
the objectives for this module that
you'll be able to develop a link
building strategy
that you'll understand the value of
different link types
finally you'll be able to find inbound
link opportunities
the first step in building links is to
evaluate what you have
now there are many tools available that
you can utilize to do this for you there
are automated tools that you can get
that will catalog all of the incoming
links to your website
some of them are link decks
moz
raven or advanced link manager there are
many that can do that
you may also want to utilize your
analytics as well
in order to find
websites that link to you
the first step is evaluating where you
are right now
your incoming links have a significant
impact on your rankings
and you can do a lot of on-page
optimization and see some results
however
a lot of google's algorithm
takes into account links from other high
quality websites
now when you evaluate what you have
in this example i'm showing you a
screenshot from link decks
link decks catalogs the incoming links
to my website
and it groups them into different areas
the first way it groups them is by high
value or high influence domains
those are websites that link to me
that have a lot of influence
not necessarily in my industry
but high influence based on the amount
of people that link to them as an
authority
on many different subjects
the next way that it groups that
is based on relevance
now this is when
it looks at
the match of my content
versus the content of the other website
in the first example we can see the
national library of medicine
it is a high influence website because
it is a government website with a lot of
information
that is cited frequently
because of the amount of other websites
linking to that site
it has a high amount of influence
now based on the website that i am
measuring
there is a lot of keyword relevance
meaning that that national library of
medicine site with the government has a
lot of content that's very similar to my
site a lot of the same keywords are
being used
so not only is this website of high
influence it also has a lot of relevance
and that's key when evaluating my
backlinks
i want to look at which websites are
also referring traffic
so while i may have a link from the
national library of medicine
i want to look at my analytics and look
to see is it also providing visitors
are visitors following that link to my
site and i also want to look at the
quality of traffic that it produces
do these visitors
stay longer than average
do they convert more than average i want
to look at the quality of traffic based
on the source
next i want to look at the incoming
links from those other websites
number one i want to make sure that the
incoming link from the other site is
both accurate and relevant
meaning the text that is used in the
link is it accurate to the content
that will appear on the page
when the visitor clicks that link
is the content relevant
this is especially relevant if i have
updated my website changed the content
or moved things around
i want to be sure that that incoming
link sends visitors to the appropriate
page
and the appropriate information
i also want to ensure that that link is
worded correctly
that it uses the right words
that is sending visitors and setting
expectations of the content that they
will see i may need to contact the
website manager or owner and maybe ask
for a better link text
or
a more accurate page destination
now this requires some interaction with
the
owner or manager of another website and
you always want to be respectful of
their time
and not demanding that they make any
changes
in some cases the organization may be so
big you may never find the right person
in order to optimize the text
or the destination of that link
you always want to look for accuracy
in cases where your company or website
name is utilized in the link
but also if there is any contact
information such as address phone number
a description of your business and any
content
make sure it's accurate and it all
points to the right place
another way to look for links
is to simply go to a search engine and
start doing searches
search for your company your business
your company name and look for websites
that may mention you
but do not have a live link to your
website
many times your company will be
mentioned or cited but there will not be
a live link
you can only find these through doing
searches and seeing which websites
mention you without linking to you
now this could be an opportunity to get
an easy link especially if you can find
some contact information and finding the
right person
that could add
a link to your company information
again you'll need to be polite
ask for their help
and it will help it if you can develop
the link
along with the link text and send that
over
giving them just a quick and easy edit
to be able to add the information
so make it as easy as possible
as an example i've provided a sample
request format
again you want to be polite
you want to be inviting and respectful
of their time
and their management
sometimes like i said you may find the
right person that can help you
however the larger the company the more
difficult it will be to make this happen
this just requires your patience
and again
being polite and not expecting the
company to do
what you are asking
many times this is just a formality
and sometimes companies will act on it
so be sure to approach this with the
right expectations
the next thing i want to look at are
business listings
these are the easy ways to establish
links and ensure
that
links are where they should be
and also opportunities
look for business directories especially
if your company has a local presence
you can utilize chamber of commerce
lists
association lists or local listings if
they are on websites
see if they offer links that can go to
your website rather than just the list
of businesses that are in the area
even on a larger level you can look for
associations directories or listings
where you can add your business or
double check if your business is there
and always ensure that your business
name
address phone number and url are correct
complete
and consistent with other listings
the next level will require some active
marketing
and that's where you search for
opportunities
you can go out and look for other
resource lists within your industry or
directories of businesses within your
industry
and you can get a link many times
through membership or submitting your
business as a resource
however
you may want to step up your marketing
you can do that by interviewing your
clients
seeing if they might be willing to
provide a testimonial and a link to your
website
you may also want to go out and find
other communities online maybe some
social communities that are relevant to
your industry
get involved with those communities
fill out a profile and get involved by
contributing information
by sharing information you'll find that
people like getting information and
they'll respond by linking to your site
another option is to utilize the tool
that you had for indexing your links
from the first step
you can also add your competitors and
you can look at their backlinks
you can look and see which websites and
which domains are linking to your
competitors
but you always need to go and see why
what are those other sites linking to
and what is the nature of that link
sometimes it may exclude you from being
able to
approach competitors backlinks and ask
them for links
however
if they're being linked to by companies
that are
simply stating here are vendors in this
space and they are linking your
competitors and you're not there then it
might make a lot of sense for you to
approach and ask if you can be listed as
well
however be sure that
the links to your competitors are not
from a consumer or customer
relationship in that case it might be
out of line for you to ask for a link
make sure if you approach
anyone who's linking to a competitor and
asking for a link to your site
make sure the context is right and then
it makes sense for them
and that's the ultimate judge of value
does it benefit somebody else
to link to your site
we all know that it will benefit you
but when you present your link request
you need to offer value and a benefit
for others to link to you
so be sure that you present it in a way
that is beneficial
and good for those people that will be
adding the link
they're the ones that have to take the
work to do it
and they're also the ones that are
adding a recommendation for you and your
business
so as always you need to be considerate
and patient
now the best way to build links
is by creating something that people
like
and sharing it
you see the best way to build links
is by creating value
through content or information or
entertainment
you see when people like things
they link to it
if they find a study or a white paper or
research that you performed
they link to it
if you post a infographic that explains
something
and it's attractive
people link to it
you see that's what's most amazing
about linking
i find that when we put most of our
effort into creating content that people
like
that's what builds the most valuable
and the most relevant links and so what
type of content well you can create
infographics videos
top 10 lists or articles
articles with advice or analysis of
market data or even
research that type of content people
love it
and so when you publish it out you
utilize social media to extend the reach
and the visibility of that type of
content
and when
someone likes it they'll link to it and
recommend it to others
now people also like depending upon your
industry or your business
they also like some personality maybe
some humor
people always like expert information
they like the cute this is why pictures
of cats tend to be liked and linked to
more than almost anything else
and also the unexpected
if you can inject any of that
into your content
that just makes it more valuable more
personable
and again more shareable
by other people
and every time someone shares it it
builds a link to your site
you see the best linking is when people
like something
when you create something that people
like and share you might be surprised at
the
many opportunities there are
to get links based on your content
i've seen many many blogs based on
cooking fashion
arts sports
music
and
when people specialize within a specific
topic
they always find an audience
and so anything they publish
builds links
even on certain social media sites such
as pinterest
people upload pictures on
articles and infographics
especially about landscaping flowers
food cars you name it there is a special
interest for anything
and you can develop links from those
social sites to your site
and it can generate traffic
even with a blog
developing articles that talk about
upcoming events new music sports
whatever it is when you create content
that people like
it takes the longest amount of time to
build content for building links
when you develop your own content
that's the biggest investment you'll
make in time and research and writing
and presentation
however
the result is
that when you develop that content
you will receive the best and highest
quality links
and the most valuable
links
are going to be to that content
as i mentioned before one high quality
link can be worth
more than hundreds or thousands
of low quality links
so my best advice is to create content
that people like
that they link to
and that will be high
value links that you'll generate to your
site google tag manager thanks for
joining and let's get started with this
simply learn webinar so let's start out
with
ygtm so let's just say you're sam
and you have your own e-commerce website
you want to understand how people are
interacting with your website well sam
today's world of websites contain a lot
of interactivity everything from videos
to pdf downloads to commenting
to form submissions uh to all sorts of
chat functionality interactivity going
on throughout the website so there's
just a lot that you need to track
outside of just page views and so
really what gtm does is they help you
track all these things i just mentioned
everything from somebody clicking on the
play button of a pdf to somebody
clicking on the submit button of a form
to somebody entering in something on a
chat function so that's what gtm is so
why gtm because it helps us track all
that interactivity so all gtm is is
really allows you to really place a
piece of java code which is just script
and the script that's added to a web
page to collect information so that's
really what a tag is it's just some
script that gets put on a web page in
order for you to collect information
like page views clicks etc and they send
it to third party tools okay so that's
what gtm does it basically allows you to
take all these tags that collect
information and you can use them in gta
so
if you want to for example
collect how many people
you know enter
a
chat functionality and start chatting
well you're going to take that script
and you're going to put it in gtm and
gtm will then allow you to start
tracking that information so that's
really what gtm is it just allows you to
put tags into a container or think of it
as a toy box you have all these toys and
you want to track or you can put all
those those toys or tags in a toy box or
container and we're going to talk a
little bit more about that but before we
get into gtm let's just say
you know you're communicating with your
developer and there's a new user request
on your web page and you want to update
the tag well your developer considering
it's probably a small
update your website is probably gonna
not um hesitate and is gonna go ahead
and turn around and do it normally and
so normally what happens is the
developer's gonna go to the website and
update the tag well what if you have a
few things that you want to track all
those things i mentioned before from
downloads to clicks to
you know somebody checking out to
watching a video well your webmaster
your web developer is going to go well
hold on a second now all these requests
are going to take time i need to put
them into the work queue so to speak
well what happens is when they go into
work queue usually it's going to take
some time and
in some cases you as a marketer need to
launch a campaign and you want to get
that tracking uh added to the website in
time for the campaign launch so you want
to go ahead and quickly turn around the
tracking for that particular campaign
let's just say you're launching a
campaign and you're sending people to a
landing page that has a form submission
and you want to be able to track how
many people click on the submit button
of that form submission well if you need
to turn that around your developer's
like well i need to put that in a work
queue the timing isn't going to always
work out between you and your developer
is my point and so that's where gtm
comes in because there is a solution
update your tags faster and that's
google tag manager so when we say gtm
that's what gtm stands for google tag
manager it's a place for you to add tags
quickly and easily so tags remember are
just snippets of code that allow you to
track things on your website
interactively interactive activity and
basically when you have gtm you can
bypass the webmaster and do it quickly
and easily so
that's what gtm is all about so why gtm
because we just identified two benefits
one you could track all the
interactivity on your website and two
you can bypass your web developer or
webmaster and so that's the benefit of
gtm so the benefit you get those tags
updated very quickly via google tag
manager okay so that's what tag manager
is so what we're going to talk about
today is specifically what tag manager
is and what it does we're going to list
some of the benefits of tag manager
we're going to show you how it works and
then we're going to show you how to get
started with tag manager tag manager if
you're not familiar with working with
webmasters and dealing with javascript
and tags and all this jargon is just new
to you today okay well don't fret sit
back we're gonna take it slow this is an
introduction into google tag manager
again let's start out with what is tag
manager so we've already introduced it
to some degree because we already
introduced is a tool where you can put
all your tags into a toolbox toy box or
container so to speak right and we
already already mentioned that hey you
can bypass your webmaster so you're
probably thinking well if i'm if you're
not familiar with tag manager how can i
bypass my webmaster well first of all
it's a free tool and it's a google tool
hence the name google tag manager and it
helps you really that's the main point
is deploying track tags on your website
by passing your webmaster so that's tag
manager and so examples of tags that can
be deployed via google tag manager are
numerous these are just some examples
like google analytics facebook pixel
tracking or google ads there's no limit
into the number of tags you can track in
tag manager there is no limit you can
add any number of tracking tags and tag
manager okay so some of the benefits
well again i we just listed two you can
put any tag into tag manager and track
that onto your website and we know you
can bypass your web developer or
webmaster and what it also does is it
also allows you to test and deploy your
javascript codes quicker so remember
these javascript codes or snippets of
codes are just there to track certain
things on your website whether that be a
page view or somebody clicking on a play
button or tracking somebody who converts
or even just goes to your website so the
biggest benefit is you can take that
snippet of code let's just say facebook
let's just say you're doing facebook
marketing and you want to put that
facebook pixel on your website so that
you could track people who come from
facebook and convert well you don't need
to put that facebook pixel on your
website you can go right to tag manager
and you can put that snippet of code
right in tag manager really quickly and
the other benefit here is all tags are
managed in one place and that's that to
me is really a good benefit because when
you start adding tags on your website
and you have some tags in tag manager it
just gets very confusing so ideally all
the tracking code you have on your
website needs to be in tag manager think
about that all the tracking so if you're
doing bing or you're doing facebook or
you're doing twitter or you're doing
linkedin and you're doing google you're
doing all this type of marketing on all
these different platforms you're gonna
have tracking code for all these
different platforms and instead of
putting on that code on your website
return gonna slow down the slow time of
your web page and website you wanna put
them all in tag manager so they can be
organized and you know exactly what
you're trying to track and the other
great benefit of tag manager is there's
a versioning control so let's just say
you have added tags to your website via
gtm for the last six months well and
let's just say you add another tag
yesterday if you added that tag
yesterday and something doesn't work
well you can just roll back to a
previous version it's that simple so you
have versioning and that's that's a good
thing when you have versioning you can
control what gets published and if
something doesn't work after it gets
published then you can roll back to a
previous version so it's a a piece of
mind so to speak just because you've
added code to your site there's no
guarantee it's going to work and so you
can always control what version you're
dealing with in tag manager and we'll
talk a little bit more about that so the
biggest benefit here to me with tag
manager is you have event tracking and
so we talked about some of the things
you could track on your website from
videos from play buttons to somebody
clicking on the stop on the video or
pausing it all the way to somebody again
chatting or let's just say somebody
clicking on that purchase button on your
website okay and you want to track all
these different things these different
interactivities and buttons well event
tracking is what you're going to use to
track all those buttons and to me this
is the biggest benefit of tag manager
and i'll show you some examples as we go
along and if we didn't mention it
already i'll mention it again it is free
tag manager is free there's no limit so
once you have tag manager going you can
add as many tracking codes as you want
there's no limit on the number of
tracking codes you can add to tag
manager okay so it's free and you can
use it to its fullest advantage okay so
it's also high security meaning that it
has different levels of permissions okay
so you can have uh somebody just go in
and look at the different tags and
tracking code you have in gtm or you can
have somebody who
is very familiar with tag manager and go
in and add the tracking code to tag
manager and then publish that tracking
code when it gets added so those are all
the benefits let's talk about how it
works now specifically how does tag
manager work because you're like rob
okay again a lot of jargon you know you
you got tags and javascript and
versioning and publishing and all this
other stuff well i know i'm throwing a
lot at you at once but just bear with me
here okay so let's start talking about
how it actually works so you have a
website okay whatever that domain is you
have a website and there's chances are
on your website you have some form of
interactivity whether that be a video
whether that be a blog whether it be a
form submission you have a website with
some interactivity and let's just say
you're even thinking about getting ready
to launch some type of campaign on maybe
google or facebook and you want to drive
traffic to your website fair enough
you're joining the millions of other
websites that are out there that have
interactivity that also drive traffic to
the website so income's google tag
manager and so tag manager is important
because again we know we want to track
people coming from that facebook
campaign or that google campaign and
interacting with our site so if you are
running facebook and you are running
google analytics well guess what you
want to put that tracking code in tag
manager so google analytics being a
google product works very nicely with
tag manager facebook has its own
tracking code but you still want to be
able to track people who come from the
facebook campaign to your website so
you're going to get that tracking code
from facebook and put it in tag manager
that's generally how it works so here
information from your website is shared
with another data source through tag
manager so think about that if i add
facebook tracking code to tag manager or
let's just say i had google analytics
tracking code to tag manager tag manager
is the one that's pushing out and doing
all the heavy lifting they're the ones
that are controlling what code gets
fired and what code doesn't so if you're
putting the code in tag manager tag
manager is controlling the code think
about it that way and let's show you an
example of what that looks like so here
i am i'm in tag manager i just went to
tag manager.google.com
and here i could see a list of tags so
in our conversation we're talking about
tracking facebook and we're talking
about tracking google analytics well
google analytics is easy because it's a
google product so here if i look at all
the different tracking code i have on my
website through tag manager let's just
take a look at google analytics so if
you're going to use tag manager you
might as well put the google analytics
code in here so here i can see i have
google analytics as a tag in tag manager
now for facebook if i'm running a
facebook campaign well i can take that
pixel tracking and put it in gtm as well
and here i can see facebook pixel that
is that code is added to gtm i just
basically took what facebook gave me and
put it into google tag manager so you
can see i can add facebook and google
analytics and again i can't stress it
enough any tracking code from any
platform i can add to google tag manager
in order to track the behavior from
those sources so let's take a little bit
deeper dive into how tag manager works
so i just showed you an example of how
you could take facebook and google
analytics code and put it into tag
manager but if you're not familiar with
tag manager then how do i do that well
let's talk about the structure and how
tag manager works so when you have a tag
manager account you have a container
remember i mentioned toy box earlier you
have a bunch of toys if they're their
code and you're tracking different bits
of code from different platforms like
facebook think of those as toys and you
have a toy box okay well that's what
this code is and that's what a container
is the code is the code and that's going
to go into the toy box or container and
so the way tag manager works is you have
tags triggers and variables so if i take
my facebook tracking code and put it
into a container i need to set up a tag
and a trigger okay so let's take a look
at what that is so first if i go back to
tag manager i'm going to have an account
and if i have an account i'm going to
have a container so here i'm just going
to click on an account with a container
and a container is nothing more than
what website you're adding the tracking
code to okay that's all the container is
we're just letting tag manager know this
is the website we're adding all this
code to so you have tags triggers and
variables that's the structure of tag
manager so tags are just what it says
tags what are we trying to quote unquote
tag well if it's google analytics that's
easy here i can see i have google
analytics added so if i click on google
analytics here's my tag and if i take a
little bit of a deeper dive there since
google analytics is a google product it
integrates already with tag managers
it's pretty easy i can just choose
google analytics then i'm going to check
page view and that's my tag now every
tag needs a trigger okay so i need to
tell tag manager how or when to fire the
google analytics tracking code so in
this case i'm going to tell tag manager
to fire on all pages so if i get
somebody a visitor to my website
analytics is firing on all pages so
whatever page that visitor lands on
google analytics is going to fire so
that's really what it comes down to is i
have a tag and i need to tell tag
manager when to trigger that tag that's
really what the structure of tag manager
is it's tags triggers and variables and
variables what we're going to talk about
here in a couple minutes but you have a
piece of code you're going to go ahead
and put that into tag manager you're
going to tag it and then you're going to
fire that trigger so let's take a look
at another example here if i go back
here you can see facebook well here's my
facebook pixel okay that's my tag so
when is it gonna fire well it's gonna
fire on a specific domain or subdomain
that's basically what we're doing we're
trying to tell gtm when to fire that
particular tag so those are the three
main components a tag okay which is
going to contain the javascript code
that you get from say facebook the
trigger so you're going to go into tag
manager and tell tag manager when to
fire that code that's the trigger and
then you have variables and so variables
are basically just additional
information that tag manager may need
for your tag and trigger to work so
that's what a variable is it's there to
get the tag and trigger to fire so
variables are divided into built-in and
user-defined variables so common used
variables include say page path or page
url or hostname or click class again
they're there and these examples i just
gave you are there to get your tag and
trigger to work think about it that way
they're just that's a component and if i
go into tag manager here and here on the
left side i can see variables so
remember i have built-in and
user-defined
so built-in means that tag manager
already built these for me so in case i
need to get my trigger to work with my
tag i can use a variable so those are
built-in and then i have user-defined so
these are what i define these are what i
created and again the variables are
there to get the tag and trigger to work
okay so that's the job of the variable
the job of the tag is to host that
javascript code okay in the case of
facebook or analytics that's where we're
putting our code so here if i click on
adwords remarketing again it's a google
product so i don't really need to even
deal with code i'm just going to select
google adwords remarketing okay so you
can see gtm integrates nicely with some
of the other google products but let's
just say you have a facebook pixel
tracking code you're gonna choose custom
and you're going to put the code here so
that's part of the tag and then the
trigger again is there to get the tag to
fire so you're telling gtm when to fire
the tag and the variable is there to
help you make sure that that trigger and
that tag work together so that's how all
three kind of work together you need the
tag to put the code you need the trigger
to tell gtm when to fire the tag in code
and the variables there to help you
define when that tag and trigger should
work or how it should work so again
review tags are they're just small codes
of javascript or tracking pixels on your
website and so tags are allowed to
manage events like scroll track and
remarketing clicks downloads files play
buttons you name it even clicks on
external links for example let's just
say you have a click uh or a facebook uh
icon on your site and when somebody
clicks on it they go to facebook you
wanna maybe track that you're to create
a tag okay the trigger is there because
you need to tell gtm when to fire that
tag so it's a certain condition whether
it's you know fire the tag if the url
equals facebook.com or some other
condition so the tag cannot be created
until the creation of the corresponding
trigger so tags and triggers go together
you can't just create a tag and not have
a trigger otherwise your tag will never
fire and then the variable was there
again it stores the information when
defining a trigger or transferring data
to tag so a variable has a variety of
data okay so you pick and choose the
variable you want to use with that
trigger okay so you're making sure that
by defining a variable you're making
sure that you're telling gtm how that
trigger should be fired so let's take a
look at another example here of how all
three play together if i'm in this
account i'm in this container if i look
down here i can see google optimize
that's another google product so
what i'm doing here is i just chose
google optimize as my tag it's already
integrated so what does that mean i
don't even need to deal with any code
i'm just going to select optimize well
we have the tag google optimized but we
need to tell gtm how to fire that and so
here we're going to tell gtm to fire it
on all pages so that's basically a very
simple example because we're firing it
on all pages so if i want to look at
something specific again facebook here's
my tag here's my code what's my trigger
well my trigger is it's gonna fire on
specific pages how do i know that well
if i look at the trigger here i could
see the trigger is a page view but i'm
telling it to fire on this particular
hostname so the tag and trigger go hand
in hand
so how to get started with tag manager
so first things first you have to create
that account so you're going to go to
tag manager.google.com
or you can do a search for google tag
manager and you're going to create your
account and then when you create your
account what's going to happen is you're
going to
set up a container and when you set up a
container you have choices so you could
set it up for your website for an app on
ios or maybe android or you can even set
it up for amp etc an accelerated mobile
page so most people by default are
probably going to set up tag manager for
their website and so when you do that
when you actually select website what's
going to happen is you're going to get
some google tag manager code in return
and so the whole idea here is you're
going to do a swap what you're doing is
basically you're saying okay google i'm
going to take this google tag manager
code and i'm going to put it on my
website i'm going to put it on every
page in my website so notice tag manager
has two scripts one goes in the head as
high as possible the other goes into the
body tag as high as possible and so what
you're doing is you're making a deal
you're putting this tag manager code on
your website and in return every code
you deal with whether that be facebook
or analytics or optimize or remarketing
or whatever it is is gonna go in gtm
okay it's gonna go into the container
you created so you need the tag manager
code on your website in order for tag
manager to work okay so when you add
this code to your website then you're
free to start adding all sorts of tags
to your container but if you don't have
this tracking code on your website then
none of the tags you add to your
container are gonna work so that's the
idea behind the container and then one
thing i wanted to mention on the account
is it's a google account so when you
create your account then make sure it's
the same account you use with say google
analytics or some other google product
that's a good best practice is always
use the same email address when you set
up your account so that it integrates
nicely across all the different
platforms meaning you can go from say
google analytics right to google tag
manager in one browser without having to
log out or log in okay so when you
create the account you're going to
create your container if you choose web
then you're going to be asked to place
code on your website and when you place
that code on your website then you are
free to start using tag manager and that
means you're free to start adding tags
so if you want to know more information
about installing google tag manager then
what i would recommend is visit the
quick start guide website of gtm so
again if you're curious as to where that
code is located in google tag manager
well when you create an account and you
create a container that container is
going to have a specific id so if i
click on that specific id here's where i
can get my code okay so again
when i'm logged in to tag manager i'm
going to click on workspace but in the
top navigation i'm going to see my
unique gtm id if i click on that that's
where my code is going to be located and
so again your code needs to go in the
header and there's another script that
needs to go in the body and if you're
not sure how to add the code to your
website well you can always click on the
quick start guide here okay and that'll
take you to a quick start guide page a
reference page related to google tag
manager so let's talk about creating a
tag so once you get tag manager
installed i'm sure you're excited to get
going and create that first tag so let's
talk about how to create a tag in tag
manager so when you're in tag manager
all you need to do is basically you're
looking at all your tags if you click on
tag in the left side navigation you'll
see all your tags and there's a new
button there so you just click new and
so basically what you're going to do is
you're going to create your first tag
and so what i would recommend once you
get tag manager installed on your
website i would recommend setting the
first tag up as google analytics so that
will get you going with tracking page
views on your website when some when
somebody visits your website okay so
ideally that's what you want to do you
want to get google analytics as your
first tag and tag manager so what i'm
going to do is because analytics is a
google product it's already integrated
nicely with tag manager so i'm just
going to click on google analytics it's
going to be a page view that's what i'm
tracking and now i have to set up a
variable and so what it's going to do
it's going to ask me to sort of select a
variable and so what you're going to do
is you're going to select new variable
and what you're going to do is you're
actually going to go and add your
tracking id here that's going to be your
variable so where do i get my tracking
id and analytics well if i'm in
analytics i'm going to go to admin and
then under property settings i'm going
to see my tracking id and all you need
to do then is go to tag manager and
paste copy first you got to copy over
that tracking id then you're going to go
to tag manager and paste it and then
that's going to create a variable for
you and then when you create that
variable you're going to see it in the
drop down here so i've already created
it and
basically that's your tag with a
variable then what are you going to do
you're going to set up a trigger so see
i have some triggers already set up
you're going to see a default trigger
already set up for you and that's going
to be all pages so ideally what you want
to do is you want to select all pages in
order for analytics to fire on all pages
so that's what we're doing we're setting
up a trigger we're basically telling tag
manager hey if i get a visitor to any
page on my website then i want you to
fire google analytics so that's
basically in summary how to set up your
first tag and my recommendation is your
first tag should be google analytics and
when you set up analytics you're gonna
have to set up a variable for the
tracking id and so you get the tracking
id again from admin property settings
copy and paste that tracking id over
save it you have your variable that
variable is going to be included in with
the tag then your trigger is going to be
all pages and there you go you have your
first tag you have your first variable
you have your first trigger so that's
basically what you want to do and once
you've added that tag once you've added
that trigger then the only thing you
need to do now is basically publish the
tag and so anytime you save a tag you're
going to go ahead and submit it so that
way it gets published so again what
you're going to do is let's take a step
back here you're going to choose new tag
you're going to choose analytics from
the drop down menu you're going to
choose page view then basically you're
going to add your tracking id so you can
set up the variable and then basically
that's what you need to do okay you're
going to add that tracking id and then
voila that's your tag with a variable
and then once you've done that then
you're going to click submit so when you
click submit you're basically saying hey
i want this tag to go live now this tag
and trigger and once you've done that
then analytics is ready to go and
anytime somebody goes to your website on
any page tag manager is going to fire
google analytics so the great thing here
is you have something called google tag
assistant and that's an extension that
works with chrome and so when you've
actually added tag manager to your site
or you have analytics running in tag
manager you can confirm if those tags
are firing properly so let's take a look
at how google tag assistant works okay
so if you just do a search for google
tag assistant you're gonna see here that
it's basically just an extension that
works in chrome and unfortunately it
only works in chrome browser it doesn't
work in any other browser so go ahead
and install that extension into chrome
and when you do that you're gonna see
this nice icon here in your browser and
now if you go to any website and i click
on google tag assistant and i click on
enable okay so basically i'm loading
google tag assistant and now once i
refresh the page i can see that this
particular site has google tag manager
installed and not only does it have tag
manager installed i can see that it's
also has google analytics running i have
also google optimize running and i have
google ads remarketing tag running in
tag manager so that's what tag assistant
does it allows you to see
if one tag manager is on the site and if
it is great what other tags are firing
on this particular site so tag
assistant's telling me i have these
particular tags firing on that site and
they're firing within tag manager so tag
assistant is a great way to confirm if
one tag manager is on the site and two
what other tags are firing on the site
now another way you could confirm if tag
manager is firing on the site is you can
go into preview mode so even before you
submit and publish your tag and trigger
you can click on the preview mode so if
i click preview in tag manager so
basically that's going to put me in
preview mode and so what does that mean
well that means that now i'm free to go
to my website and see if those tags are
firing and so let's take a look at what
that looks like so if i go to the
website and just click refresh then
what's going to happen is tag manager is
going to load in preview mode just as
you see here okay so that's going to
take a second couple seconds to load up
and now what can i see in preview mode i
could see that
i have gtm firing but i also have some
other tags firing on this page
remarketing i have google analytics i
google optimize i have some other tags
firing as well and so the preview mode
shows me what tags are firing on any
given page and i can also see what tags
did not fire okay so here i have a
number of tags already in gtm but they
didn't fire on this particular page so
let's just say i clicked on the donate
now button i'm still in preview mode so
i'm gonna be able to see what tags fired
now i could see i have a couple of tags
that have fired on this particular page
and then i can see what tags did not
fire on this page okay
so that's the preview mode you can use
the preview mode before you even submit
a tag and trigger to see if it fires and
that's the great benefit of tag manager
so if you're not sure if something's
going to fire or not then you can always
go into preview mode um and if you are
sure it's going to fire then you can go
ahead and submit it so you can leave
preview mode and just go ahead and
submit that particular tag and trigger
so here i'm going to leave preview mode
and now once i'm done and i'm sure the
tag is going to fire and go ahead and
submit all my changes that i've worked
on in terms of setting up tags and
triggers so that's really gtm in a
nutshell so i have my tags okay my tags
are just snippets of code that i'm going
to put in whether that be facebook or
vet tracking or any other google product
like optimize or page view then i have
my triggers my triggers are there to
tell gtm when to fire that tag and the
variables are there to help those tags
and triggers work together so remember
that particular variable we set up for
google analytics okay so here it is
right here because we want to tell gtm
what property
to specifically fire in google analytics
so that's why we set up that variable
but there are all sorts of variables
google tag manager has built in or
variables already created for you or you
can specifically define a variable so
variables are there to help the tags and
triggers work together so when you set
up a tag you set up a trigger you use a
variable you can always go into preview
mode preview it by going to the website
seeing if it fires if it fires then
voila you can go ahead and click submit
and that will publish the tag and
trigger and you're good to go that's
pretty much how tag manager works and
again i can't stress
that there's an unlimited number of tags
you can add to tag manager there's no
limit so you got everything from
anything from google to non-google to
event tracking okay to facebook to
anything that you want to track you want
to be able to put into tag manager and
again there's versioning that's one of
the great benefits of tag manager so if
i want to go back to an older version i
can simply do that so here you can see
i'm on version 32. that's how tag
manager works and
i can't stress that you know tag manager
is there to help you track interactivity
on the site because if you have a site
that's interactive that has a video
that has a download button let's just
say you know you have all sorts of
newsletter sign ups facebook youtube
buttons on your website just like this
website does and you won't be able to
track how many people click on that
particular button well you're going to
need tag manager and when you have tag
manager you're going to be able to track
all of these button clicks and
interactivity on your website choose
from over 300 in-demand skills and get
access to 1 000 plus hours of video
content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more we're going to
talk about how to rank number one on
google so let's get started and
let's go with the scenario that you have
a friend named sam and he has a website
where he sells shoes but sam doesn't
understand why his website's not ranking
number one on google and so typically
ranked number one on google there are
some factors involved and those are
factors that are going to help sam get
his website ranked number one on google
so he can sell his shoes get traffic and
convert that traffic to conversions so
there are factors involved and so what
are those factors well it always starts
with keyword research so in order to
rank for a website where you sell shoes
or
you sell products other products like
clothing or food or
you're an automobile website you're a
mechanic it doesn't matter whether
you're selling to customers or selling
to other businesses you have to start
with the keyword research and so we're
going to go into really explicit detail
on how to conduct a proper keyword
research and then the second factor
involved is high quality content so in
order to rank high on google search you
need to have high quality content so
we're going to go over
what's involved with creating high
quality content then we're going to
take that content we're going to
optimize it using on-page elements and
website level factors so we're going to
take into account what's involved with
your website and what's involved with
specific pages on your website in order
to rank number one on google then we're
gonna get into the off-site engagement
so when it comes to ranking on google
you need to optimize your website and
you need to do
some elements off your website you need
to be engaging off your website meaning
on other websites and so we're going to
talk about what's involved with offsite
engagement so seo being a major channel
for most companies and websites where
the opportunity to drive a lot of
traffic is there but you have to earn
that reward the reward is a lot of
traffic but you have to earn the reward
there's a lot of work involved and so
ideally what we want to do is follow
what we call the 80 20 rule when it
comes to search engine optimization and
ranking on google and what do we mean by
the 80 20 rule well 80 20 means we're
investing 20 of our effort and 80
percent of the results are obtained so
we want to invest 20 and get back 80.
that's basically what we mean by 80 20.
so for example if 20 of our targeted
keywords bring in 80 of the traffic then
that's following the 80 20 rule or
twenty percent of our landing pages
drive eighty percent of the overall
traffic that's following the 80 20 rule
or twenty percent of our backlinks past
eighty percent of our link juice that's
the 80 20 rule meaning these targeted
keywords these targeted landing pages
these trying to target backlinks using
off-site engagement we want to put in 20
percent of our effort on those keywords
landing pages and backlinks in return
for 80 percent of the results so without
further ado let's get started with the
keyword research let's talk about that
keyword research for a website with
shoes and it doesn't really matter
what particular product you have if you
need to rank number one on google it all
starts with the keywords as i mentioned
before and so
in this example if you have a website
where you sell shoes for kids you're
going to want to be found for certain
keywords so the obvious keyword here
would be shoes for kids well every
keyword that you target has search
volume associated with it so that means
when we talk about search volume we're
talking about how many people on average
type in that keyword or related keyword
on google.com or google search and
there's always an average number of
searches associated with every keyword
and we call that search volume how much
search volume so obviously if we're
going to target a keyword we want to
have as much volume as possible however
there's always going to be
competition for those keywords meaning
there's always going to be other
websites who want to rank number one on
google for the same keywords and we call
that competition or difficulty so for
every keyword you're going to have
volume and you're going to have
competition or difficulty and the
difficulty ranges as well depending on
the tool you use and we'll get into that
in a minute but search volume is how
much on average people are typing in
that keyword or close variance of that
keyword and the difficulty is measured
in terms of how many other websites are
trying to rank for the same keyword and
so ideally when it comes to keyword
research we want to find that nice
balance we want high volume and we want
low competition but at the same time we
want to focus on keywords that are
highly relevant to our business so if
we're selling shoes for kids and shoes
for kids is highly relevant has high
volume and low competition then that's a
keyword we want to target so we always
want to focus in on those three areas so
there's always a trade-off with keywords
so shoes for kids might have high volume
but also might have high competition or
difficulty if we look for another
keyword that's just as relevant for
example shoes for children it may still
have high search volume but the
competition or the difficulty may be
lower and if that's the case then that
may be a better keyword for us to target
instead of something highly competitive
like shoes for kids we can focus on
another relevant keyword like shoes for
children with just as much volume and
lower competition and the reason why we
want lower competition is because we
want to be able to rank for that keyword
so the higher the competition the harder
it is for us to rank number one on
google for that keyword and so the whole
idea beyond keyword research is
analyzing and choosing the best keywords
so we want to identify a list of
keywords that are always relevant we
want to choose the keyword that your
competitors are ranking for and we want
to use third-party tools to choose
keywords to identify which keywords have
low competition and what keywords have
high search volume so one thing to take
into consideration when you're doing
keyword research is that the longer the
keyword phrase or in other words long
tail keywords or keywords with three
keywords in the phrase or more you're
going to always have less competition
but there's always a trade-off with
long-tail keywords meaning the longer
the keyword phrase there's going to be
less volume but the trade-off is less
competition and so what we want to do is
we want to brainstorm some ideas and
find those relevant keywords so let's
look at an example here so if we go to
google ads so google ads has a tool
called keyword planner and let's just
say i have a
a website where i'm selling dried figs
and if i'm selling dried figs i want
people to buy these dried figs however
in order to attract them i want to be
able to show them that hey we have a a
bunch of recipes and if i show you a
bunch of recipes where you can use dried
figs maybe you'll buy these dried figs
to use in these recipes and so we're
going to look for
keywords related to bread recipes
because if we can optimize for our
recipes page for bread then that will
attract an audience who wants to make
bread and use dried figs with those
bread recipes so that's the example i'm
going to give here and so if i look at
the keyword planner in google ads if i
just type in bread recipes what google
is going to do is they're going to give
me an average monthly search volume so i
can see the average monthly search
volume here is 60 500 and so in order to
do keyword research what i would
recommend is keep a spreadsheet and so
the idea behind the spreadsheet is to
document the volume and the competition
you're getting for certain keywords so
if i go into a spreadsheet here my theme
of keywords is bread recipes my keyword
is bread recipes and my volume therefore
is going to be 60 500. however if i go
back into google's keyword planner
google is telling me the competition is
low so that's great i want high volume i
want low competition but how low is low
so we want to be careful so if we're
going to put in numbers into a
spreadsheet we want to figure out what
that competition really is for the
keyword bread recipes so if i go to
google and just type in bread recipes
i'm going to be able to see
771 billion results for the keyword
bread recipes now with
billion are real competition maybe maybe
not what we want to do is put in a
syntax and we want to put in the syntax
all in title and then colon space and
then our keyword and the reason why we
do that in search is because we want to
be able to identify the true competitive
number or the true number of websites
who are trying to rank for bread recipes
and if we put in the syntax all entitled
colon and then our keyword bread recipes
we'll be able to see that there are 998
000 results that's a lot lower than 771
billion so that means that 998
000
sites or listings have the keyword bread
recipes in the title tag and the title
tag is what shows up in the search
engine results and so if i look down and
scroll down here i can see bread recipes
on every one of these title tags so
title tag is an important element to
rank number one on google and we'll talk
about that in a few minutes but if we
understand that there are 998 000
results with bread recipes in the title
tag then this tells us that those are
the websites who are trying to rank
number one on google for that keyword
and therefore those are the websites we
need to jump over in order for our
website to rank number one on google and
so therefore i'm going to put in 998
000 in my spreadsheet as the competitive
number and so now i can see for the
keyword bread recipes i have 60 500 and
if my competition is 998 000 then my kei
or keyboard effectiveness index or in
other words the ratio of volume to
competition is six percent so that's
nothing more than volume divided by
competition so that tells me that my kei
or my ratio between volume competition
is six percent so remember we want more
volume than we want competition so
anytime you do a keyword research you're
going to find a number of different
relevant keywords so if i go back into
google's keyword planner if i typed in
bread recipes you could see that
google is going to give me a number of
different keywords related to bread
recipes let's just say i have another
keyword that i want to think about
optimizing for being ranked on google
for and that's banana bread recipe very
similar keyword as bread recipes except
it's a little longer tail now if i type
in banana bread recipe in google's
keyword planner now i can see the
average monthly search volume has
actually gone up it's 368
000. i can also see the competition is
low so those are good signs so now i can
see 368 000 i'm going to go ahead and
put that in my spreadsheet now i'm going
to go into google i'm going to put in my
syntax all in title i'm going to put in
banana bread recipe i'm going to hit
enter and now i can see i have 233 000
results with the keyword banana bread
recipe in the title tag so if i look at
the title tags i can see banana bread
recipe banana bread recipe banana bread
recipe on all the listings in the google
search results so that tells me i have
233
000 results that i have to jump over in
order to rank number one on google so
i'm going to put 233 000 in my
spreadsheet now i can see my kei or my
volume to competition ratio is 157 158
and so to me that's a lot better number
to work with or in other words that's a
lot better keyword because it's just as
relevant and it has a higher ratio of
volume to competition so therefore
banana bread recipe is going to be a
better keyword to optimize for in order
to rank number one on google so that's
the whole idea behind keyword research
you want to brainstorm ideas there are
plenty of tools out there so the tool i
recommend is google ads keyword planner
google's going to give you
how much search volume they're going to
tell you the competition but then you're
going to go into google search you're
going to use the syntax on title to get
a more accurate read on the actual
competitive number and so to find out
how keywords that your competitors are
ranking for you can use those keyword
tools that i mentioned another tool that
i use is miles so moz if you go to
moz.com
they have a tool called keyword explorer
so if we just type in the keyword for
example red recipes it's going to be
able to tell us how much volume and the
difficulty so you can use other tools at
your disposal figure out the volume and
the difficulty there are plenty of tools
out there but the one thing i would just
make sure is you use everything at your
disposal so you can use social media to
find the most shared article for a
particular topic or keyword like bread
recipes you could check other platforms
that have a lot of shared content like
reading and cora where you can ask
people about certain topics using
keywords to figure out how much
competition or volume there might be you
can stay up to date on industry news to
get an idea of what types of keywords
are trending but when it comes to
keywords and keyword research remember
for every web page we want to be able to
pick two keywords we want a primary and
secondary keyword so when we do keyword
research and we enter all our keywords
into our spreadsheet we want to be able
to have a number of different keywords
in this case we're focusing on the theme
bread recipes we want to have different
keywords because we want to be able to
choose a primary keyword and a secondary
keyword because we want to be able to
focus on multiple keywords for each page
because we don't want to put necessarily
all our eggs in one basket maybe we
won't want to put our emphasis just on
one keyword to rank for we want multiple
keywords to try and rank for so the
primary key work and define the nature
of our business the secondary keyword
could be just highly relevant to our
keyword at the end of the day we want to
choose multiple keywords to try and rank
on google for that page so for example
we have a blog and we're using ice cream
recipes and we're blogging about ice
cream recipes we can have a primary
keyword that is about ice cream recipes
or homemade ice cream recipes we're
going to always want to find out what
the volume and the competition is our
secondary keyword could be built around
other similar keywords like low-fat ice
cream recipes or fat-free ice cream
recipes or low-fat homemade ice care
recipes those are complementary keywords
just like our bread recipes and banana
bread recipe so one thing we want to do
when we do keyword research is we want
to be able to target one keyword per
content when you can target many we want
to be able to target multiple keywords
not necessarily target one keyword and
so we want to be able to cluster
keywords so we don't want to target just
one we want to target multiple keywords
per page and when we talk about
clustering if we go back to
our keyword research what we're doing is
we're clustering a bunch of keywords
under the theme bread recipes and so by
looking at the volume looking at the
competition looking at the kei we can
choose different keywords for our page
and that's what we mean by clustering we
want to cluster keywords into a content
theme so why target only one keyword per
content when we can target many because
we don't want to put all our eggs in one
basket we don't want to target just one
keyword we want to target many and so
that means clustering your keywords into
a theme and choosing multiple keywords
for that particular page and when we do
that we have a better opportunity to
rank high on google search and the whole
idea behind ranking high on google
search is we can get the volume so if we
know we're ranked number one on google
search for bread recipes or banana bread
recipe we know we stand a chance of
getting a majority of the volume
associated with that keyword and if we
can get the volume and get the traffic
then we can get the conversions so let's
move on to high quality content and talk
about the impact content has on your
ability to get your website ranked
number one on google so
let's just say you have content on your
website and the content is ranking on
you know page four of google and it's
that blog with ice cream recipes and if
it's just content for the sake of
content is not really informative then
it's not necessarily going to get good
engagement in the eyes of google you
know they want to rank content that's
very informative it's very fresh it's
exciting to read it's interesting it's
going to have good engagement so if it's
a recipe or an article about any topic
if it's the content is just not
informative then you're not going to get
good engagement and when you don't get
good engagement if people don't stay on
the site to engage in the content and
they just leave the website after
landing on the page causing a bounce
then the content is just going to
continue to fall down the rankings and
we want to prevent that we want to move
up the rankings we want to be number one
on google we don't necessarily want to
fall in the rankings for our content so
content is a key driver
in being able to rank number one on
google so if the content is on page nine
what can we do well we want to be able
to you know take that content and do
something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media
and to me social media is a good
platform to share your content because
on social media platforms like facebook
for example you're building a community
on that platform that community is
already interested in your content so if
you're sharing an ice cream recipe
especially in the summer time and you're
engaging with your community on that
platform then the likelihood of that
community on that platform is going to
increase engagement increased engagement
will send social signals to the search
engine that says hey this content is
good quality likewise for any other
platform most social media platforms
have engagement metrics and those
engagement metrics pass signals is it
good is it not good do we like this
content are we giving it a thumbs up are
we going to want to follow it are we
going to want to share it and so
if you share content that you feel is
engaging on social platforms then it's
going to be engaging and it's likely
going to cause an increase in engagement
for example a decrease in bounces and
once you share that quality content then
the likelihood of it moving up the
rankings even as far as number one on
google is going to be greater so you
always want to start out writing good
quality content so let's talk about good
quality content because google does take
content seriously they do take into
account what other people think of that
content so high quality content is an
important factor so how to create good
content that's always the question so
let's talk about some best practices
here remember in the last segment we
talked about keyword research so we want
to perform good keyword research why
because we want to choose keywords
remember we're choosing multiple
keywords per page one keyword could be
related to our brand one keyword could
be related to the content but another
keyword could be related to a user's
intent like recipes if you recall the
example we use with bread recipes maybe
somebody's looking to type in a keyword
that says how do i make you know a bread
or how do i make a specific type of
bread or how do i make banana bread or
what's the best recipe for banana bread
they're question related and we want to
be able to answer those questions so
that's where choosing those right
keywords that's going to respond to a
user's intent so starts with choosing
the right keywords so remember we talked
about a number of different tools when
we talked about keyword research so
there's a research tool that you can use
called phrase.io and that will help you
do quick research on you know keywords
and trends and whatnot so if you know
about a research tool that you use for
keyword research then drop us a comment
below i'd be interested in getting your
comments about keyword research and what
research tools are out there so if you
know something better than phrase.io
drop a comment below and we'd be
interested in getting your perspective
so keyword research is key but creating
content that fulfills users requirements
so answering those questions it's a
recipe we want to answer that question
if it's directions we want to answer
that question if they don't know how to
do something we want to answer that
question that's the whole idea behind
content content is not just to fill a
page it's to really fulfill users
requirements that's when you get good
engagement so if somebody's typing in
something on google and they're looking
for an answer your content should answer
that question but we also want to make
the content readable so in other words
you know write for your audience don't
impress anybody with
very high vocabulary type words that
somebody doesn't necessarily know the
meaning of don't use jargon don't use a
street language for example use everyday
common language that's just easily
digestible when your audience is reading
and then we want to keep that content
organized and so when we mean organized
we want to use headers and subheaders
you know break your content into
paragraphs keep the flow organized if we
can keep the flow organized then it's
going to be easier for somebody to read
and then it's okay to add resources
especially resources from credible sites
so if you can incorporate those
resources in there then it's just going
to add the credibility to your content
let the audience know that hey i've done
my research on this topic and this is
what this person has to say about it
this person who seems to be credible
okay so it only adds value to your
content so these are all tips to
remember when creating content and then
the one important tip here is we want to
use white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we've chosen keywords that are going
to answer somebody's question we don't
want to stuff those keywords into the
content we want the content to be
naturally written so when we say opt for
white hat techniques that's what we mean
write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include
third-party sources and make sure it
answers a question so they're different
types of content so there's content
where you just write words to install
text based you could also use an
infographic an infographic is simply
just a graphic that visualizes exactly
what you're trying to explain for
example if we want to
write an article about
how to write good engaging content we
don't necessarily have to write all that
out as a text we can create an
infographic so for example here's an
infographic on 20 effective ways to
basically not bore your readers but
write engaging content so you could see
this is an infographic it's all
graphically laid out so infographics
tend to be easier to understand because
they're visual they're easy for the end
user to comprehend because there's
generally no jargon it's usually images
that are portraying the point of what
you're trying to get across and so it
tends to break it up the monotony of
just text it's more visually appealing
and it's laid out and organized so you
can see this infographic has 20
different steps or rules and they lay
those out all here in this infographic
and the great thing i like about
infographics is you could you could
share them on social media you can
re-engage them as a post you can save
them on really any social platform so
infographics tend to tell a better story
and versus say just writing text you can
use video and images so you don't
necessarily have to lay it all out in an
infographic you can certainly insert a
video or an image into
your content especially if it's a blog
post if it's a blog post then sometimes
video and images on its own
tell the story you don't necessarily
need text to
go ahead and tell your story a video or
an image as they say tells a thousand
words and so
images and videos are great to use in a
blog post so
using different forms of content you
know you always want to review your
content when a user dwells on your web
page for a longer time google will tend
to think okay this person's engaged so
we're going to rank that favorable so if
you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative in
the types of content you use so longer
engaging content tends to bode well with
search engines so this is according to
hubspot so the more word count you use
the more words you use the chances of
you ranking higher are going to be
better just take into account best
practices you want to maybe break up the
content with an image organize it make
it engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily just words it's the words
and how those words are written how
they're structured the types of keywords
you're using how you're engaging with
your audience there's a lot of factors
again there's best practices we just
went over but the key is you know if you
have longer more engaging content then
it's going to bode better for you on
search engines so a couple of steps to
create high quality content so you want
to begin with a comprehensive
introduction so always introduce your
content remember the content should be
relevant to the keywords so if you're
choosing keywords in your keyword
research think about answering that
question if somebody's typing in bread
recipes maybe they're looking for banana
bread recipes how to
make the best banana bread or how to
make banana bread using dried figs we
want to be able to align our content
with that keyword naturally you want to
create a title that's worthy that's
click worthy so remember if you're in
google search and you're doing search
for
something simple like bread recipes we
wanted some make something that's going
to be you know engaging for somebody to
click on like easy perfect yeast bread
or easy crusty french bread or something
that's going to be engaging you know the
best bread recipes or how to make the
best homemade bread you know something
that's going to draw somebody's
attention to the title of that blog post
so we want to include lsi keyword so
what i mean by lsi keywords in your
content we mean you know long tail
keywords make it natural headings and
subheadings should consist of keywords
and variants so
if you're writing headers and subheaders
include the keyword in there and that
way the the content always stays
relevant to the audience okay shorten
your sentences and paragraphs so don't
write long paragraphs remember we want
to break this up we want to make it easy
for the end user to read and we want to
always put internal links on our blog
post why because if we have internal
links then if we have a link from one
blog post to another blog post or say
our blog post to an internal page on our
website we want to make sure that it's
relevant content that way somebody's
reading something and you have an
internal link let's just say from a
bread recipes page to
a banana bread recipes page then they
may find it interesting click on that
link and go to the banana bread recipes
page so it's keeping somebody engaged on
your website so putting in internal
linking will help keep the end user
engaged because you're offering up links
that's relevant to the content you
always want to break up that content
with images okay we want to use alt tags
meaning we want to
pan the image with text so that way if
the image doesn't load then at least the
alt text will load so we can incorporate
call out boxes and more importantly we
want to update our content regularly so
we always want to
get the best recipe out there if it's
banana bread or different ways to create
banana bread or always just coming up
with ways to update the content so we
want to keep our content our blog post
fresh and then we want to include a cta
call to action if we include a call to
action
then that's going to keep somebody
engaged and have them act on your
content so these are
steps to creating high quality content
and so let's look at an example here
and this is a three month old post on
buzzfeed and it's 21 pictures that
restore your faith in humanity so it has
a lot of likes a lot of tweaks and that
means it's engaged people are engaged
when reading that and so if we go and
look at it as an example we could see it
on a buzzfeed here 21 pictures that will
restore your faith in humanity so this
was written back in 2012 again a lot of
engagement but if we look at it we can
see immediately that it's taking into
account third-party sources it's got
some content it's got images it's being
broken up by images we can see there's
call to actions on there in the form of
social so people can go ahead and go
ahead and share it if they like it okay
it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because listen you know it's engaging
content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we could see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content so not
just video not just images but text as
well and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
content's updated regularly it's
engaging and it includes sources from
high authority websites some do's and
don'ts on the content so take into
account the best practices i mentioned
about creating high quality content
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know because that
likely is going to be their search and
so you want to be able to respond to the
end user that's part of creating high
quality content different types of
content i.e in the form of infographics
or videos or text or images you can add
images from public domain sites you can
be relatable and use examples to clarify
points just like the buzzfeed article
simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language talk to your
audience as if you they were standing
right in front of you and use bullet
points to exemplify your examples your
points so some do's that don'ts
obviously don't lift content we don't
want to lift content from another
website so that's plagiarism so we want
to have our own unique content we also
don't want to take images from other
websites and so if you do happen to find
an image that works for your post and
it's on somebody else's website ideally
that's not a good situation but if you
do happen to do that then always give
credit to the website okay so if you
took it from xyz.com
creditxyz.com for the image and even put
a link back but ideally you don't want
to take images from other websites just
as much as you don't want to take copy
you don't want to take images use your
own imagery and content but if you don't
have imagery then you can always go to
stock photography there are plenty of
websites out there where you can sign up
for a subscription like adobe stock
images as an example you could sign up
for an account and in some cases you can
sign up for a free account and use stock
imagery okay don't give less information
to your audience give them to your
audience what they deserve which is the
information they're looking for they're
looking for the best banana bread
recipes give them the best banana bread
recipes incorporate your own images
break it up with titles give them a good
quality piece of content that they're
going to be able to engage with and so
if you put long paragraphs in your
content then it's going to be less
engaging so try to avoid those long
paragraphs remember shorten up the
paragraphs keep the language simple add
in images answer those questions use
third party credible sources but write
it in your own words and you should be
on your way to creating good quality
content okay so now that we've talked
about high quality content in order to
get your pages ranked high on google
search let's turn our attention to
optimizing on-page elements and discuss
some website level factors that are both
going to help you rank high on google
search so
let's just do an overview of what we're
talking about when we talk about on-page
elements and website level factors so
optimizing on-page elements include a
number of different things but primarily
we're going to focus in on meta tags
also known as meta description tags
header tags also known as title tags and
urls so those are just some of the
on-page elements we want to be able to
optimize using relevant keywords in
order to rank high in google search we
also want to
take a look at some website factors that
will affect our ranking on google search
they include website architecture having
a secure website having a site map and
taking a look at page speed so all of
those are some of the website factors we
need to take into account in order to
rank high on google search so title tag
and meta description
together are considered
meta tags so both play an important role
in ranking high on google so we want to
be able to write unique title and
descriptions for each page on our
website when i say unique that means the
title and the meta description need to
be different for every page on the
website and so if you're not quite sure
what a title tag and a meta description
tag is if you go to search and just type
in any particular search query the title
tag is what's going to show up here in
bold and then the description is going
to show up below it below the url and
that's going to describe the page so
both of these meta tags are important
because it describes what your page is
all about and that's what google uses in
the search results pages so we want to
be able to pay attention to the length
of our meta tags so if we go back to our
search results pages met title tags are
generally 60 65 characters meta
description tags are generally 160
characters so anything really longer
than that then what's gonna happen is
the
meta description tag or the title tag
will get truncated and so if we look
here for example we can see all of the
title tags here fit the 65 character
limit but if you run over the character
account meta description then google is
going to truncate the copy so you want
to stay within your parameters in order
to avoid getting your content truncated
and so the other thing when we're
writing title meta description tags we
want to minimize keyword repetition so
if we're optimizing for keyword we don't
want to necessarily just plug that
keyword into the title tag and meta
description multiple times we want to
make sure our title tags and meta
descriptions are naturally written so if
somebody's typing for banana bread
recipe with dried figs you know we want
to have a nice title tag and into this
description that is going to get
somebody to respond based on their need
and so we definitely want to avoid
keyword repetition but we want to be
able to use that keyword in the title
tag because if you remember from the
earlier segment when we did the all in
title syntax to find out exactly how
many competitors were using that
particular keyword well we obviously
want to use that keyword in the title
tag because again the title tag is an
important factor when it comes to search
engine results so we want to use the
keyword but we want to avoid stuffing or
using it repetitively in our title tag
and our meta description we want the
title tag and the meta description to
describe the page sound natural but also
be engaging because the point is we want
people to click on our link and go to
our website from search engines so title
tags with numbers tend to result in
higher click-through rates this is
according to mods so for example
if you just put in a title tag that says
learn digital marketing well that may
work but if you put a number in there
like five easy ways to learn digital
marketing that might get somebody to
click on your link and go to your
website so having questions in your meta
tags can also increase your
click-through rate for example if you
just put learn the importance of first
page rankings not too bad but again
generic but if you put it into the
formal question how to rank number one
on google it's more action oriented it's
gonna get somebody to resonate with the
question that they have and that may be
their query how to rank number one on
google and so these techniques will
help you get higher click-through rates
and so according to backlinko
title tag with a keyword can improve
site ranking so remember we want to
include that keyword in the title tag
even though we only have 65 characters
we want to include that keyword but we
want to avoid stuffing the keyword in
there we want to again make the title
tag action oriented maybe with the
number maybe as a question with the
keyword in there once naturally not easy
to do
but that's the beauty of seo if you can
follow these best practices and write a
good title tag then the chances of you
improving in your search results are
going to be greater so having only one
h1 tag in your post is going to be good
so remember when somebody clicks on a
link so let's say they do find a title
tag engaging and they click on this this
link here and they go to that website
you know you want to start out with
having that particular h1tech because
the h1 tag especially with the keyword
in it is going to signal to google hey
we're organizing our page and because
it's an h1 tag it's important we're
structuring the page according to best
practices so having only one h1 tag in
your post is definitely helpful having
multiple tags h tags in your post help
organize the page a lot better so we
want to add that targeted keyword in
that tag and your header tags should be
relevant to the content so if we go back
to our example of the using dried figs
with banana breads well the title says
california fig banana bread and remember
the last segment when we're talking
about high quality content we'll look no
further than including a video into
our content so not only will this video
help keep the engagement high but it
breaks up the monotony of the page and
it's from a third-party source so it
adds credibility to the page so adding a
videos based on the last segment of high
quality content definitely helps with
ranking high on google search so
following hierarchical structure that
means putting those h tags in there h2
tags help break up the content and we
want to avoid repetition of h1 tags on
your different web pages of your site
meaning don't just put the same h1 tag
with the same keyword in it and keeping
it blase we want to make those h1 tags
exciting to read but also used
appropriately to break up the content so
remember all white hat techniques we
want to avoid hidden texts we want to
avoid stuffing keywords we want things
to be natural we don't want things to be
forced and your h1 tag should be 20 to
70 characters don't make long h1 tags if
we go back to our page example a short
sweet tag here california fig banana
bread it's relevant to the content it's
short sweet and breaks up the monotony
of the content and more importantly
again any content you have on the page
should always answer the user's intent
remember people are using search to
answer questions find information our
content should be able to answer that
for them so
according to john muller senior
webmaster trends analyst at google
header tags would definitely help google
for rankings in the search results so we
want to use header tags so when it comes
to urls we want to use hyphens and avoid
underscores so if we look at this url
here this uses hyphens fig and banana
bread so it's all broken up with hyphens
that's a best practice remember
canonical urls a canonical url signals
to google this is the original content
so we want to use original content and
if you have multiple sources of content
out there on say different websites we
want to use the canonical tag to signal
to google this is the original content
please index this content and that
doesn't hurt to use a favicon url
meaning a small icon
it helps to break up the monotony and
help your url stand out we can add
targeted keywords in the url so again
looking at the url here i can see we're
using targeted keyword as part of the
url structure vegan banana bread and
notice the h1 tag is fake banana bread
so it's all consistent
and it flows naturally urls that are no
longer existing then we want to be able
to set up a redirect for those urls
meaning a 301 redirect is a server
response for google that says hey
google this page is no longer available
but we permanently redirected it to this
page which is now available so that's
what a 301 redirect does it helps signal
to google and all the other search
engines that if the page is no longer
there that's fine you're just going to
go to this page this is the page that's
permanently there now and another thing
we want to do here is if you have mobile
urls you want to include those in the
sitemap and we're going to hit on that
in just a minute but all urls should be
mobile friendly as well as desktop
friendly meaning take into account those
best practices keep your url short use
hyphens put the keyword in that url and
make it easy to understand want to avoid
capital letters in the urls the urls are
case sensitive so go lower case you
should always go lower case from the url
readable urls again the rule of thumb
here is if you understand what the url
is then google is going to understand
what the url is so the shorter the url
the easier it is to read the easier it
is to read the better chance you have to
rank high on google search so according
to backlink 2 urls that are shorter
definitely definitely help you rank so
we want to be able to shorten those urls
keep them short and sweet don't make
them long and unreadable so those are
some on optimized ways or on-page
elements that help you optimize now we
want to look at some website level
factors that will help you optimize and
write kind google search so good site
structure provides better crawling for
search engine bots and what do we mean
by that well we mean having your site
organized in a fashion that google's
gonna be able to find all the pages so
what do we mean by that create a logical
hierarchy structure so if you're selling
shoes you know you're gonna have a home
page break the structure up into men's
shoes women's shoes children's shoes
then under men's shoes you could have it
by brand it could be nike puma adidas on
the women's side it could be nike puma
adidas on the child side it could be
nike puma adidas and so you want to keep
the structure flow in a hierarchy so we
want to balance the amount of
subcategories within each category so
the men's if it has nike puma adidas the
women should have nike puma adidas and
so you want to code your site navigation
in css or html meaning we want to be
able to use something that google's
going to be able to index so most sites
are built in html and that's what google
likes to index they like to index
something that they could take back to
their servers and then more importantly
build a comprehensive structure for
internal linking so internal links mean
that if you're on a site you should have
natural links pointing to other pages on
your website so to keep the flow going
and we don't want to
have unnatural inbound links you always
want to have natural internal links to
keep the flow of the user going from one
page to the other so here i can see as
an example all the ingredients in this
recipe well this has an internal link to
another page on our site and this
happens to link to a page where somebody
can buy the ingredients so it's a
natural internal link so john doherty of
credo has claimed that one of the
biggest changes that he can make in
fixing the credo website is architecture
so for example in credo john dougherty
has increased the organic sessions by 74
in pages by per session by 41
just by changing the site architecture
so you'd be surprised by changing the
site architecture what that will do to
engagement and so let's turn our
attention to secure versus non-secure so
what we mean by that is securing your
site we want to make it sure that
compliant with certain protocols and so
if we go back here we can see that this
particular site is compliant it is
secure
https means it has a secure license
meaning the site is secure so google
likes secure versus non-secure so
non-secure would be http so we want
https as our protocol and what that
means is just enabling ssl certificates
and that means when you enable an ssl
certificate that means your domain or
your protocol is going to be turned to
https so google prefers sites that are
secure versus non-secure so if you use
hsts
as a protocol that adds an extra layer
of security over the https and
hsts prevents cookie hijacking so adding
multiple layers of security always helps
in my opinion if you have an http
website a non-secure website you should
look into
buying an ssl certificate getting your
sites flipped over to https
because what's going to happen is your
url structure is going to change when
your url structure changes google's
going to recognize that because they're
going to index your site and when they
index your site they're going to see
those secure urls and that's going to
work favorably in your favor and help
you rank higher on google search so
websites using secure or
https have a higher chance of ranking
higher so https is a ranking signal
because google indexes those pages so
let's also talk about sitemaps so
sitemap is one of the most important
ways to improve your website ranking why
well because sitemaps are a way to
organize all your urls into one file so
we're basically going to
prioritize all our web pages in a
sitemap so if you go to any particular
website and you type in sitemap xml
you're likely going to see all the pages
on your website so usually the sitemap
is located in the root directory so if i
type in
sitemap.xml i'm going to be able to see
all the pages in my root directory and i
can also prioritize them i can also
alert google as to how often they change
and every page is going to have a date
stamp associated with it so google can
actually see how often it changes so
remember we want our content to be
updated frequently so content's not
updated frequently or it's not fresh
then google is going to see that site
that date stamp that last modification
down so we want to be able to make sure
content's updated frequently we want to
let google know that we change it
frequently and we want to be able to
prioritize our pages let google know hey
these pages are important to us so all
that can be set up in a sitemap we want
to be able to add canonical versions of
urls in the sitemap so we want to be
able to add all our original urls in our
sitemap and so we always want to build
dynamic urls sitemaps for larger
websites and what i mean by dynamic urls
that means that if i look at this
sitemap and we're always adding content
let's just say in the form of a blog
well guess what we want those pages to
be added to the sitemap as they're
published so as we add pages to the blog
or to the site then they should
automatically be added to the site map
and so in effect what's going to happen
is we're going to be able to see
the site map grow with more urls when
the sitemap grows with more urls then
that means then google is going to index
more pages they're going to index more
fresh pages so they're going to be able
to get those pages that are just
published quicker so that's the whole
idea behind dynamic site maps is we want
to be able to capture all the urls just
as they're published and we want to be
able to maintain our sitemaps and so i
would always recommend a dynamic sitemap
but you can always create your own site
map just by going to a tool called xml
sitemap so if i just type in xml
sitemaps
into google search here i can see xml
sitemaps generator and i can be able if
i have a small website just create a
free and simple sitemap on my own when
xml sitemaps creates it or your platform
creates a dynamic sitemap either way the
sitemaps going to sit in the root
directory and then what we want to do in
turn is let google know where that site
map is so in search console we want to
be able to submit the sitemap so you're
going to add the sitemap you're going to
let google know where it is it should be
in the root directory and it should be
called sitemap.xml
and when you do that google is going to
be able to take those urls and index
them so we could see we submitted 528
urls google index 521 so one thing about
urls here is when we create a site map
we're putting all your urls in there we
do not add no index urls in your sitemap
and what that means is that any url we
don't want google to index we're just
going to exclude from the sitemap okay
so we want google to take all the urls
we want indexed and put them in the
sitemap so according to edgy using
sitemaps for seo can increase your
website's visibility and help you get
indexed why because what you're in fact
doing is taking all your urls that you
want indexed you're telling google how
often they're modified you're telling
google which ones are important and
you're submitting that to google and so
google's going to be able to take all
these urls quicker index them quicker
and when they're indexed quicker you can
get ranked quicker and when you get rank
quicker you can get traffic quicker so
that's the whole idea behind site maps
so let's turn our attention to page
speed now so when the last factors for
our website besides architecture making
it secure and adding site maps is want
to take a look at how quick our pages
load here are some tips in order to
optimize page speed because ideally the
quicker a page loads the more engaged
the user is going to be if it takes a
longer time for the page to load all the
elements of that page then what's going
to happen is the user is going to get
impatient maybe leave the website all
together or go to another page and so we
want to be able to optimize images so
any image that's of large size in terms
of megabytes we want to be able to
optimize that to compress the image so
that's one way to speed up page speed we
want to use a simple website design you
know html with css or cascading style
sheets just a simple design with simple
hierarchy and website navigation
structure so nothing fancy nothing
complex just a simple website design
with optimized images we want to
leverage browser caching and we want to
upgrade the server response time meaning
all your files are sitting on the server
so when somebody goes to web page the
server is serving up all of those files
the images the text etc and so we want
the server to respond as quick as
possible so when it comes to page speed
we can look at the factors affecting
page speed in google analytics so if i
go to google analytics and i go under
behavior and i go under site speed and i
go to overview
i'm going to be able to see what my
average load time is for my site and
ideally we want our pages to load as
quick as possible so that means anything
under 4 seconds anything four seconds or
higher and it's likely the end user is
going to leave the page there's a
correlation be between page load time
and bounce rate and so what google
actually does is give you speed
suggestions so if we do have a page that
loads slow we can just go to speed
suggestions and google analytics and we
go to speed suggestions then google is
going to be able to tell us hey this
particular page load fast this potential
page loads slow and if it loaded slow
why is it loading slow so here we could
see the home page of the example is
loaded on average of seven seconds well
if we look here they're going to give us
some suggestions so if i click on those
page speed suggestions it's going to
load a report and a tool called page
speed insights and basically what it's
then going to do after it's done running
is it's going to tell me all the ways in
which i can optimize my pages not only
for desktop but also for mobile so here
i can see for desktop or for mobile i
can look at some ways in which i can
optimize it to increase page speed for
example sizing my images properly server
response time reducing my server
response time avoiding multiple page
redirect so there's a lot of
opportunities that we can do to speed up
page load time and all that's found in
page speed insights and all that's found
within google analytics so remember
optimizing code minimizing redirects
optimizing your images upgrading your
server response and all of those are
factors and so again you can go into
analytics page speed insights and you
can see exactly what google is
recognizing as what's lowering or
slowing down your page load time so
google takes site speed as one of the
most important ranking factors why
because they're going to rank pages not
only with high quality content that are
relevant to the keyword queries but they
want those pages to have a good user
experience so somebody clicks on the
page then the user should be able to see
that content fairly quickly and so
that's why it's such an important factor
so the quicker your pages load the
chances of you ranking higher are going
to be better so according to web
performance today walmart as an example
experienced declining conversions so
what they did was looked at their page
speed and when they looked at their page
speed you'd be surprised what that did
just increasing it from one to four
seconds or decreasing it basically
increase conversion so there's always
going to be a correlation between how
quick a page loads and how engaged the
user is because if it's users engaged
they're going to stay on the site and if
they stay on the site then their chances
of converting are going to be higher so
just even one to two seconds increase in
page load is low time will make a world
of difference in terms of engagement and
conversions let's turn our attention to
offsite engagement so previously we
talked about on-page elements and
website factors that affect our rankings
for search results but we also need to
turn our attention away from our website
meaning what we do on our website and
turn our attention what we can do for
our website off our website and on to
other websites so that's off-site
engagement and so let's look at an
example so that ice cream recipes blog
i'm going to talk about how to rank
youtube videos today so it's simply
learn we take our videos on youtube very
seriously meaning that when we create
videos we want people to see them
because we know we make good videos and
we know we have good content and we know
that our audience is going to enjoy it
and so we want our audience to see the
videos that we're creating and so we're
going to give you some tips and tricks
and methodology and ideas on how to get
your videos to rank on youtube so at
simply learn if i go to
youtube and i just type in machine
learning you can see where right here is
the first organic video on youtube for
machine learning if i jump over to
google and i type in machine learning
basics you can see where number we're
number one for machine learning basics
under videos if i click on all we're
also ranked here as well under the video
section on organic search results
another example data science for
beginners we ranked number one for that
if i look at another keyword data
science interview question okay we'll
rank number two for that so we're
ranking for a lot of videos and why are
we ranking for a lot of different
content and videos on google search and
on youtube well we put a lot of work in
behind the scenes of creating the video
and that's what we want to show you so
part of that has a lot to do with you
know how our audience engages and sees
our video so for example we're looking
at uh the machine learning basics video
here and we could see that it has over
221 000 subscribers for this video 234
000 views we've had over 2 000 people
like the video and we have had over 270
plus comment on the video so when we get
our videos to rank then we can see
there's a lot of engagement and so
that's the whole idea is when you do a
video and you want to show up on youtube
you want people to enjoy you want people
to share it you want people to like it
you want people to comment on that and
that's part of the whole ecosystem of
youtube it's you know we're going to
show you behind the scenes of what it
takes to get your videos to rank and
then we're going to show you some of the
metrics involved with some of these
videos to help you stay ranking so
without further ado let's go into
how to get your videos to rank on
youtube so we're going to talk about
keyword research for youtube we're going
to talk about some ways to create high
quality videos so the importance of user
engagement just as i showed you with the
machine learning basics video all the
shares all the commenting all the views
and subscriptions then we're going to
get into how to promote your content and
then we're going to just review a little
checklist for you and sum it all up so
let's get started with keyword research
so basically what we want to do is
center our keywords just like our
website we want to center our keywords
around or our content around good
keywords so the videos on youtube are no
different than the web pages on our
website so if we have somebody who
states youtube is the world's second
most well well-known engine well it is
because it's right behind google it's
not a search engine per se it's a video
platform but if it was a search engine
it'd probably be second right behind
google so
youtube is pretty popular majority
people use youtube search every day to
watch videos on a number of different
topics so they can find these videos in
google but because youtube's so powerful
and so popular people go directly right
into youtube for their searches and so
the whole idea behind youtube being the
second most well-known search engine is
centered around keywords so if you have
the right keywords for your video then
the chances of you ranking higher
increases on youtube so we're gonna
share with you a few easy ways to do
keyword research this is the most
important step in getting your videos to
rank on youtube just like for those of
you who watched any of the seo videos we
produced at simplylearn you know that
keyword research is so essential to
getting your web pages to rank on google
well it's no different keyword research
and choosing the right keywords is just
as important for your videos as is for
your web pages so we're going to go into
a few things to do here to find the
right keywords so we have the search
suggestion you can look at your
competitors we have different tools we
can use some other factors involved in
google itself so let's start talking
about some of these ways to really hone
in and do some good research on your
keywords to align them with your videos
first thing is search suggest so youtube
has a feature called autocomplete so if
you've done any searches on google it's
very similar if you're typing something
in to youtube search then youtube is
going to suggest other related popular
keywords so let's take a look at that if
we go back to
youtube for a second and i just type in
machine learning youtube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in the
search bar some other popular keywords
that we can potentially use or in this
case if i choose you know machine
learning tutorial i'm going to see a
video about machine learning tutorial so
here you can see simply learns ranked
number one for machine learning tutorial
but there are other videos that show up
in my search result so we want to be
able to use the search suggestion box in
the search box field so when we're
typing in something you know youtube
just like on google is going to give us
those suggestions so if we're focusing
uh a video on machine learning then you
know we have some ideas of some other
keywords that we could center around
because these are our popular keywords
these are keywords that people are using
to search on youtube so that's one
suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video and title and description so
let me talk a little bit about that what
you want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitor's youtube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title and description and then once you
do that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to youtube so if i go
to type in simply learn here's our
channel page just by clicking on simply
learn i click on videos ever wonder if
there's so now i can see all the ever
wonder if there's an easier way go back
so here i can see all the videos sort by
most popular once they do that then i
can choose a video this is the most
popular video right now for simply learn
if i click on that video it's
automatically going to start playing but
what i could do is simply just look at
you know the content description so just
by clicking show more i can see all the
content that align with this video
that's one way to do it is simply by
looking at your competitors now what you
could also do is look at the tags
associated with the particular video and
so what you want to do is you want to
look at the html and so that means
looking at the page source so just like
web pages what youtube does is they look
at meta tags so if you call from seo in
order to get your pages to rank you need
to have a title tag and a meta tag
description so videos are no different
what we're doing
for youtube is aligning certain keywords
with the video so if you take a look and
do a search for keywords by viewing the
page source you're going to see all the
keywords associated
with a particular video so for example i
go back to youtube and i look at the
page source of a video let's just say
this video here facebook's ad tutorial
i'm going to pull up the page source and
all i need to do is control f and type
in keywords and now for that facebook
video i can see all the keywords
associated with the video so you can see
there's a lot of different keywords
we're aligning with this video and so
why do we want to do that because we
want you know our video to show up for
keywords that people may type in and so
if you use that youtube autocomplete
it's going to give you those ideas this
was popular keywords so if they're
related align those keywords with the
video so here you can see facebook
marketing facebook ad strategy facebook
ads for beginners so forth and so on so
there's a lot of keywords we've aligned
here with that particular video and
again all you need to do is look at the
page source so right clicking view page
source do a control f for keywords and
you'll be able to see the keywords
aligned so you could do that for your
competitors videos as well so you can
see what keywords your competitors using
for a video that's most popular for
their channel and is also ranking on
youtube and on google so using the
autocomplete gives you those keyword
ideas looking at your competitors videos
also gives you some other ideas for
keywords that you can align with a video
that's relevant that you want to rank
for so let's look at
some other ideas here so you can install
plugins and there are plenty of plugins
available on the chrome browser that
will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples of vid iq and
tubebuddy those are extensions that work
in chrome and what they do is they give
you the exact tags that a particular
video is using so for example if i go
back here and i look at a video on
youtube let's just say the machine
learning basics video i have vid iq
installed on my chrome browser so just
by clicking on that vid iq is going to
give me a lot of information about that
video they're just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with facebook
some engagement metrics really what i'm
interested in is those keywords so if i
scroll down a bit here i can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning basics video so vid iq is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated i can also see where they
rank so for machine learning basics this
particular video ranks number one if i
go down i could see what is machine
learning and how does it work i can see
it's ranked number two here i could see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so i can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
i can also see some channel tags but
really this is the video tags or the
idea place i want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you
to really get an understanding of what
keywords to use at the particular video
so autocomplete you can look at the page
source of a competitor's video or you
can use a chrome extension in this case
i'm using vid iq to give me some
information about the video tags for a
particular video so according to an
industry study using keywords and video
tags will help you rank well on youtube
so you have to use keywords and video
tags if you want your video to rank
there's been a lot of studies youtube is
so popular and videos are so prominent
in today's world where if you have
videos and you're going to upload them
to youtube then associate the right
keywords with those videos so some
important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on youtube or google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third-party
extension in chrome in my example i use
vid iq that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with keywords that have low difficulty
and are easier to rank for so you don't
want to choose something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy so for talking
about machine learning basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that autocomplete
comes in handy because what google's
going to do and youtube's going to do is
give us keywords that are very closely
related to the video that we're trying
to optimize for and so we have a number
of different keywords at our disposal
that are relevant that we can look to
see if they have good volume and low
competition and so the whole idea is we
want to choose a keyword that defines
the nature of the content and then what
we want to do is support that with
secondary keywords so we want keywords
that are highly relevant to the primary
keyword so that's the way to go about
aligning your keywords you want keywords
that are high volume low competition are
relevant and you want to choose that one
keyword that is really what the contents
about and then the secondary keywords
that support the primary so if you have
a machine learning video you could
choose your primary keyword as in this
case the machine learning basics video
so well chosen keywords help you rank
well on youtube just like the machine
learning basics so if i go back to our
video our machine learning basics video
if i just type in machine learning
basics i'll be able to pull it up and so
here it is if i click on it i'm going to
go to youtube and so here i can see this
keyword we know humans learn from their
is well aligned because
it's in the title it's in the copy and
it's aligned as a keyword tag with the
video so we know that that keyword has
good volume low competition is relevant
because that's what the video is about
the basics of machine learning it's an
introduction to machine learning so
instead of honing in on just
introduction
machine learning primary keyword is
machine learning basics and then we
supported that video with those
secondary keywords what is machine
learning because somebody who doesn't
know machine learning is probably going
to type in that keyword and then
introduction of machine learning is a
good secondary keyword because it's
explaining the basics of what machine
learning is all about so primary keyword
machine learning basic secondary
keywords what is machine learning an
introduction to machine learning so
that's the whole idea behind choosing
keywords you want that keyword that
really is going to define the content
and then support that with those
secondary keywords so remember when
you're performing your keyword research
choose keywords for your videos that
google shows on the video results page
so what i mean by that is your video can
get more views if you rank on google as
well so the whole idea is not
necessarily to be found on youtube it's
also to be found on google so if i go
back to google and i just type in data
science for beginners and i type in
videos then you can see we're ranked
number one so even if you're not looking
at the videos clicking on the videos
link on google search you can always
just when you do a search what google's
going to do is also put in the videos
here on par as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular keyword and so we
may not rank overall
for data science for beginners but we're
ranked number one in the videos category
and so if somebody's looking for a video
that's important and you can see here
that these first two are at so what
google is doing is they're saying hey
this is so relevant this particular
video for the keyword query data science
for beginners that we're going to show
it above the organic listings even
though it's a video so the whole idea is
to be found on youtube and google
because you're increasing your
visibility you're increasing your
chances of getting found on both search
platforms so according to backlinko
google ranks videos with keywords like
how to tutorials so you know a lot of
the videos that you find on youtube are
going to be instructional based and so
what google's doing is they're saying
hey if somebody types in how to or
tutorial or an introduction to anything
that's going to signal to google that
it's instructional it's going to help
you rank so when you search for machine
learning tutorial or how to become a
machine learning engineer you're going
to get results related to that because
if you look at these examples we have
machine learning tutorial in our title
or how to become a machine learning
engineer so keep that in mind if you're
creating a video and it's educational in
nature you know use those key terms like
how to and tutorials in the video title
because that will help you rank so let's
move over now to video titles so we want
to use our target keyword in the title
of the video and again we want to make
sure if it's educational to include that
keyword tutorial or how to so for every
video title youtube has a limit of 100
characters so we really have to pick and
choose a really wisely so if we look at
the video that we were focusing on a
couple of minutes ago so machine
learning basics here we could see under
100 characters we have machine learning
basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so it takes
into account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really that key term
that really google and youtube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us rank by having our keywords
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to align
it with the right keywords your primary
and your secondary and so we want to use
those catchy words and numbers to gain
high click-through rates just like you
would on the title tag of your web page
we want to do the same with our video
title because the video titles what's
going to show up in search so if i go
back to you know search here we could
see you know data science tutorial data
science for beginners so we want to make
sure in this case you can see data
science in five minutes so that was
purposely done so that hey i don't have
time to watch a video i only have a
couple minutes data science in five
minutes okay great i'm gonna click on
the video and now i have an opportunity
to watch something and learn something
under five minutes so choosing the right
words in your video title is going to
help you get that click-through rate up
remember click-through rate is clicks
divided by impressions and an impression
is how many times your video shows up in
the search results on youtube or google
so we want to keep our click-through
rate high and in order to do that we
want to be able to write some really
good title tags for our video so use
catchy words like a number or how to or
what is because that's going to resonate
with people when they're searching now
for the description what we want to do
is we want to use the target word at the
beginning of the description the title
and the tags itself so if i go back to
my video here machine learning basics we
know it's in the video title and right
off the bat if i look at the description
of the video here i can see this machine
learning basics video will help you
understand what is machine learning so
our primary keyword is in the first
sentence right in the introductory of
the description and so that's going to
bode well for optimizing our video the
description length is 5 000 characters
so we have a lot of characters to work
with so if i go back to my video i click
show more we have a lot of characters to
really describe what the video is about
okay there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if i go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else you
would use on social media it just
signals to the end user hey this is what
the video is all about and if i go ahead
and type in that keyword then it's our
video has a better chance because it's
aligned with that hashtag and then
there's target keywords and lsi keywords
latent semantic indexing keywords we
want to be able to use those keywords as
target keywords with our video so if you
recall the example i gave a few minutes
ago we used the facebook ads tutorial as
our example here i could see all the
target keywords associated with that
particular video so don't be afraid to
use those lsi related keywords meaning
keywords that are related to the content
use them as target keywords with the
video so between your lsi keywords
target keywords and then using our
primary and secondary keyword in the
title tag using our primary and
secondary keyword in the description and
then using hashtags in the description
the combination of all of that if we
chose the right keyword then we should
find that our video will eventually rank
on youtube so just doing these small
tidbits with our keywords really help
get our video to rank so at the end of
the day we want to be able to use the
tools available to us youtube itself by
looking at our competitors there's
extensions like vid iq the autocomplete
to really find our good keywords and
then incorporating those keywords into
you know the title tag the description
as target keywords hashtags we should
really be off and running with our video
on youtube let's our turn our attention
to creating high quality videos and some
of the best practices around that so
along with everything we mentioned about
choosing the right keywords we always
need to keep in mind that the videos we
create need to be of high quality so the
content itself in addition to the
keywords this is a primary factor in
ranking so in order to have keywords we
need to have content and in order to
rank we need to have you know good
content so let's talk a little bit about
creating content and what's involved
with that and what we really mean by
high quality videos so if you have a
video content that is not informative or
relevant to the topic it won't rank so
that's just common sense so you need to
create content that's aligned with the
topic obviously and then that way you
have keywords that are aligned with the
content so but if you have content it
really isn't aligned with the topic then
you're not going to rank no matter how
much you've optimized that video so just
keep that in mind so there's a couple of
things we want to look at here so high
quality content is determined by really
two metrics so we're not sure about how
good our content is and how good of high
quality video we've created we want to
look at audience retention and user
engagement so audience retention is
simply the percentage length of your
video that the audience has watched it's
the percentage your audience has watched
so focusing on audience retention is
important for people who want their
videos to rank high so if you want to
rank you need to optimize for the
keywords but got to keep in mind content
so content is related to audience
retention and user engagement so
audience retention percentage length
your video of your video that the
audience has watched and for example it
can be both absolute in minutes or
percentages so audience retention can be
the average view duration or percentage
of the audience that watched then we
have user engagement so yours engagement
viewers who are engaged with your
content and so that means they're either
sharing it subscribing commenting or
liking so those are all forms of
engagement so the percentage of users
who watched or how long they watched
versus engagement or in combination with
engagement are two factors for ranking
so let's talk about some tips for
creating high quality videos so we want
to publish longer videos and so what do
we mean behind longer videos so what's
the reason for longer videos let's just
suppose we have two videos one shorter
in length and one longer in length first
video is 15 minutes long the second
video is seven minutes long so on
average if viewers watch about 40 of
both videos then video x which is 15
minutes long will have more than twice
the watch time of the video that's seven
minutes long so remember duration we
want you know people to watch our videos
longer so if the video is longer in
length if it's 40 then it's gonna have a
longer audience engagement audience
retention so that's one of the reasons
you know from a metric standpoint so
even when viewers watch you know both
videos the time is going to differ so we
want to take into account longer videos
for primarily that reason is because you
know it gives an end user an opportunity
to
watch the video longer and then it's
going to help us rank our videos longer
so we talk about watch time so if one
video has higher watch time than the
other watch time is just the number of
views times the average view duration so
another tip is we want to plan our video
script so we want to keep the content
organized my recommendation is you know
create an outline first and once you
create an outline of how the video is
going to flow then start populating with
content and so to me that's how you can
keep the flow organized okay is really
with an outline starting out with it on
holidays no videos are no different than
say a presentation if you've done a
powerpoint presentation you always want
to start out doing an outline then we
want to upload high resolution videos
high resolution
we don't want to create videos that you
know are small resolution like say you
know 400 by 400 resolution or something
you know something really small we want
to create something a very high res so
according to back or link oaks more than
50 of videos on the first page of
youtube are high definition so
high definition videos of higher quality
are going to be shown on the first page
of youtube more often than not so high
resolution videos organizing the content
publishing longer videos are examples of
creating high quality videos we also
want to make sure that content is
relevant to the title so if we're
talking about machine learning basics
you know obviously the content is going
to be about you know intro to machine
learning or what is machine learning and
then the title should reflect that
content so aligning the title sets the
expectation for the end user so when
they see a title what is machine
learning then when they watch the video
they're expecting to learn about machine
learning and what it is so if it meets
expectations then the chances are that
person who's watching the video is going
to watch it longer and that means it's
going to fulfill the viewers
requirements and when you align
everything accordingly keywords titles
content then at the end of the day the
user is going to watch it and the more
they watch it the higher the engagement
the higher the engagement the better
chance you have to rank some other tips
that you could use to
create high quality videos so we want to
be able to you know use examples to
clarify our content so you know don't be
afraid to go into another screen like i
am if i want to i'm talking about videos
jump into the machine learning basics
video which i've done throughout this
session i can simply do that by keeping
the user engaged here this video is
about machine learning basics well the
title is online with the video we made
sure that we have a nice description
about what the video is about and we're
aligning the expectations so not only
that i'm showing you example within the
video itself so we want to use examples
throughout your video to keep the user
engaged it will also help clarify what
you're trying to express in the video
itself so we want to make it visually
appealing so visually appealing means
imagery or examples in the video and
then when we talk about imagery you know
you want to use good images in your
video so use public domain sites that
are available to you like shutterstock
or flat icon i mean there are plenty of
those sites out there so feel free to
use any one of those sites to
use high quality images in your video
give more information to your audience
giving maximum relevant information can
help gain more views and so when we talk
about more information again it goes
back to you know examples you use
there's no should be no shortage of
examples here description use all 5 000
characters at your disposal imagery we
want to build up as much information as
you can in the video itself to keep the
end user the viewer engaged we also want
to create original content so always
create original content you could
certainly get ideas from youtube if you
want to create a video about machine
learning see what else has already been
done do searches on youtube itself but
you know when you're going to create a
video yeah you can create another video
about what is machine learning but just
make sure it has your own take on it
you're the subject matter expert when
creating the video create it with your
own original content have high audio
quality and video effects so just like
you see here on this video we have
effects in it and the audio is of high
quality meaning no background noise no
distortion and we want to be able to
speak clearly in the video so you want
to speak clearly loudly concise just as
i'm trying to do now so that you can
understand what i'm trying to say or
what the viewers trying to to understand
when they're watching the video so
watching and listening are two of the
components and you want to make sure
both of our high quality avoid
distractions we don't want to pause you
don't want to ramble on a particular
point too long we want to keep users
engaged so you always want to move from
one point to the other intermix it with
examples those are ways to keep the
users engaged we want to include
transcripts or subtitles for your video
so transcripts is just more content
that's aligned with the video and the
search engines will be able to pick up
that content and help your video rank so
to me that's a key component to creating
a good video is having the necessary
content to go along with the video that
outline i referenced earlier in terms of
organization you always want to have a
content outline so what topics are you
going to cover in the video that's why
you need the outline to point that out
confirm that before you actually start
creating the video okay focus on the
initial 15 seconds so that's key you
know somebody's going to click the play
button of your video and if you don't
catch them in the first 15 seconds then
they're likely going to pause the video
or just go ahead and close it out
altogether so you want to be able to
capture somebody's attention right off
the bat and even before they click on
that play button you want to make sure
again you're exceeding expectations that
title is aligned with the content so in
your first 15 seconds it basically needs
to be catchy but also setting the
expectation of what the user is
expecting so in this example here we
want to pay close attention to the first
15 seconds that's when viewers are most
likely to drop off so we can look at
audience retention in youtube so use the
options above the graph to view absolute
audience retention or relative audience
retention so audience retention is
basically how many views a video
received and the percentage of the total
number of video views and that includes
every moment of the video as a
percentage so we'll show you an example
of what that looks like so here if we go
to the machine learning basics video we
can look at the audience retention
report and this is since it's been
uploaded the lifetime audience retention
so here we can see a nice graph the
percentage of people who viewed it and
how long they viewed it so in percentage
so here for example i can see you know
43 44
watch the video for at least two minutes
here i can see
28.6 watch it for six minutes plus so
that's the audience retention it gives
us an idea in terms of percentage how
many people or percentage of people
watch the video at what length so that's
audience retention so we want to keep
that number high at the very initial
stage of the video and we want to keep
it high throughout and that's why you
always want to create high quality
content using those examples using
imagery making it organized content not
pausing you know going from one point to
the other those are all
best practices to keep the viewer
engaged and then we want to add
resources from well-known sites so
throughout this video we've used
backlinko there are other sources we've
used so if you have a source go ahead
and put it in your video to add
credibility and then we want to use
cards to your videos so this cards is
basically a feature that recommends
relevant videos to your audience so in
addition to machine learning basics
there could be other videos about
machine learning that we can recommend
or youtube can recommend to the audience
to set up end screens you want to make
sure that with end screens you can use
relevant videos to your audience towards
the end of your video so you can
recommend relevant videos towards the
end of your video you can also create
playlists so this is a feature that
keeps your audience engaged with
relevant content by auto playing the
next video so if you enable this feature
it's going to go from one video to
another pattern interrupts keep the
audience engaged so basically
it allows your audience to stay within
one video without having any
interruptions involved and so going back
to the did you know audience retention
report helps you analyze how well your
videos are engaging to the audience so
what do we mean by that well if i go
back again to my audience retention
report how engaging was it well i could
see 42
43
watched it on average of three minutes
and 21 seconds so to me that's pretty
good of course we always want a 100 of
the video the video is seven minutes
long if almost half of our audience saw
over half of the video then i would say
that's pretty good people were engaged
so audience retention just is a good
report to start looking at to help you
understand how engaging is my video and
if your video is not engaging you know
you can always go back and edit it or
fix it or tweak it so remember the
average view duration for all videos and
top performing videos listed by all time
we can look at that information as well
in addition we can look at demographics
so we can get an overview of the age
gender and location okay we can look at
playback locations report and what the
playback locations report does is it
helps us determine the platforms where
our videos are being streamed from
within youtube look at the traffic
sources where did the viewers come from
devices did they look on mobile or
tablet and so if there's any doubts you
know if you have any questions please
drop a comment below but especially if
you have any doubts on the metrics so if
we go back into youtube we can look at
analytics and if we're looking at
analytics we can see more and then this
is going to show us everything we need
to see from device type so if i click on
more i can see my playback location so
this will show me where the video was
watched it was on a watch page or a
channel page i could see the traffic
sources i could see the gender and age
so if i click on the viewer age report i
can see the percentage of views by age
so i can get a lot of information
about my video and how it's performed
who's watched it what they've done with
it where they come from all the
information they need to know okay so
it's all within youtube analytics so
again if you have any questions about
that you know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to youtube you
may have some questions but just know
that every video you publish to youtube
high quality align with your keywords
you're going to be able to view the
metrics by looking at youtube analytics
so let's talk about the importance of
user engagement so engagement is as we
mentioned important because basically we
can't rank without engagement our videos
won't rank unless we have engagement so
that's why it's important so engagement
is somebody liking the video commenting
sharing it or subscribing each one of
these is important to ranking so yes you
need to line keywords yes you need to
have high quality content so when you do
both of those and you upload your video
then it's up to the viewer and so
the hard work that you put out for the
video is hopefully going to pay
dividends with engagement so you want
people to do one of these for okay so
let's talk about what that means so how
do i get engagement so we already talked
about creating engaging content so there
are a lot of tips to creating engaging
content and so according to word stream
if your content is entertaining then
over three quarters of the users are
going to share it so that's part of
keeping uh
users engaged is keeping it entertaining
is part of getting a high quality video
so remember on the high quality video
when we say entertaining the audio
portion has a lot to do with it examples
has a lot to do with it quality of the
video itself has a lot to do with it so
a lot of components so all those
components on a high quality video are
going to lead to engagement so parts of
what you could do in your videos is
conduct a quiz so meaning the quiz
itself is a way to keep people engaged
in your video so that'll also help you
get some more comments so according to
backlinku video comments help in ranking
your video higher so just as i mentioned
the last segment about
youtube analytics and all the different
reports available on youtube hey if you
have questions on those just go ahead
and add a comment so that's a way to
entice your users or your viewers to add
comments is if they have questions
because you know with videos you're not
going to be able to cover every detail
or every minute detail about a
particular topic you can only cover in
some cases the topic at a high level so
users are going to have comments or
questions naturally and so the comments
section is a good way to remind viewers
hey if you have a question or comment go
ahead and put in the comment section
because that will lend to engagement as
well so we want to add sources from high
quality websites that'll help with
engagement okay use humor in your video
we want to be able to
basically you know make it human-based
we don't want to be robots so we want to
be able to sound like you know we know
we're talking about but at the same time
talk to the viewer not necessarily at
the viewer or looking the other way and
just going through the motions so adding
humor adding personality never hurts at
the end of the day we are all human
adding that clear call to action at the
end of the video will also
lead to engagement so if we win the
video with hey
leave your comments on this video or hey
feel free to share this video with
colleagues who are interested then
that's a call to action that's likely
going to lead to more engagement reply
to your comments as well so if you have
comments we always want to reply to them
likely those comments are going to be
questions because again as i mentioned
even in this video about how to rank
your videos on youtube okay there's a
lot of information and a lot of
information sometimes doesn't get
covered in its entirety and so we want
to make sure that if we miss something
because we're only human that we're able
to respond in the form of an answer to a
question that somebody leaves in the
comments section so more comments also
lead to higher rankings because it's
engagement so when you're getting high
engagement and your video starts to rank
well you know you're going to start
feeling really good and what is that
going to do okay that feel good is going
to lead to confidence which in turn is
going to probably lead to more videos
and that's exactly what we do at simply
learn we're in the education business
but we're in it to not only educate but
making sure that our videos are shown to
as many people as possible so that we
can educate as many people as possible
so it's all it's contagious so getting
ranked feels good and then once you get
ranked then you know you probably have
good engagement okay let's talk about
how to promote your content so once
you've done all the hard work getting
your video done high quality content
optimize with keywords and then publish
to youtube we want to let everybody in
the world know about it right so we want
to promote it we've done all the work we
want to promote it now so is it
necessary to promote it i would say yes
because once your video is published you
want to reach out you want to reach out
to your audience not necessarily on
youtube but on different platforms so if
you're active on facebook or twitter
that's an opportunity for you to post or
tweet something about the new video so
when we say different platforms i am
talking about you know social media
platforms so it depends on what you're
active on so if you're active on
facebook yeah go ahead and post some
you're active on twitter go ahead and
tweet something it could be you know on
linkedin group if you're part of a
linkedin group about you know machine
learning then go ahead and post
something to that group to promote the
video so that's going to help drive
traffic to the video and then help with
engagement so we want to engage with our
audience on those social media sites so
it really depends on what you're active
on so if you have a large following on
twitter then go ahead and you know share
that youtube video link on twitter with
the tweet that's going to drive traffic
from twitter to youtube remember you
know you're going to be able to see
audience engagement or retention by
getting people to watch the video so
you're going to be able to see right
away by promoting the video and driving
traffic to the video how engaging it is
remember the more people you have watch
the video the more engaging it becomes
the better it's going to rain so it's an
ecosystem and promoting your content is
part of that ecosystem so it all starts
with social media if you're active on
whatever platform that is go ahead and
promote it so you can also
look at you know content-based social
media sites or social media content
based platforms like reddit or flickr
for example so you can participate in a
forum discussion on reddit so in this
example here it's about machine learning
so we want to be able to post something
about machine learning with the link to
our video so we can also go to
content-based sites that are q and a
related like cora for example core is a
really good site where you know if you
go there post information about machine
learning or the basics of machine
learning with the link back to the video
it's gonna help because not only is it
gonna drive traffic but it's going to
signal to google hey
a lot of traffic coming from quora this
is going to bode well for this video in
terms of ranking so here's an example
you know if you find a question that you
can post on core then you're going to
get people to click on your video and
respond accordingly on quora or you can
act as the person responding to a
question that's already there so
somebody already asked a question about
what is machine learning you can respond
with your video as the answer so you can
just simply embed your video url as part
of your answer that'll help drive
traffic so you can also create your own
blog and embed your videos so in the
case of machine learning here we have an
example machine learning what is it why
it matters so this
goes nicely with the video so here you
can see the person the author of this
blog went ahead and embedded the
relevant video in the blog post so they
play off one another nicely you can also
opt in for influencer marking meaning
hey you can reach out to somebody in
this example here you know katy nuggets
posted information about machine
learning so in this case why choose
machine learning as a career well they
got information and then what did they
do they went ahead and embedded the
video about machine learning basics and
so working with you know influencers in
a particular category or topic will help
drive traffic to the video you can also
create a youtube playlist so playlists
tend to rank high in youtube searches so
if you find yourself doing a lot of
videos we'll go ahead and you know go to
your channel and simply on your channel
you can go ahead and create playlists so
when you create playlists basically what
you're doing is you're organizing the
content into different playlists no
different than say the music you have
set up on your you know your iphone or
ipad or or ipod whatever it is you're
using so you're just creating different
videos in a particular category and it
youtube likes it it's organized it's
going to help you get your videos found
quicker and easier on youtube itself by
putting your videos in a playlist so
here you could see we have entire
playlists on machine learning trending
technologies cloud computing big data
digital marketing project management's a
lot of different playlists very
organized if somebody goes to the
channel they're going to be able to go
to the playlist that's interesting to
them and see all the videos there so it
allows not only the end user to find
what they're looking for but it's good
for youtube because youtube likes those
playlists so we want to engage our
audience by posting your video link on a
community page so you could do that
within youtube and you can prefer to
link your youtube channel in your email
so you can also do that so for example
if i go back to youtube and i'm looking
at a youtube video you know i can always
click share so here i'm gonna get a
particular url that's associated with
the video and i can just embed that so i
can embed the whole thing in my email i
can embed it on a web page or a blog
post so just by clicking share i can
also immediately share it onto the
social media platforms that we mentioned
facebook linkedin reddit okay tumblr so
there's a lot of ways to
embed the video not just that on blog
posts or influencer blog posts but in
our email and on social media as well so
here's an example of what we can do with
the youtube discussion so we can also
bookmark the video on a popular
bookmarking site you know like stumbled
upon or read it or
you know there's lots of other ones out
there so there's plenty of sites that
you'll be able to go to and bookmark
that content so that people can find it
and you can always opt for backlinks so
that means that hey
if there's a blogger out there that
blogs about machine learning you can
always you know ask that blogger to
create a link back to the video and you
could reciprocate do the same thing so
that helps increase the authority of the
video so a lot of things you could do to
promote your video so let's do a quick
review on everything we talked about in
terms of ranking your video on youtube
it all starts with the keywords so we
want to identify a list of keywords that
are relevant to the video so we can use
tools to choose our keywords but
remember we want to choose keywords that
have high volume and low competition and
so where can we go to choose those
keywords well we can use the
autocomplete on youtube we could check
out our own competitors videos or you
know we could use vid iq or tubebuddy or
any of these extensions in chrome to
help us look at the keywords that are
tagged with a particular video so
remember we want to have a primary
keyword that's aligned with the content
then we want to choose lsi keywords as
our secondary keyword or keywords that
are related to the primary keyword so we
want to create high retention videos
meaning that first 15 seconds are the
most important but throughout the video
we want to use examples we want to keep
it interacting by adding quizzes imagery
good audio good video quality so we want
to focus on the user experience and we
also want to optimize our video content
what does that mean well those keywords
that we chose we want to use them in the
title we want to use them in the
description we want to use them as
hashtags we want to use them and tag
them with the video themselves so we can
add keywords to our meta tag okay we
don't want to overdo it but we want to
add a handful of keywords that are
associated with the video so we want to
be able to write eye catchy video titles
and descriptions so remember use some of
those key phrases like a number
or a question like what is machine
learning so we want to use relevant meta
tags for the videos and we want to use
popular youtube tags so we want to be
able to tag our videos appropriately to
watch the length of your meta tags so
there are links involved remember
keywords at the beginning of the title
target keywords in the title description
and tags we want to use interesting
thumbnails to increase our click-through
rate ensure that thumbnails are relevant
meaning when i say thumbnails i mean the
actual title tag itself or the meta
description we want to use high-res
videos we want to create you know videos
with good high audio quality don't be
afraid to put in video effects like some
animation don't be afraid to use
examples and then you know obviously
look at the draft of the video before
you publish it so does your video follow
an outline is it organized so these are
all the things to take into account and
there's there's plenty more you can do
you know you remember once you create
and optimize that video you want to
promote it you want to make sure that
you're sharing it on social media you
create a complimentary blog you know
generate backlinks from say other blog
posts so there are lots of things you
can do to promote your video so before
you promote it you want to organize the
content create good quality content
align it with keywords once you publish
it you know keep organizing it by
creating this playlist and then reach
out on social reach out on different
communities related to the topic and all
those things combined will help you to
get your youtube video ranked we're
going to talk about how to increase
youtube subscribers so with youtube it's
all about subscribers the number of
subscribers you have on youtube it's
just one of the key metrics to measure
success so gaining more subscribers can
help you achieve more view counts on
your youtube videos so it's all about
how to get subscribers and today we're
going to talk about how to get more
subscribers and before we begin let's
just show you what we did at simply
learn so if we look at the past 365 days
on our youtube channel you can see we
started here back in uh if we look back
at march 9 2018 we had 208 and you could
see just over the course of the year it
kept creeping up creeping up creeping up
and creeping up we've gained you know a
significant number of subscribers over
the last year and what's our secret well
it's posting videos so you can see we've
posted a number of videos over the
course of the year and then our
subscribers have gone basically 165
over the last year so you can see it's
part of it is about posting videos
because when you post videos you have
people who can watch those videos when
you have people watch those videos you
can have engagement and then when you
have engagement you have shares and
people who like it and then other people
will see it so it's kind of a halo
effect so to speak so getting
subscribers it takes a lot more than
just posting videos and today we're
going to talk about some tips to help
you increase those subscriptions so
let's start out with some of those tips
we're going to start with creating
engagement informative content so
engaging in informative content that's
where we're going to start talking today
about how to increase subscriptions then
we're going to talk about publishing
videos frequently so simply learn you
can see the past 365 days we were
consistent in publishing videos
consistently throughout the month and
the weeks so another tip we're going to
talk about is how to optimize your
youtube videos so there's a lot that
goes into optimization but this is a key
key tip to pay attention to because when
it comes to posting publishing videos on
youtube you need to align certain things
like keywords and content and metadata
so optimize on our videos we're going to
talk a lot about that then we're going
to talk about optimizing the youtube
channel so there's some tips and tricks
here you want to do to optimize your
youtube channel producing high quality
videos we're going to talk about that
adding a subscriber watermark to your
videos okay that's another tip we're
going to mention today engage with our
audience okay that's what we want to do
we want to engage with our audience
that's a really key tip we're saving the
best for last promote your videos in
different platforms so all of these tips
we're going to talk about today so let's
get started and talk about create
engaging informative content so that's
the first place we want to start okay so
create engaging and informative content
so if we want to gain more subscribers
on our channel we have to create highly
engaging and informative content why
because not our audience is not going to
pay attention and they're not going to
watch the video and then the
engagement's not going to be high and
they're not going to share the video and
they're not going to tell their friends
or like it and so this is where it all
starts you have to be able to plan your
content and not only planning your
content but you gotta create it so it's
engaging and informative so how do you
do that well let's talk about that so
the first thing is you have to know your
audio okay so when you create a video
who you're creating the video for i mean
that's where it all starts so when
you're creating your content you're
creating your content for your audience
you're not creating it for the entire
world now we know on youtube there's a
lot of cute videos about kittens and
jokes and you know people playing games
and you know everybody likes positive
things on youtube but you know when
we're talking about a specific topic you
know we really have to hone in on a
target audience and so if you know who
your audience is then you can really
hone in on your content okay so that's
the first thing ask yourself who is your
audience and then build your content
around that specific audience don't
build it just for the mass general
population because it's not going to be
engaging and informative so that's the
first place to start then you want to
engage that audience with relevant
content so if you know your audience and
depending on the topic you want to make
sure that whatever the topic is the
content matches the topic don't veer off
course if you veer off course you're not
going to engage your viewers your
viewers are coming to watch the video
for specific reason the reason is the
topic okay so if they're your target
audience and they want to watch the
video that's a specific topic then the
content has to align so plan your video
script so if you know who your audience
is and you know you want to engage them
with relevant content go ahead and plan
the script out so what i normally do is
you know have an outline and then once i
have the outline then i go ahead and
create my slides if i will or my topics
points i want to talk about and then i
write out those points i want to make
sure i get all my points in and that's
what you should be doing you want to
plan it ahead of time so that you can
get all your relevant points across
that's what makes a video informative
okay you want to ensure to give maximum
information to your audience so the key
here is maximum information so you don't
want to overload the audience but then
again you want to cut out information so
you want to make sure that when you're
planning your script and you're writing
the outline that you're making sure you
include all your points that you want to
get across once you include those points
then go ahead and you know write your
script and make sure all the information
for all those points are in the script
that's how you're going to ensure you
give maximum information but you don't
want to overdo it so if you feel like
it's too much information it probably is
too much information back off a little
use the information to create another
video so it's all about knowing your
audience so all of these points play
against one another so be clear and use
more examples in your content just like
we're doing here okay just like at the
beginning of the session i showed you an
example of simply learned subscribers
over the past 365 days and so that's
what we want to do we want to be clear
but use examples to punctuate the
content or the point we're trying to get
across so we want to include sources
from high quality sites so if you're
going to use examples make sure they're
from relevant high quality sites and
what i mean high quality meaning does
your audience know who that source is or
that site if it's really specific and
your audience may not know then it's
probably not high quality so just keep
that in mind always play to your
audience so you want to start your video
with an interesting hook so again i go
back to this example if you're still
watching this then the hook worked we
showed you our subscriptions we showed
you how we grew over the course of a
year you could see our growth and part
of it was posting a lot of videos with
relevant and informative content and so
you see how we did it so you're paying
attention you want to know how to do it
and so part of what we did is exactly
what i'm telling you now we know who our
audience is we plan out our scripts we
use good examples and we start our
videos with interesting hooks now when
we do our videos we also create original
content so that goes back to planning
your script okay you always want to you
know come across as original and
informative when you do that you're
going to be engaging but if you're
leveraging somebody else's content then
the engaging part may not resonate
because it's not your content to begin
with so always always always use
original content okay so keep the
content flow organized so again that
goes back to an outline you know feel
free to change up the outline so the
flow makes sense add visuals to your
content and make it appealing always
include images to me if you can use
images in your videos and play off the
video or the images then it's just gonna
flow and make it a little bit more
engaging and appealing meaning the
content so visuals help guide and aid in
the points you're trying to make so
don't make it so text heavy you know
accentuate it balance it with some
images use simple language and crisp
sentences meaning don't choose jargon
don't come across and talk above your
audience you always want to talk to your
audience and talk in a language that
they're going to understand so it goes
back to point one if you know who your
audience is you're talking to them as if
they're right in front of you and not
you're above them or they're below you
you want to talk at them so add cards
and screens and pattern interrupts to
engage your audience and so youtube
cards are just interactive panels that
slide in and out when a video is playing
so it encourages
interaction by the viewer okay so you
can add up to five cards which include
images text or clickable links so feel
free to play around with some of these
features that youtube has to offer to
make your content more engaging so tip
two publish videos frequently so
creating and uploading videos
consistently will help you increase your
youtube subscribers so suppose you
haven't published videos for more than
say a month or two months it's likely
that that audience not gonna subscribe
to your channel so think about youtube
videos as a popular tv program that
comes on once a week when a new episode
comes on based on the regular schedule
it's consistency and that consistency is
what helps your users stay engaged so
for example if i go back to our youtube
channel you know what helped us gain
subscribers was our consistency in
publishing videos you could see we were
consistent publishing a couple of videos
a week every couple of weeks and so this
helps users stay engaged they know when
the video is coming out they know that
simply learn is good for two three four
videos a month and the great thing about
publishing videos is that when somebody
does subscribe to your channel they're
gonna get a notification or youtube has
an option where they can get a
notification via email so i subscribe to
simplylearn's channel i subscribe to
other channels like google analytics for
example so anytime google analytics
publishes a video i get an email that
says hey google analytics youtube
channel just published a video and the
great thing is i'm checking my email and
i'm getting this notification in gmail
so guess what i can watch the video
right then and there just by clicking on
the link in the email i don't even have
to go to the channel but knowing that if
you publish consistently and somebody
does get the email once a week then it's
more likely they're going to engage
especially if the content is original
engaging and informative so frequent
video publishing equals more
subscriptions so according to social
media examiner youtube channels that
publish videos more than once a week are
performing much better so if you can
afford to publish more videos more than
once a week the chances of you gaining
subscribers quicker are going to be
greater so keeping a fixed frequency can
help you quickly gain more subscribers
posting videos is like almost like
blogging i always say start small if you
could do one blog post a month and then
once you get in a routine then you can
ramp up the frequency so from one blog
post you could do two a month then four
times a month and once a week or twice a
week same with the youtube videos you
want to get into a rhythm you know start
with once a month and ramp it up okay
you'll find that the more you ramp it up
the more subscribers you're gonna get so
tip three optimize your youtube videos
so optimizing your videos will help your
content rank higher on youtube so this
is a give must it's not a given it's a
must you must optimize your videos if
you want people to see them of course if
you don't optimize people aren't going
to see them then people aren't going to
engage and then not subscribe so it's
just kind of a snowball effect so this
is an important tip so i mentioned it at
the beginning when we were going over
all the items we're going to discuss
this is the one item that is a must and
a given to some degree because if you
don't optimize your videos they're just
not going to be found so you need that
audience to watch your video so
audiences who tend to interact more with
your content have more chance to
subscribe to your channel but they're
not going to subscribe if they don't
even watch your video so there is a
snowball effect in play here if we don't
optimize your videos so okay rob what
are some of the tips to optimize your
youtube video well let's go through some
of those tips so to ensure your videos
reaches the relevant audience on youtube
you need to optimize the title
description in the video tag okay rob
what do you mean by title description
and video tag so let's take a look at
that so when you actually create your
youtube video you're going to have an
opportunity to put in a title you're
going to have an opportunity to put in a
description and you're going to have an
opportunity to add text so those are the
three key areas okay so once you put in
that what it looks like on the front end
is this so if i go back to youtube and
here you can see another video that we
did about a month ago you could see what
is seo so if that's our topic that's our
title uh or of the content of the video
then the title of the video is going to
be what is seo and you can see we also
added in some other content for the
title so what is seo and how does it
work seo tutorial for beginners and then
our brand name so we have some content
to work with for the title okay and then
the description we have a lot of
characters to work with description so
use as much as you can here to describe
what the video is about here you can see
we did that and so it's always good to
include this information okay and then
you can see we have tags up here seo seo
tutorial for beginners digital marketing
so we put in the necessary information
here on this video to help us rank
because if we don't optimize it we're
not going to rank and so you can see we
just put a lot of relevant content
around the description around the title
and around those tags by doing so we're
able to optimize this video and get
found so that's just an example three of
the things you can do to help optimize
your youtube video so if you want to
watch more on how to optimize meta tags
then i suggest maybe watching the other
video we did on the subject how to rank
youtube videos so this goes into more
detail about how to optimize the title
the meta description and the meta tags
but there's a three quick fields or
areas that you can use to optimize your
video so just something to keep in mind
write a long description with keywords
time stamps and links so what i mean by
time stamps with time stamp an audience
can choose the section of the video that
they want to look for and then links
prefer to include relevant links of your
other videos so those are just some
additional tips to help keep your
content engaging so remember when your
content is engaging then people are
going to like it people are going to
share it and watch it later so upload a
captivating thumbnail okay so you want
to include a thumbnail that's going to
grab people's attention you want to
upload a transcript of the video so that
goes back to when you're creating your
content when you write your original
content you want to keep a transcript of
the content of the video so that you can
upload that as well and then add a start
screen and end screen to your youtube
videos so that way you know when
somebody plays the video they're going
to see it what it looks like up front
and then when we finish it they're going
to see an end screen at the end and so
you just don't want to keep it dark and
black and non-descriptive so according
to backlinko using an exact keyword in
your video title can help you with
rankings so high ranking more views more
views more subscribers so that's what
i've been saying all along you need to
get these videos optimized so again use
an exact keyword in your video title so
let's go back again to that video i just
showed you a couple minutes ago what is
seo so here we started out with a
question what is seo that's the name of
the title that's one our exact title of
the video that's our exact keyword okay
so what is seo and how does it work and
then seo tutorial for beginners so what
is seo is our exact keyword and that's
part of the video that's the content of
the video that's in the title and we use
it throughout the description as well so
using that exact keyword in your video
title can help with the ranking so
whatever your topic is your title of the
video or the topic of the video include
it in the title so backlinko also
mentions that there is a moderate
correlation between a channel's total
subscribers and rankings and so for some
of you this may be common sense it's
just like organic search if you're not
ranking you're not going to get traffic
on youtube if you're not ranking you're
not going to get eyeballs on your videos
and you're not going to get subscribers
so higher rankings can help you to get
more subscribers but you can't get those
rankings unless you optimize and so
again just for the sake of simplicity
going back focus in on your title make
sure your title matches the title of the
video itself when you're publishing your
description use all the amount of
content available to you so you can see
it this entire description has a lot of
content maximize the content and then
use tags using those three fields those
three areas can help you optimize your
video and gain the necessary ranking you
need to get viewers which will turn into
subscribers so tip four optimize your
youtube channel so we just talked about
optimizing our videos now we're gonna
turn our attention to our youtube
channel so one of the easiest ways to
ask your views to subscribe to your
channel is really by creating a good not
even a good a great youtube channel
trailer you also want to add channel
keywords a description and some good
artwork and then having sections and
playlists to keep your videos organized
these are all good tips to creating a
good youtube channel so let's talk about
some of these these tips here so we want
to give your audience a preview what
your channel is offering so this is by
hooking your audience with a trailer so
you can create a trailer to you know
just give your audience an idea of who
you are as a brand what kind of videos
you're going to be posting and give them
a kind of a taste of what the future
videos are going to be like okay you can
even tell them your release schedule in
the trailer so you can start out by
saying hey hey guys we're new to this
we're gonna be posting one video a month
but as we get rolling maybe two per
month and you know one per week you know
just being honest and open and talking
into your audience and get them excited
about future videos that's what the
trailer is all about so you also want to
keep it that the channel description
short interesting so in your channel you
want to have a description of what the
channel is all about what kind of videos
you're going to be posting so in
addition to the trailer you want to
write something short and interesting
then we want to use keywords in our
channel descriptions just like in the
videos with what is seo we included what
is seo in the title we included you know
what is seo in the description and so we
want to be true to what our channel is
so pick keywords not only include those
keywords in the videos but include them
in the channel description pay attention
to the first 100 to 150 characters of
your channel description because that's
what's shown next your channel on the
search results so for example here you
can see
we have a description here simply learn
is one of the world's leading
certification training providers we
partner with companies and individuals
to address and so you can see those
characters
100-150 are what shows up in the channel
description when somebody's trying to
understand hey simply learn just
uploaded this video who is simply
learning so you want to write short
interesting channel description so that
when somebody's first introduced to your
video they could see what your brand's
all about so and your description with
an appropriate call to action so short
interesting good call to action at the
end of the video a good call to action
would be hey check out our next video or
check out our latest video something
that's going to gauge somebody and get
them to watch one of your videos so you
want to pick interesting channel art so
let's turn our attention to the simply
learn channel page and here you can see
we recently
had reached a milestone so recently
reached the two hundred thousand k
subscribers so two hundred 000
subscribers is a big achievement for
simply learn we went ahead and updated
our channel r and i'm sure we will reach
500k we'll update the artwork then too
but the point is you want to keep your
channel art kind of interesting hip and
cool and feel free to change it out
every once in a while so you have that
option in youtube to do i mean it's very
simple so here you can see simply learns
channel we go home get all our videos
listed here we got the about us you know
something very short interesting about
us here's our call to action for more
information visit simply learn so you
want to make sure when you create your
channel get some good artwork in there
put your description in play and create
your first videos and get them posted up
there and optimize them accordingly okay
so some other tips to go with that
channel art and description is a profile
picture relevant to your brand so you
always want to maybe put
the company logo up there okay so here
you can see we have the company logo at
accurate relevant channel keywords so if
we go back to who we are who are we
we're the world's leading certification
training provider okay that's who we are
okay we partner with companies and
individuals so we're all about training
and training is one of our key words so
you could see at simply learn we provide
online training and machine learning aws
amazon web services devops big data
digital marketing project management a
lot of different topics so make sure
that's included in the channel
description feature the playlist on your
home page so if we go back to the home
page we can see here we have our
channels so you can see we have ai
machine learning trending technologies
cloud computing tutorials dev op
tutorials popular videos big data we
have a lot of different channels so you
want to organize your videos into
different playlists so those playlists
are going to feature on the home page of
your channel so how you organize the
playlist is totally up to you but i
would certainly create a playlist for
different sections so depending on your
product your services think about how
you want to organize don't just stick
all your videos in one playlist then
optimize the playlist titles and
descriptions for search rankings so just
like the videos themselves just like the
channel description you have an
opportunity to optimize the playlist
titles and descriptions so be very keen
on aligning the right keyword with the
playlist title so here you can see
programming language tutorials project
management tutorials digital marketing
tutorials so we're very clear on how we
go about choosing our titles because we
want to optimize those playlist titles
okay we can rearrange our videos in a
playlist so we want to rearrange the
videos in a way that we're maybe putting
the freshest the most newest the video
that's been published last first so
almost in descending order if you will
so we want our users to see what video
has the latest in that particular
playlist so they're seeing the most
recent first but you can rearrange your
videos any way you want feel free to
play around with it of course you can
also take the video that's the most
popular and put that up front so people
could see that first vice versa you
could take a video that maybe hasn't
gotten a lot of views or isn't ranked
particularly high maybe put that video
up so it can get some views and some
shares and likes so how you rearrange
your videos is totally up to you just
have some rationale behind that so
choose a playlist thumbnail from a top
performing video so for example if i go
back to our youtube page you can see the
top performing videos here you know for
example this one we got a nice thumbnail
here what is machine learning so if i
click on that
most popular videos so 3 000 likes on
this video a lot of views 250 000 plus
views so have a thumbnail to go along
with that particular video so according
to backlinko youtube seo ranking factor
study discovered that channel keywords
have a small yet significant correlation
with higher youtube search rankings so
channel keywords so when you're
optimizing your channel and you want to
include keywords start with your
description so if i go back to our
channel if i go back about us make sure
your description has those relevant
keywords in it that's where it all
starts so in case you have any doubts if
you're not sure about everything we
talked about on optimizing the channel
go ahead and drop a comment below
because we do respond to every comment
that gets posted on our videos so if
you're not sure how to go about
optimizing your channel when you say
align keywords with the channel what
does that really mean so if you want
some clarity on that go ahead and drop
us a channel if you're not sure about
the trailer video drop us a comment
we're more than happy to expand upon the
explanation of how to best optimize your
channel okay tip number five produce
high quality videos so we need to get in
the habit of producing high quality
videos because viewers don't prefer to
watch videos that have poor audio and
video quality it's just that simple you
need to know what it takes to produce
high quality videos if you don't you're
just going to discredit you're not going
to come across as relevant you know i'm
going to come across as qualified
professional there's a lot of things
attached to poor quality videos so we
need to
create high quality videos for the end
user so let's talk about some ways in
which you can create high quality videos
and so the first is to avoid any noise
in the background so you want to have a
nice quiet atmosphere no distractions so
people can hear you clearly and only you
clearly you want to use good audio
recording equipment there's plenty of
options available on the internet
usually i would recommend going with
something paid not overly expensive
because you get what you pay for so if
you use something free it might not be
of good quality and you might not have
all the features and bells and whistles
with a free option so you know use good
audio recording equipment again it could
be online or it could be some software
just make sure that you're able to
produce good high quality video and
audio so when you do purchase that audio
recording equipment you want to have
something similar to an input volume
meter that way you can see whether your
audio is coming across or not so if
you're not seeing green lights then your
audio is not coming across if it's red
it might be distorted and so you want
something that's going to signify that
you're really pushing out good quality
audio you want to create your videos in
10 80 pixel size okay that's hd and so
you want to have at least minimum 1080.
so anything less than that it's probably
going to come across as not so good
maybe staticky blurry
not professional not high def so you
want to create a high def video and 1080
is about the minimum you want to go and
then you want to plan your video script
before filming so it goes back to some
of the other points i made earlier you
always want to have a video script
available so you know what you're saying
when you're recording your audio that
way you're not doing something on the
fly then you want to use good lighting
for video recording so you don't want to
be in a dark place you want some nice
lighting so your video comes across well
lit people could see you they're not
struggling to strain their eyes on what
it is you're trying to show and appear
because of poor lighting again it just
comes across as professional so if you
can you know shoot a high def video with
good audio speaking clearly having a
professional script with some good
lighting then people are going to take
you serious and they're going to start
to listen and engage and and see the
video as good quality and very relevant
and informative and share it so use slow
motion and jump cuts wisely so there's
some features you could do with your
video you know using slow motion and
jump cuts are some of the features you
can use to
accentuate your points and then set up a
green background for recording again
this is for you know making sure that
the video part of it comes across in
good quality then stabilize your video
recordings with a tripod that way you're
not moving your video camera all around
and and again it's coming across as
shaky and poor quality shoot horizontal
videos you don't want to go vertical it
tends to cut the screen so you want to
stay horizontal so that people can see
everything that should be included in
the video okay you want to capture a
wider shot using a clip-on lens again a
good feature a good tip to use use that
wider shot okay so you could do that
using a clip-on lens and then choose
good video editing software i can't
state this enough because you're putting
all this time and effort into a video
you need to be able to edit it to cut
out you know some of the things you
didn't want to say or maybe some poor
quality or or you know you just want to
have a smooth professional output for
your video and so you gotta have good
video editing software there's plenty of
options available on the internet again
i would go with something low cost but
paid usually free isn't exactly the way
you want to go if you're trying to
create a high def good quality video and
at the very least review your work
before publishing i just said it a
minute ago i'll say it again you want to
be able to have a really professional
video and high def when you have a good
professional video and high def with
good audio horizontal shots you know
nice green background image nice well
lit it's gonna come across as
professional and if you have a
professional video then people are gonna
take you seriously they're gonna see you
as a professional and then share or
subscribe and like and then they're
gonna watch more videos and and that's
how you start to build up a reputation
as being a very professional
organization so just following these
simple tips on producing high quality
videos so you want to review your work
because if you don't you put all that
effort into it and then you're going to
realize hey your video is low quality
and then you're going to have to do it
all over again so follow these tips get
a high quality video and you should be
on your way to ranking in fact according
to backlinko youtube preferably ranks hd
videos so you got to have that 1080 uh
pixel size that way you know your video
is gonna come across crisp and clear and
youtube prefers that tip six add a
subscriber watermark to your videos so
this is a great feature in youtube so
it's a feature that allows you to add a
watermark that can be shown on all your
videos the reason why you want that
watermark because you want to keep
reminding your audience to subscribe to
your channel the watermark can be
whatever you want but normally it's
going to be some type of logo or brand
and a call to action and so how do you
add a watermark to your video well you
log into your youtube account it's
pretty simple at the top right corner
you're gonna select your creator studio
icon and then you're gonna go to channel
select branding and then add a watermark
to your video so if we look at that in
youtube so here creator studio on the
left side navigation i'm just gonna
click channel then i'm going to click
branding and then once you click
branding you have the ability to add
your watermark and then you can add it
to the entire video at the end of the
video at a specific start time and then
just click update and that's pretty much
it so you want to be able to add this so
that you can brand your videos with an
image and then add that cta so this is a
good good feature for youtube it allows
you to be consistent with all your
videos by branding and adding that call
to action tip seven engage with your
audience so you want to be able to
interact with your audience as much as
possible just because the video and you
can't see people doesn't mean you can't
engage with them so when you interact
with your viewers especially when you
interact with them immediately there's
gratification you know everybody likes
to be responded to nobody likes to be
ignored and so when somebody is
responded to there's a higher chance
that your viewers are likely to gonna
become customers it's just customer
service is how you really wanna look at
this okay so when you engage you're
creating a service for your customers so
here are some tips on how to engage with
your audience so first is at the end of
every video convey a thank you message
to your viewers you know thank you for
spending the time out of your busy day
to watch this video you know some of our
videos go an hour plus long and so when
somebody's taking an hour to watch a
video it's only the least you can do is
thank them now you could thank them and
give them some information about where
to go for more information because if
they watch the whole video they're
already engaged and they're probably
going to want to learn more so you
always want to follow up to thank you
with where to go for more information
just like our videos always convey at
the end okay you always want to ask your
audience for their feedback or ideas on
the video so with youtube
there's a comment section and you always
want to encourage comments so comments
can be in the form of feedback so as
you're watching this video feel free to
leave feedback on other ways to engage
with your audience or some other tips to
increase your subscribers on youtube so
we're always looking for those ideas we
want to keep it engaging so somebody may
have some other ideas that we didn't
think about and so we always appreciate
that from our audience so we very much
appreciate the feedback that our
audience gives us so not all the
feedback is always going to be positive
some of the feedback could be less than
positive or even negative there could be
mistakes so the idea behind getting
feedback is you want to look at it you
want to read it and you want to react to
it you want to react to it positively in
the form of you know what thank you for
the feedback and looking at the feedback
weighing it and incorporating the
feedback so you don't always want to
make the same mistake twice in a video
so if there's something definitely wrong
with the video that we're doing for
example and somebody looked at it and
gave us feedback on it we'd certainly
definitely take a deep look into that
and try not to do the same mistake twice
because likely that user is going to
watch the video again so you always want
to learn from your mistakes and you want
to turn those mistakes or turn those
comments into future videos okay so
create videos based on your commenter's
request the audience has given us
feedback we should take that as positive
and sometimes that's creative sometimes
as ideas for more videos okay you always
want to ask questions to your audience
and reward excellent commenters so we
try to ask questions in our videos and
when users respond with the answer if
there's an excellent comment or
excellent answer you know we can reward
them you know reward them in the form of
say some type of gift card or gift
certificate or promotion or something
there's always some way to incentivize
somebody who provides excellent feedback
you can always give emoji hearts there's
so many emojis out there that you can
use emojis just to engage with your
audience based on the feedback that
they're giving the point is if your
audience has taken the time to give
feedback you always want to respond to
it and you want to respond to a positive
so emojis tend to have a positive
connotation to them and so responding
with an emoji especially to a favorite
comment goes a long way so you can
reward your community both on and off
youtube for their engagement and support
and that's just being creative you can
reward in many ways many ways not
necessarily monetarily but by
recognition you could do promotions you
could do something fun there's always
ways to reward and prefer to host live
streams and interact with your audience
so you don't always have to do a
pre-recorded video there's certainly
youtube has them other platforms like
facebook have them instagram so you can
certainly reach out to your audience
with a live stream and that's talking
directly to your audience right there in
the flesh so when you can have an
opportunity to talk to your audience and
engage with them that's always going to
work because they can see personality
they can see what you're all about and
there's two-way conversation and so that
will lend to more of a you know
relationship so to speak with your
audience so you want to create videos
for subscribers subscribers can get
impressed when a channel dedicates a
video for them so you know take the time
out to create a video just for your
subscribers subscribers are the ones who
are most likely going to engage with you
okay they're your loyal fan base so if
you create something for them that's a
form of a reward so you can captivate
your viewers by uploading interesting
youtube stories as well you can also
hear from your audience and get their
videos and use their videos and upload
them to your channel so according to
backlinko video comments have a very
strong correlation with rankings so as
you create a video feel free to talk to
your audience and ask them hey if you
have any comments feel free to put them
in the comment section right below this
video i see that a lot now with a lot of
videos and i'm gonna ask my audience
right now to do the same thing if
there's anything you see about rewarding
the audience or engaging with the
audience feel free to comment we'd love
to get your suggestions because if you
can engage with the audience even more
then that's only going to net positive
results not only in rankings but with
your subscriber base so comments are the
way to go solicit comments respond to
the comments reward the comments tip
number eight promote your videos on
different platforms so promoting your
videos on different platforms has been
around for many years it's a good
strategy once you create your video on
youtube you want people to see it you
want to get it out there so if you want
to increase your youtube subscribers
this is a strategy you have to perform
so let's take a look at all the ways you
can use and leverage different platforms
to increase your subscribers so before
you do that you want to research
discover how and
you can use different platforms so the
first thing you want to do is look at
the platforms you're already using if
you're using facebook and instagram
that's probably a good place to start
but there's other platforms you can also
leverage and we're going to talk about
those so social media most companies
most individuals are on in some form or
fashion amongst the most popular like
facebook and instagram so you could
start there so with facebook you can
post something include the link of your
youtube video with facebook if you're a
business you have a business page you're
communicating with your community and
that's a great way to get started by
promoting your youtube video you can
also do the same on twitter or instagram
or whatever platform you're on go ahead
and post something or tweet something
and include that link to youtube you can
participate in forums and blog
discussions so there's plenty of forums
and blogs out there where you can
participate in discussion and include a
link to the youtube video if it's
relevant and natural so for example here
there's a blog about machine learning
you can include if you have a video
about machine learning and the response
to that conversation in this example
we've done that on reddit you can list
your video in relevant and reputable
directories there's plenty of
directories out there there's plenty of
video directories okay that you can just
go ahead and publish your video on you
can use testimonial link building okay
so somebody can provide a testimonial
include the link of your video you can
opt for influencer marketing so if
there's somebody that is associated that
likes your brand or product and has a
large following you can ask them to post
a video on your behalf it's a great way
to reach an audience fairly quickly okay
you can earn backlinks from relative
relevant and authoritative websites so
for example if you look at this website
here
genix okay there's a article here about
you know certificate of achievements
okay for aws so if you scroll down we
could see our video is included here
in this particular web page so this is a
high quality web page okay that's
generating a backlink for us not only is
it generating a backlink it's also
generating traffic and awareness for the
video go ahead and find out if there's
any websites that are relevant to your
video topic and see if you can
collaborate with them on producing a web
page to include that video you can also
take advantage of email marketing by
adding your youtube link in the email
signature for example it's a simple
email any email client like gmail or
yahoo or even hotmail or outlook is
going to have an ability to or give you
the ability to add a signature in the
signature you could simply just include
a link to the video or to your youtube
channel it doesn't have to be do a
specific video but it's a way to get
people to your youtube page or to that
video so the whole idea is more eyeballs
more potential subscribers engage your
audience by posting your video links on
community pages so for example you know
we're promoting something here on a
community page and that's going to get
some additional traffic over to us you
can always bookmark your videos on
bookmarking sites like stumbleupon.com
again this is free very little time to
do this but it's a chance for you to get
the video out there and even generate a
backlink you can collaborate with other
youtube channels this is always a good
strategy if you're creating a video on a
particular topic on youtube chances are
there's probably somebody else out there
doing the same thing it doesn't have to
be necessarily a competitor it can be a
complimentary product or service and if
you offer that then go ahead and
collaborate with them and see if you can
exchange your videos on their channel
and you can take their video and put it
on your channel in a particular playlist
okay so that's a way to collaborate with
other youtube channels is swap videos
you could join high pr qa sites and post
answers to the questions related to your
video like core is always a good example
or e-hop okay so core there's always a
question being posted and if you have
the answer to that question in the form
of your video then go ahead and post a
response with a link to the video on
youtube it's a great way to get the
video noticed and it's relevant and
natural okay you can embed videos in
your blog post so if you're using a
platform like wordpress for example very
easy to go ahead and just take that
video you can even just put the link in
the blog post i like this option i think
blog posts are always good because you
don't have to be text heavy with a blog
post you want to create a blog post
that's nice and balanced with an image
and text but if you put a video to
support your blog post that goes even
further and blog posts themselves can be
engaging and interactive with your
audience so having a video in your blog
post always goes well in my opinion okay
so you can promote other videos in your
end screen for example at the end of
your video you can always promote
something related like we've done here
in this example so lots of ideas get
your video out there use them in email
use them in your blog post go to free
bookmarking sites like stumbleupon you
know collaborate with other people on
youtube you know go to core respond to a
question use social media to your
advantage there's lots of opportunities
to get your video out there the more you
can get your video out there the more
traffic you're gonna get the more
traffic you get to the video the more
subscribers you're going to get so
that's how the game is played in order
to get your video out there but these
are relatively you know low time
consuming ideas to get your video so
we're going to talk about how to get
traffic to your website so thank you for
joining and let's get started so
let's imagine you're setting up your own
website okay you're clicking away you're
developing using some good tools you're
developing you're designing
you're doing some qa
you're testing you're sharing with
friends in an alpha version and then
finally
your website is all set up
congratulations well when you hit enter
and your website is finally published
what's going to happen well a few days
later you're checking your website and
you're looking at analytics and you
notice your traffic's very low okay well
you're scratching your head because
you've done all this work with your
website but you're not getting any
traffic so the reason is
you
spent all your time developing and
designing the website to make it look
good but you didn't do anything or any
planning or any strategy around bringing
users to your website so the two go hand
in hand you just can't build a website
without
thinking about how to drive users to the
website and so before i tell you how to
bring traffic to your website let me
tell you why this is so important okay
why do we want to bring users to our
website i mean it has to be on equal
ground as web development and design is
somebody who goes to your site and then
does something when they get to your
site so you have users and when those
users get to your site they're
generating page views and traffic and
you want to turn that traffic into
engagement okay so each page's traffic
is configured independently of all their
pages so when you go when somebody goes
to your website they look at a page
that's a page view in certain pages on
your website you want to turn that page
view into a conversion okay whether that
be
you know looking at a video or
purchasing something so think of these
pages on your website as salespeople
they're trying to convert visitors who
come to your website but first we need
to get the visitors to your website so
when you get visitors to your website
again you can generate sales which means
revenue or you can increase brand
awareness or you can earn revenue
through sponsored posts and
advertisements so if you have for
example a lot of content on your website
you can turn that in to
revenue by hosting ads on your website
so when somebody clicks on that ad
you're gonna earn a percentage of that
click okay what that click is worth so
having a website means
a lot of good things for you but first
you got to get the traffic there and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
tell you how to drive traffic to your
website so there's lots of different
ways in which you can bring traffic to
your website well the first is paid
advertising so paying to advertise your
products services with ads is one of the
easiest ways to drive traffic to your
website so some of the options available
are
search ads social media ads or display
ads so search ads are ads that are
displayed in the search engine results
so when a user types in a keyword query
you want your ad to show up based on
that keyword query okay so an example is
digital marketing course somebody types
in digital marketing course and simply
learn is the first app that shows up how
do we know it's an ad because you can
see the word add next to the domain so
when somebody clicks on that link simply
learn is going to pay google so that's
how search advertising works okay the
next is social so social media marketing
involves increasing traffic or
engagement or brand awareness a lot of
different strategies but you're instead
of doing this on search you're doing it
on a social media platform okay so for
example
you can advertise on any particular
platform and the way you advertise could
be with an image it could be with a
video so in this case you could see
cobreo
is doing a sponsored ad here how to
succeed with google ads and then another
form of advertising is display so
display means creating ads that are
placed on specific websites so with
display
unlike search you have a choice in the
ad format with search you only have text
ads but with display you have text edge
image ads rich media ads video ads so
you have lots of different options in
which you can advertise on other
websites so the idea here is to get your
ad in front of the right audience when
they could see your display banner your
banner ad then it's going to be more
visual
more appealing generate some brand
interest and hopefully you can get
somebody to click on that ad and over to
your website so that's paid advertising
again through search through social
through display but you can also promote
your site on social media so once your
content has gone live you could take
advantage of different social media
platforms i mean it really depends on
what you're trying to promote because
what you're trying to promote needs to
align with the appropriate social media
platform so
facebook is best suited for industries
like food and beverages and news and
media and if you're selling a product so
you fall into one of those categories
and facebook could be the right platform
for you if you're involved in again
beauty or food and beverage or
e-commerce then you can also leverage
instagram which is part of facebook's
ecosystem so if you advertise on
facebook you can also advertise on
instagram and or instagram so it doesn't
have to be and facebook and instagram it
could be facebook or instagram you also
have linkedin as a platform linkedin is
great for b2b so
if you're trying to promote industry
news or or tips and best practices or
job postings then linkedin is the place
for you it's a b2b platform it's great
for
targeting specific industries targeting
specific job levels or job descriptions
okay so linkedin is great if you're into
b2b focusing on the business side of it
so you also have youtube now youtube is
part of google's ecosystem youtube is a
video platform okay so it's great if
you're trying to promote gaming or
entertainment if you're a vlogger okay
so youtube's a great way to promote your
site uh by getting your product out
there in the form of a video and then
you have twitter twitter to me
encompasses a lot of different
industries beauty and fitness news and
media entertainment
okay you have limited number of
characters but a lot of people are
active on twitter and it's a great way
to generate some awareness and get some
clicks over to your website so these are
just some of the most popular social
media platforms of course there are
plenty more out there the third way in
which you can drive traffic to your site
is guest post blogging so
most of you already know what blogging's
all about well if you're blogging for
your own site you can jump on somebody
else's site and blog on their behalf so
having the opportunity to guest post on
another website can be very helpful
because one that other blog could have
lots of traffic and have a a well-known
brand so if you're blogging on another
blog it's going to build your brand
awareness and potentially increase
traffic to your blog or website so it
exposes to you to targeted traffic so if
you're going to guest blog guest blog on
a site that's very relevant to your
business or industry that way you're
targeting the right audience okay you
can expand your personal network so
getting yourself out there getting your
brand out there in front of a different
audience and then obviously for serves
because it generates a backlink so serps
search engine ranking pages means that
hey if you want to rank organically
you're going to have to generate some
backlinks so guest blogging is a way to
generate some back links to your site
and an effect that's going to help you
get your pages ranked higher because
google is going to recognize the
relationship from one blog to your blog
and build up your relevancy so some
other benefits here to guest blogging is
you can grow your social media following
because you can then promote that on
social media that you're guest blogging
okay again you can improve your online
authority okay because when you're guest
blogging and you have recognition on
that guest blog if it's a popular blog
then it's not going to help your domain
and page authority for seo and then the
end result is going to improve your
backlink score so a lot of benefits to
guest blogging to me at the end of the
day it's just about reaching out to your
audience using another platform to do
that in the form of a blog and the
results of that is going to mean more
brand awareness for you and turning that
traffic from that other blog into
qualified leads so you can also
interview industry thought leaders so
that's another way an interesting way to
generate traffic to your site so
reaching out to thought leaders for
interviews okay could generate some
credibility for you and the other person
so it's reciprocal so it means that
you're active in the industry that
you're in and it allows you to engage
with other
leaders in the industry and the indirect
net result of that could be increased
traffic because if you do the interview
and you record it or if it's via video
then you can obviously post it on other
platforms and that could in turn drive
traffic to your website obviously just
like guest blogging it's going to
increase your reach so getting yourself
out there if nobody knows who your brand
is and they know who the thought leaders
are and they see you're interviewing the
thought leaders then that's going to put
you in front of these people and so it's
going to increase your reach another way
to drive traffic to your website is just
to make sure your website's responsive
and what do we mean by response of well
we mean does it work on multiple devices
specifically mobile
so depending on the device your website
hides shows shrinks enlarges or moves
content so that it conforms to the
browser that that person's looking at on
your web for your website so if
somebody's looking on mobile at your
website you want to make sure that your
website adjusts accordingly so you want
to be able to you know test to make sure
it's responsive and so is content
arranged based on importance okay does
it work across different browsers on
different devices and do the images text
and everything else align just like it
does on desktop so there are plenty of
tools out there on the web all you need
to do is just do a search for you know
check my website for responsiveness you
know so you you can use plenty of tools
to check to see if your website is
responsive towards multiple devices why
is that important because if somebody
goes to your website via mobile and your
site doesn't align properly or the
contents all stretched out and somebody
has to maneuver their browser just to
see your website then chances are
they're not going to come back chances
are they're not going to convert okay so
you want to be able to revise your
device browser combinations you want to
make sure that everything works
accordingly you want to be able to test
those fonts make sure they look good and
then you also want to make sure that
people can navigate so if they're on
mobile are they going to navigate just
as easy as they can on desktop and if
you have any pop-ups you want to
probably make sure they're removed so
that way when somebody's looking at your
website they're not getting interfered
with on mobile and then of course you
want to make sure that these pages load
okay so they load just as quick on
desktop as they should on mobile and
vice versa so they should not take a
long time to load so moving on from
responsiveness on mobile to building a
brand community so brand community
refers to a group of people who identify
your brand and use your brand as a
platform to exchange ideas and
contribute content some advantages of
having a brand community are promoting
brand evangelism and loyalty it can be a
source of feedback loyalty and ideas so
build a community build a brand
community who you know identify with you
okay so continue to
you know treat these people as loyal
customers okay maybe give them a
promotion uh to use specifically just
for them that they can use on your
website or talk directly to them because
you know that they're followers they're
repeat customers they purchase for you
multiple times so talk to them
differently as well you know who these
people are and that's what building a
brand is all about it's about
identifying your brand with other people
okay and then identify people who
identify with your brand and messaging
and talking to them as if they're part
of your own community your own family so
you can use user generated content that
provides future marketing strategies so
the feedback you get from your own
community could be in turn used to
promote or used in future marketing
strategies i.e advertising i.e
post on social okay it can also provide
pr opportunities so it's a chance for
you to you know put out press releases
based on the community that you built so
any brand regardless of who it is should
be able to identify with your audience
their target audience and that target
audience eventually going to become part
of a community these are group of people
who identify with you what you're trying
to sell what your cause is what your
mission statement is what your services
they identify with you so leverage them
and reciprocate identify them talk to
them separately
give them the what they deserve the
respect and loyalty that they deserve as
well because they're communicating and
they're following you as a brand so the
next thing you could do
to drive traffic is be active in the
comments section so engage in relevant
and thought-provoking conversations on
other blogs and sites it doesn't
necessarily have to be another blog per
se could be other sites like reddit or
quora or media sites that have a lot of
content that are broken out by industry
that allow you to engage in conversation
allow you to either upvote or share or
respond okay so be active because when
you're active people are gonna see that
hey
you're a leader in the industry you know
what you're talking about you have some
some brand equity you have some thought
and some knowledge on the specific topic
and subject so it just puts you in a
better light when you can respond and be
active on these different platforms okay
let's turn our attention to
search engine optimization also known as
seo or organic search so in order to
drive traffic to your site you're going
to have to implement an seo strategy why
do you want to implement an seo strategy
because it can help you improve your
overall search ability and visibility on
search engines and obviously that comes
with advantages one of those advantages
is obviously more traffic to the site
search is still king in terms of volumes
of people using search on a daily basis
so you have a great opportunity to be
found it also builds trust and
credibility because still a majority of
the people who do a search click on an
organic search listing and so if you're
found organically
and you're ranked number one then
chances are somebody's going to click on
your listing and it provides increased
engagement and traffic and so what that
means is more traffic more engagement an
engagement is something you define it
could be again a download of a document
or the clicking on the play button of a
video or or submitting a form or signing
up for a newsletter or calling these are
all forms of engagement so
the amount of traffic you drive from
organic search to your website is only
going to improve engagement okay so
you can also provide and improve user
experience and what do we mean by that
well if you're getting lots of traffic
from organic search you have a really
good opportunity to do a b testing and
when you do a b testing you can improve
user experience meaning you're showing
one variation against the other from
people coming from organic search and so
this is helpful
and that you know if you're running an a
b test the variation has a chance to
improve or outperform the original and
if it outperforms the original you're
improving user experience and then it
helps target quality traffic so seo to
me or all search is the only medium in
which you're meeting somebody halfway
you're you're addressing what they're
looking for so somebody's looking for a
pair of red women's nike shoes
the 2019 model and you have that
particular product to offer well you
have a chance of showing up via organic
search somebody types in new women's red
nike shoes size whatever at the year
2019 model then of course they're gonna
probably likely click on your listing
because you have what they're looking
for and and that goes with any keyword
any industry any business any segment
any type of
product you're selling so
again you have a chance to really be
visible for what people are looking for
and so that's the beauty of search
engine optimization you have a really
good opportunity here to meet people
halfway to drive quality traffic to get
them to enjoy a good user experience all
the while generating engagement and
along with seo we want to be able to
build backlinks so
seo is a two-pronged approach meaning
you have two strategies in one on-page
and off page and so
off-page involves backlinking so
backlinks are just links that direct
users from
other websites to your own website so
with that inherently it's going to drive
traffic qualified traffic to your
website because if somebody's on a
relevant website that's linking to yours
and they click on that link and go to
your website it's likely going to be
qualified meaning they're going to be
relevant and so
backlinking because it's an off-page
strategy why is it an off-page ses
strategy because if google crawls that
other site that has a link to you
then that's going to give you credit
because google say hey this site's
getting some links from some relevant
sites we must think they're relevant and
therefore
we're going to trust this site so
by google
trusting your site it's going to improve
your organic ranking and with the
organic rankings being improved meaning
it's going to mean faster indexing so
what does that mean so you want to be
indexed by the search engines and so the
quicker google can find your pages even
if it's on somebody else's site then
that means they're gonna follow that
link go to that page on your site and
take that page back to their servers to
be indexed okay so the quicker you can
get indexed the quicker you get found
and then it helps with referral traffic
so
again we noticed that our efforts are on
seo organic search but if you're getting
traffic from another website hey that
still counts that's referral traffic
okay so that's a side advantage to
having backlinks is good traffic from
other sites okay so those those are
inherently the some of the reasons to do
backlinking okay never hurts i mean
there's brand awareness reasons to being
on other sites as well there's industry
leadership meaning if you you post
content on reddit okay you're coming
across as an industry leader but yet
generating a backlink which helps with
seo and referral traffic so there's a
lot of benefits to building backlinks
and the opposite of backlinks are
internal links so
you want to do internal linking and that
just means connecting one page on your
site to another and why is that
beneficial because it can help direct
visitors to other pages they wouldn't
normally otherwise find via your
navigation so if you're active on a blog
don't be afraid to include multiple
internal links you want to move people
through your site you want the flow of
traffic to go from one page to another
to another and so when you do internal
linking just like with backlinks it's
going to improve the indexing of your
website google is going to follow those
links and index those pages and google
does give credits from an seo
perspective from an internal linking
perspective so if one page is linked to
another and that page has really good
relevance in the eyes of google then the
other page is probably going to benefit
from that the other reason we want to do
internal linking again you want to move
people from your one page of your site
to the other and when you do that it's
going to reduce bounce rates so bounce
rate is simply the rate at which people
land on a page and then leave so if i
have 100 people land on my homepage and
only one person went to another page and
the other 99 left the site then that's a
99 bounce rate so by putting internal
links in place you're helping people
move from one page to the other and thus
reducing the bounce rate and that's what
you want you want to keep people on your
site you want to be greedy it also
drives traffic to older posts so again
when we say older posts we're really
referring to blog posts so if you have a
relevant blog post and you're writing a
new blog post then link the two together
if it's relevant link it i don't you
know regardless of how old it is you
know you want to show google that these
older blog posts just because they were
written a year ago doesn't mean they're
outdated and old-fashioned okay or
useless you want to keep them alive by
linking to them so to me that's a good
strategy for internal linking link to
older blog posts you know show people
you're an industry expert you've been
doing this for a while and then you have
lots of content to share okay so the
longer you can keep somebody on your
website the more likely it is they're
going to engage and convert and some
other inherent benefits improves page
rank so what we mean by pagerank is
simply just a rank that google gives
pages so the more internal linking you
have the better off you are and then it
helps spread link juice across websites
and we'll maybe buy link juice again
just like backlinking it builds
relevancy so
just keep all these inherent benefits in
mind to internal linking the end result
is keeping the flow of traffic on your
site and all these other benefits will
fall into place okay so another way in
which you can really hone in on traffic
to your website is long tail keywords
and long tail keywords to me are more
than just one or two keyword phrases
okay so they're usually three or longer
keywords in a phrase okay so long tail
keywords really nowadays account for
most web searches people
really take the time to even post
questions as a search query say likely
somebody it's unlikely somebody's going
to go into search and just type in the
word shoes they might type in red shoes
but that's unlikely what they're
probably going to type in is you know
red
nike running shoes 2019
or some variation of that okay that's a
long tail keyword and some of the
advantages of using long tail keywords
to be found for are less competition so
if you're using broad keywords like red
shoes then who doesn't want to be found
for red shoes well you don't necessarily
you don't want to be found for red shoes
because it's too broad you don't know
what type of shoes somebody's looking
for you just know they're looking for
red shoes it could be running shoes it
could be work shoes it could be you know
boots it could be
slippers okay it's too broad so long
tail keywords help narrow it in and the
more narrow and focused the keyword is
the less competition it's gonna have and
when something's not competitive in the
form of a keyword then that means your
chances of ranking for that keyword are
going to be greater and the chance of
you ranking faster are going to be
greater and then of course if somebody's
looking for exactly what you have to
offer then you have a higher chance to
convert that person so if you have
exactly those 2019
red nike women's running shoes and
somebody does a search for that and
that's a long tail keyword and they
click on your organic listing if you
have the right price then they're
probably going to convert so you have a
really good chance of converting
somebody using long tail keywords so my
point here is if you're looking for
keywords to use focus on longer tail
don't focus on one or two keyword
phrases what it also does is it brings
targeted traffic so even if somebody
doesn't convert hey they could be back
because it's exactly what they're
looking for and if you're focusing on
longer tail keywords like i just
mentioned stay away from the shorter
ones it's just easier to optimize your
page for seo so remember seo is a
two-pronged approach on page and off
page we talked about off page with
internal linking and backlinks on page
is all about making sure those keywords
you choose are integrated in with the
page you want to be found for and so if
you're using a long tail keyword it's
just easier to work that keyword in so
it enables easier on-page optimization
okay let's switch away from seo to email
marketing so let's focus on email
marketing as a form or method of driving
traffic to your website so email
marketing has been around a long time in
terms of digital marketing why because
it provides an effective way to convert
leads into sales why because you can
send personalized emails to a target
audience so when you send an email to
somebody on a regular basis
you know who that person is so what are
you doing in the email you're writing a
specific message to that person well
email marketing is the same thing except
you're just sending an email to a larger
group of people and when you send an
email to a larger group of people you're
still going to personalize the message
right you're not going to send a generic
email to 1 000 people okay nobody's
gonna do that so make sure your email is
targeted if it's targeted it can be cost
effective why because sending large
amounts of emails or let's just say an
email to a large amount of people or a
large group of people is going to be
cost effective it's not cost per click
you know it's not cost per open
okay so email usually depending on the
the email provider you're using really
is a flat fee so just really depends on
how many emails you're sending or how
how many people you're sending the email
to as well so but email generally tends
to be more cost effective than other
forms of marketing so look at the email
content provider you're using and just
get a sense of what they charge but if
you look at it and do a comparison email
generally is cheaper than say doing
pay-per-click because with pay-per-click
you're paying for each click okay so
that could be expensive depending on the
keywords so email marketing is also time
saving okay meaning it's a one-time
thing and done so once you send the
email it's just a matter of you know
watching and looking at the metrics and
learning what's going on so you don't
make the same mistakes again but it is
time conducive meaning you send out one
email and that's it with pay-per-click
you're constantly measuring and managing
the campaigns and it provides real-time
marketing so when you do send the email
more than likely a majority of the
people
on day one or the day you send the email
are going to be able to view it open it
click on some of the links and convert
so
that's normally what happens an email
majority of the people open it on day
one and it kind of tells off from there
so think about it as real time so when
you send that email and if you have a
thousand people on your email recipient
list break it up send the first 500
first with a different subject line and
then you can see the data come in and if
you don't see the good results from the
subject line or the body of the email or
you know the page you're going to then
make adjustments before you send the
other email to the next 500. so that's a
great thing about emails you can break
up the email into two groups the first
group and then the second group with
different subject lines and you can
probably send them a little bit of time
apart that way you can learn from the
first email because with email
you are generally going to get results
right away okay within the first 24
hours so that's a great thing about
email okay so the other thing about
email it's less intrusive so normally
people who are going to get the email
are the ones who sign up for the email
so they're almost expecting your email
so when they get your email again as
long as you're not sending an email on a
daily basis normally most companies send
it monthly or bi-weekly it's not going
to be as intrusive okay and then it also
helps build credibility increased
visibility and brand awareness meaning
you're going to build your brand in that
email you're going to put content in
that email that's going to show off your
credibility meaning you could put some
testimonials in the email you could put
some good affiliations you can put a
good article to an industry article you
just wrote so email is going to
inherently continue to build brand
awareness for you okay and it's an easy
way to track roi so if your e-commerce
it's pretty clear you send the email
somebody opens it clicks on it checks
out and purchases something it's easily
trackable because you could track it
right from that email so one thing i
want to say there is just if you do send
an email make sure you're tracking that
campaign and you want to be able to use
an analytics program like google
analytics if you use google analytics
you're going to be able to track when
you send the email who clicks on it and
who converts so you want to be able to
measure an roi for these emails and you
can and that's the beauty of email
marketing okay let's move away from
email marketing to webinars so webinars
great method for effective social media
promotion it's a great way to bring
traffic to your website so why do we
recommend webinars well because it
provides direct content contact within
your target group what do we mean by
contact with your target group well
you're going to host a webinar and
you're going to invite this targeted
group of people who are interested in
your product or service so if you have a
facebook community you can do a facebook
live event or you could do a youtube or
you know you can even set up a webinar
on another platform but promote it on
social media and if you're pronouncing
something on social media you're
probably promoting it to people who are
already following you or like you and so
that's what we mean by direct contact
with your target group so you're going
to be able to create a webinar and talk
directly to that group and that's going
to help build brand awareness and
credibility and the great thing about
webinars is you don't need some fancy
software i mean i'm talking to you on a
webinar right now and so webinars are
free all you need is a video camera and
a recorder that's all and that's all
built in with software so there's plenty
of software out there that allows you
just to do a webinar really quick and
easy there's lots of opportunities in
software so and a lot of them are very
cost effective so if you want to build
uh create a webinar you can do that by
spending very little money and webinars
again allow you to talk to your targeted
group your community maybe prospective
clients it helps build credibility and
in effect drive traffic to your website
and when somebody does attend a webinar
they're likely going to be highly
engaged because you're inviting them
they're going to opt into the webinar
and the great thing about webinars is
even if they don't attend the webinar
the day you have it it's going to be
recorded so they can always go back and
watch it so whoever watches the webinar
is going to be engaged because it's
going to be a topic they're interested
in and then users are likely to become
prospective customers so having a
webinar talking about something
inherently interesting to maybe a larger
group of people you can promote that on
social media and potentially get
prospective customers to
sign up and watch the webinar and if you
do they're going to be engaged and then
take the next step oh i like what this
guy this person has to say they seem to
be credible i like their personality i
like their brand i like their product
i'm gonna go check their web out their
website okay so webinars allow you to
kind of pull in more people as well as
just your community because you can
promote the webinar and you can promote
it in advance and you can leverage
social media for that okay so something
related to webinars incorporating video
content so videos have been proven to be
a really good way to attract new
visitors and it just it makes your
website very engaging when you have
videos on your website as well so if you
create video you have an opportunity to
post it on various video platforms like
youtube or vimeo okay there's plenty of
video platforms out there or just
embedded in a blog post or embedded in a
facebook post or a tweet okay so you can
do a lot with video and having video on
your site is going to increase
engagement okay when you increase
engagement good things happen that's
going to lead to increased conversions
and sales or
roi or just like we mentioned the
webinar can help build trust with your
audience even that webinar you could
post on your website so you want people
to engage by watching this video they
watch the video they're going to gain
trust in you because you're talking
directly to that person that user that
audience that visitor to your website
and when you get bail trust it's going
to increase engagement and that's the
beauty of video unlike text or imagery
videos really do engage with the
audience and so the more video you could
do the better off you are because again
you can leverage social to draw
attention to your brand and product and
service and then you can have that video
on your website to increase engagement
which in turn increases conversions and
sales and improves roi so always think
video there's plenty of video software
out there that you can leverage and the
great thing about video 2 is hey most
people are using mobile phones these
days smartphones and so video works just
as well on mobile as it does on desktop
so keep that in mind you know video is
going to be engaging regardless of what
device somebody uses and then of course
if they're watching the video on
facebook or youtube then chances are
they're going to
share
that particular video which is going to
bode well for your brand and traffic
okay so video if somebody likes a video
it's very easy to share video especially
from a mobile phone so youtube just
makes it so easy to share or like or
subscribe to a channel it just it
becomes that much easier things can go
viral and chances of them going viral
video are going to be greater okay so
other ways to drive traffic to your
website is submit your content to
content aggregators so what's a content
aggregator well content aggregators like
reddit that provides a great platform
for you to post your content so that's
what a content aggregator is really a
site like reddit or medium or quora
where you can post content to a large
number of people okay so with reddit
people are either going to upvote it or
downvote it so the more upvotes you get
or thumbs up or likes or people who
encourage that content the more of a
chance it has to be found and so first
thing out of the gate if you do provide
content to a content aggregator like
reddit make sure it's good quality
content that's interesting and that
should be a case the case around across
the board whether it's a social post or
blog post make sure the contents unique
professional and interesting and then if
you do say put something on medium or
you do put something on cora and it is
professional and interesting and
thought-provoking then people are going
to react to it and then that again could
lead to traffic but even if it doesn't
lead to traffic it helps build brand
awareness so if you have content just
like videos leverage it put the content
out there okay and when you put content
out there it's only gonna especially if
it's good content put it's gonna put you
in a good light so don't be afraid to
share your content on the likes of
reddit or medium or core or some of
these other content aggregator websites
because good things are only gonna
happen and again referral traffic seo
brand awareness conversions so all these
are inherent benefits of just sharing
your content okay and then finally we
want to learn from analytics okay so
what do i mean learning from analytics
so there are plenty of analytics
platforms out there one of the most
popular is google analytics so you want
to make sure you're tracking traffic on
your site with google analytics so i
have to do is just go to google
analytics via search
sign up add the analytics code to your
website and voila they're doing all the
heavy lifting they're going to track
traffic coming your website and not only
they're going to track traffic but
they're going to tell you how that
traffic engaged and so the benefits of
it google analytics is hey you could
figure out where users are coming from
are they coming from that email campaign
that i sent out to a thousand people are
they coming from youtube based on that
video i posted or are they coming from
reddit based on the content i just
posted there or are they coming from
organic search it is so google analytics
can help us understand how much traffic
we're getting from organic search so to
help us measure our seo efforts and then
with google analytics you could segment
so we could segment by mobile we can
segment by desktop returning user new
user by campaign by page by language by
city by region i mean there's so many
ways in which to segment your audience
and segmenting simply is breaking up the
entire group of people who come to your
website into different segments based on
what you want to see so
if you want to look at you know females
between the ages of 18 to 24 who come
from mobile via organic search that's a
segment and you can look at that
information and analytics if that's your
target audience then you can see how
they're performing okay so and there are
a lot of benefits to google analytics
definitely want to take advantage of
segmenting in google analytics you could
look at your competition so there's a
benchmarking report the great thing
about google analytics you can also look
at content and how your content is
performing when somebody lands on your
website are they what page are they
spending time on what page are they
engaging on the most okay what pages
have the highest bounce rate or the
lowest time on page so you can really
determine what pages work best and then
of course the end result in analyzing
all this data
is you want to be able to fine-tune your
website so take advantage of the data
that google analytics or any other
analytics platform is giving you by
learning once you learn what's going on
with your website you can make
adjustments to your website to improve
user experience okay so we went over a
lot of different ways to drive traffic
we're gonna talk about seo tools let's
get started so if you're doing seo and
you're doing on-page and off-page seo
for an organization or website you're
going to need some tools to help you so
you can't go at it alone you can't do
anything manually you have to lean on
tools to help you work more efficiently
help you gain an advantage and so if
you're doing seo you're going to need
tools for keyword research you're going
to need tools to help you with the
technical aspects related to seo you're
going to have to use some tools for
off-page seo including backlink
monitoring and analysis and then there's
tools for helping you track where your
keywords and pages rank so there's tools
for every element of seo and today we're
going to take a look at some of the best
tools out there on the market to help
you do your job better so let's start
with the keyword research so with
keyword research tools you can do your
job a lot more efficiently finding the
right relevant keywords i mean that's
really key to seo is finding keywords
that are relevant to your business
product or service that you want to rank
for so you want to be able to choose
keywords with high search volume and low
competition so where do you get those
numbers you get those from certain tools
you also want to get forecasts for
certain targeted keywords you want to be
able to generate a list of latent
semantic index and type keywords your
keywords close to the keyword you're
trying to target you want to be able to
select primary and secondary keywords
wisely so having a list of keywords or
certain data points will help you do
that and you want to be able to identify
the keywords that your competitors are
also ranking for so good keyword
research tool will help you do all of
those things so what are some of the
tools out there well look no further
than some of the free ones that google
offers like google trends so google
trends is a good tool that you can lean
on if so if we look at google trends all
you need to do is
trends.google.com you could type in a
keyword i can look at the volume or
interest of that keyword over time here
i'm looking at football versus american
football and i could see how it's
trending then i could see you know how
it trends in specific regions of say the
united states as my market i can also
look at other related queries similar to
football or american football and so
google trends is a good tool helps you
look at the volume helps you look at
what specific regions help you look at
other keywords you know if you want you
could simply just do a keyword search or
you can actually just see what's
trending just by looking at the latest
stories and insights so we could see
international women's day you know
started to pick up steam it's picking up
more steam etc so it's certain keywords
that tend to trend well and you can pick
up on what those keywords are using
google trends now you could also use
another google tool called google
keyword planner the only difference is
this one's paid you need a google ads
account so if we go into google ads hey
you'll need to go to tools and you'll
need a keyword planner but when you're
in keyword planner you can find new
keywords so if i type in for example you
know online marketing and click get
started what the keyword tool is going
to do is give me the data that i need to
do appropriate keyword research it's
going to give me my keyword and similar
keywords it's going to give me the
average monthly volume and the great
thing here is i can actually see the
trend for that keyword over time just by
clicking on this little bar graph so for
digital marketing i could see what the
trend is over time i could see what the
competition is i could see you know if
i'm going to bid on this keyword i could
see what the bidding range is so more
important i can see the volume and i can
see the competition here's my volume for
this keyword over the last 12 months on
average and here's my competition so
google's keyword planner gives you the
necessary information you need to choose
relevant keywords wisely now there are
other tools out there that are paid that
help you look for relevant keywords like
sem rush or keyword finder that's a
freemium tool so there are plenty of
tools available to you you know another
tool i use that's not listed here is moz
so if you just type a keyword let's just
type in the same keyword like online
marketing for example okay so what moz
is going to do is going to give me some
volume it's going to give me some other
keyword suggestions okay it's going to
tell me how difficult that keyword is
and it's going to tell me who else is
ranking for that keyword so it gives me
again all the relative information i
need including competitive information
so you can use these two these keyword
tools moz is freemium some are paid some
are free there's plenty of tools out
there but these are the ones i would
recommend for keyword research now let's
turn our attention to technical seo so
for technical seo you're going to need
to use some tools there's no getting
around that because you want to be able
to monitor how your website is
performing i mean is it loading slow for
example does it have a lot of
issues with the website in terms of
server-side rendering for example or
server response time what about
four-fours and redirects so you want to
be able to gather a lot of the technical
information that could aid or prohibit
your site from ranking so you want to be
able to also you know look at what the
bots are saying and how they're viewing
your website so if google goes to crawl
your site are they experiencing you know
a slow server response time where they
experiencing pages not found you also
want to see if you have a site map you
know what's the site map are these bots
crawling your site or getting the pages
from a sitemap again you want to be able
to lean on some of these tools to help
you fix errors that you may encounter
like meta tags or four or fours or
canonicals so you need a good tool to
help you manage all that and so i'm
gonna go back to maz starting out so if
we go back to maz maz is a good tool
it's an all-in-one it's a great seo
platform so if i go to moz and i log
into an account i can just go to
sitecrawl and so what moz is going to do
it's going to give me a lot of
information about how moz's bot is
seeing my site okay so if i go to the
site crawl i can look at all the
particular critical uh issues that have
experienced so i could see four or four
errors okay reiterates related to that i
could see meta descriptions missing meta
descriptions duplicate content so
there's a lot of different issues that
moz is detecting for this particular
site and the great thing about moz and
this is why i use moz is my seo platform
i don't work for moz i've just used them
a long time is if you do have issues
then they give you ways to fix it the
how to fix it section so if i see
missing description here if i just click
on review and get a more in-depth
analysis as to what the issues are here
but i can also click on the why and how
to fix okay and they're going to give
you some information about how this is
impacting seo and what you could do to
fix the issue they lay out the issues
pretty prominently here you can see for
all the metadata issues i have i have
you know 142
total metadata issues i have 10 title
tag two longs i have 122 missing meta
descriptions so they lay it out nicely
here up the top so you can kind of get a
sense of what to work on and again they
prioritize it based on the severity of
the issue and then they break it down
into several categories for example i
just looked at metadata issues you can
see if i click on content issues i have
some duplicate content that moz is
recognizing or missing or valid h tags
so maz does a really really great job
laying on all the issues out for you to
recognize okay there's another tool that
i like to use called screaming frog it's
a pay tool so if we go look here great
thing i like about a screaming frog it
will crawl your sight and it will give
you some list of issues just like moz
does of you know what it sees in your
sight is it experiencing four or fours
broken links are there any redirects
it's picking up duplicate content site
maps you know they're javascript issues
how is it see the site architecture so
it really does take a deep look at
everything that could impact your
website from ranking okay there are
other tools out there like you know deep
crawl or woo rank they're both paid and
so pay tools are really great as well it
just depends on you know your pricing
structure what your budget is but really
when it comes to all these tools they
all more or less overlap and do the same
thing you just need to rely on one of
them to make sure that you're able to
see what the issues are now there's
nothing wrong with using two of them
just as a second reference point to see
if both are picking up the same issue
and of course i like to use search
console i always like to lean on google
search console because that is the
source so search console will also you
know give you some feedback on how
google's bot is crawling your site so
that's under the crawl error section
here so you can also you know use search
console to upload a sitemap so that's a
key to seo you want google to be able to
find your web pages quickly so you can
simply just uh signify to google where
your sitemap is located so the search
console does a lot more gives you some
html improvements gives you some
backlinking uh and then the process of
updating this search console user
interface so there's a new user
interface that you can use with google
search console the great thing is it's
free and it has everything you need to
know about your website and how it's
affected by seo organic search the only
thing you have to do with search console
is verify the site but once you verify
it it has all the relevant information
you need so let's talk about backlink
monitoring and analysis okay so this is
related to off-page seo so you're going
to need a good tool to help you monitor
your website backlinks and backlinks are
simply just links from external sites
pointing to your site and you need to
keep an eye on what sites are linking to
yours are they spammy related sites are
they good or relevant sites or anything
in between so you need to really be able
to analyze what the good links are and
what the bad links are pointing to your
website and you can also you know given
the tool also perform some competitor
analysis so you should be able to use a
tool to be able to compare how your
site's ranking against your competitor
okay you want to measure the ratio
referring domains to backlinks so how
many pure domains are linking to your
site so you want a tool that's going to
be able to tell you that you want to
identify and disavow poor backlinks okay
so you want to be able to recognize
which sites are linking to yours that's
actually hurting you from an seo
standpoint and you want to be able to do
something about that okay you want to
measure citation flow and trust flow you
want to check the ratio of link
distribution in terms of is it internal
or external or you know what kind of
sites are linking to my site are they
you know social related are they pure
content related and then you want to be
able to track the number of do follow
and no follow links you know how many
links pointing to our site are actually
telling google and other bots not to
follow the link or how many are actually
allowing the bots to follow that link if
a bot follows a link it's going to pass
what we call link juice so you're going
to get credit for the backlink if it's a
no follower you're not going to get
credit for the backlink and we want to
be able to measure that and so we want
to have tools that will help us do that
so what are some of those tools well
hrefs is a good tool it's a pain tool
majestic is a freemium tool moz again
moz is the tool i use scm rush and then
again i gotta mention google search
console so let's take a look at some of
these tools in terms of backlink
monitoring and analysis so let's start
with google search console again it's
free you just have to verify your site
and so if i go to google search console
i can look at links and i can see what
external links i have pointing to my
site okay so i could see i have 17 000
in this example pointing to the homepage
of this particular site okay so if i
click on that i can see all the the top
sites pointing to my home page now from
an off page seo perspective do you want
every backlink or external link pointing
to your home page no so you want links
pointing to internal pages so you want
to be able to measure that so i could
see what the top linking sites are and i
can also see what the anchor text is so
do i want my anchor text always to be my
brand name no i want it to be you know
keyword we're trying to target search
console also gives you some internal
links okay one of the top link pages for
internal links so from an seo
perspective you always want to have a
nice balance of internal linking so this
report helps you understand what pages
are getting links and are the links
evenly spread so this is google search
console this is the links report this is
totally free this is provided by google
all you have to do is verify your site
now if we go over to moz we type in a
domain any domain so i just typed in
simply learn okay moz has some metrics
that are important to off page seo
including domain authority so the higher
your domain authority the better off you
are and so what helps a domain authority
grow is how many quality links are
pointing to that domain and so here we
could see over 7
500 linking domains to simply learn so
what's important is we just don't want
any site we want quality relevant sites
pointing okay so we could see how many
total inbound links and then how many
ranking keywords we have okay so here
moz is going to give me kind of an idea
of what my domain authority has been
over time they're going to tell me the
top followed links to this site so they
can tell me you know what are those
links pointing to my site and what's the
page authority of those sites okay here
i can get a nice graphical breakdown of
the linking domains by domain authority
so you want pages with high domain
authority pointing to your site so here
i could see 69 linking domains between
91 and 100 so that's really good we want
high relevant domains linking to our
site so just like search console i could
see the top anchor text being used okay
and i can see the top pages that have
you know good page authority on the site
i could see following versus nofollow on
internal and external links so this is
just the overview so moz really really
does break down for you you know what
those pages and linking domains are so
if i just click on linking domains now i
could get a detailed look for my home
page what domains are pointing to our
domain so i can see microsoft.com has a
domain authority of 100. youtube 99. and
so not only does moz provide you with
the domains it also provides you with
your domain authority score and spam
score so you want to keep an eye on any
particular site that has a high spam
score so having a site with a high spam
score and a low domain authority will
hurt your domain and page authority for
that page so moz does a great job of
breaking it out and this is for any page
it doesn't necessarily have to be the
home page okay if i take a look look at
another example here majestic so
majestic again i can use a free version
of the tool they have their own metrics
citation flow trust flow so when they
say trust flow what's the link quality
all about okay citation flow what's the
link volume and they can get an idea of
how many external backlinks are pointing
to the site and what's the trend on that
referring domains so majestic does a
really good job again some of the same
metrics that we could see here except
they go into detail about languages as
well so this is majestic and you got
search console you got a lot of other
tools and then i'm going to just revert
back to moz because you want to be able
to compare link profiles if you're in a
competitive space and you're doing
off-page seo you know moz will help you
compare how your site stands against
maybe another competitive side or
relevant site so just doing this
analysis i can compare my domain
authority spam score how many total
links you know how many external follow
links or external no follow links a
breakdown of linking domains so it does
a nice job of comparing one site versus
another that's going back to moz and
that's what you want you want a good
tool that's going to help you do that i
mean there's other tools out there not
listed like bright edge that will also
help you compare linking profiles so at
the end of the day if you're doing
off-page seo you want to get a sense of
what sites are linking to yours are they
quality sites are they spammy what
anchor texts are they using are they no
follow are they do follow you know are
they top domains how do you compare
against your competitors i mean all
these metrics are related to off-page
seo so you want a good tool that's going
to help you measure this okay so let's
talk about rank tracking so when we do
keyword research we're looking for
relevant keywords we find our relevant
keywords we assign primary and secondary
keywords to pages we optimize those
pages we do off-page seo we're doing all
this work for seo okay we want to be
able to measure the fruits of our labor
we want to be able to measure how we
perform for on and off page seo for the
keywords we cover in the pages they're
related to and so that's where rank
tracking comes into play so we want to
be able to track our website's ranking
and not just our website all the pages
we've optimized we want to be able to
measure our click-through rates and
impressions we want to be able to track
the ranking for both desktop and mobile
for specific locations and we want to
identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords so in other words we
want to look at trends is the keyword
ranking is it going up and ranking is it
going down in rank and if it's going
down in ranking then you need to take
action so you need a tool a good tool
for rank tracking so we can look no
further than again google search console
it's free it's right from the source so
let's take a look at what google search
console has to offer in terms of rank
tracking so if i go to google search
console and i put in a url what it's
going to do is it's going to give me and
this is the search queries report it's
going to give me what queries people
have used to actually type into
google.com and it's going to be able to
tell me how many times my pages show
pages showed up for that query it could
be more than one page that's an
impression and if i did receive an
impression meaning did my page show up
in the organic listing then did i get a
click as a result and so in this case if
i got 68 impressions and 10 clicks for
keywords somebody typed in that's a 14.7
percent click-through rate and so what
search console will also do is say hey
look for that particular keyword you
appeared on average in position 4.1 so
it gives you really
good insight as to you know what people
are typing in and how you're being found
for those keywords it breaks it down by
pages it breaks it down by country
breaks it down by device so i could see
you know mobile i've had
899 impressions over the last three
months on mobile and i received 33
clicks as a result my average position
on mobile was 2.6 so search console does
a really good job again this is free
information uh providing you the actual
keyword somebody's using on google
search as a query and how many
impressions you're receiving for that
keyword how many clicks click the rate
and then average position so in theory
the higher you are positioned on google
the more clicks you're going to receive
so if i'm not positioned properly for
keyword let's say say page two then i'm
probably not going to receive as many
clicks as i would like so that's search
console there are other tools out there
like hrefs again does a good job of
tracking amz tracker we look at winter
so there's some good tools out there i'm
just going to show you another one again
i'm going to go back to moz for example
so moz has a tool called so if i go back
into the account so moz has a rankings
tool that you can look at to see where
your keywords are ranking so if you've
already chosen keywords and optimize
pages for those keywords then you want
to be able to load those keywords into
moz and so moz allows you to do that and
so
what moz does they do a crawl once a
week and they'll be able to tell you
where you rank for all your keywords are
we moving up in the rankings are we
moving down how many keywords do we have
rank between positions 1 and 3 11
through 20 4 through 10 21 through 50.
so we'll be able to see where our
keywords rank and so it gives you a
breakdown here of nationally in the
united states where this keyword is
ranked and if it's moved up or down and
for what url is it ranked for and so you
can label so the keywords and and this
is what you want to look for in a good
tool you want to be able to organize
your keywords and label them so for all
our branded keywords we want to be able
to label them branded because ideally
you don't want to optimize for your
brand keywords so maybe we want to
exclude our brand keywords and look at
our non-brand keywords in terms of
ranking and so you can certainly add
locations and look at specific locations
the whole idea between a good ranking
tool is to be able to measure you know
if a keyword is trending up or down okay
so i can simply look at a particular
keyword and i can see the trend of that
keyword and then you know if a keyword
is not ranking then we want to wonder
why it's not ranking well is it
difficult is it not ranking because of
its difficulty or can we do a better job
of optimizing for that keyword and so
moz also has a page optimization tool so
if you're not ranking for keyword you
can flip over the page optimization tool
then put in the keyword put in the url
and moz will give you some idea as to
what you can further do to optimize the
page okay so that's moz you know this is
hrefs so you can see ahrefs does the
same thing they provide you some
visibility average position how much
traffic you know where you're ranking in
terms of positions one through three
four through 10 11 through 50. and so
you want to be able to get a sense of
where my track keywords are trending are
they training up are they trending down
and the whole idea again beyond ranking
tools if you're trending down you want
to be able to address why it's trending
now so you want to start with on-page
seo can we do a better job of optimizing
or off page does that page need more
backlinks so that's why you need a
backlink tool to support your ranking
and ahrefs does offer up some competitor
information as well so you can see how
your competitors are performing so these
are some good examples of ranking tools
that you can take advantage of now there
are also a few important seo tools that
can be helpful in different ways for
example if you're doing video so there
are some tools to help you measure how
you're performing via video for example
vid iq so let's take a look at vid iq so
if i load in say video and youtube in
this example how to rank youtube videos
i have a vid iq extension loaded into my
browser in chrome and so now i can get a
good eye sense of how many views the
duration the engagement rate the like
ratio how many people shared it on
reddit but further i can look at how the
video was optimized so they're telling
me the title's too long here maybe
shorten it up but we have tags we have
descriptions we have cards we have end
screens it's been shared on facebook it
hasn't been shared on twitter okay it is
public we do have pinned comments and we
do have hearted comments and so this
gives me an idea of how we did in terms
of optimizing this particular video okay
so if we wanted to tweak it we could
tweak the title tag make it a little bit
shorter to help it rank better on
youtube so you want to be able to use a
tool like this because if you have
videos then you want those videos to
rank and so you can certainly watch this
video on how to rank your youtube videos
and in that video we do allude to vid iq
so you want to be able to use a tool
like this because you know youtube it is
a video portal but it's the second
largest search engine behind google so
if you do have videos you want to be
able to rank for them and you want a
tool that's going to help you measure
and help you understand if you are
ranking if you're not ranking why are
you not ranking now for content
optimization there are tools you can use
like seo site checkup or site analyzer
are some good tools if you already have
moz as an example just going back to moz
as you already know i use moz a lot so
they have a page optimization so you
could check the content how your
optimize your content so it's going to
give me some good feedback on you know
is your page title meta description are
they in line okay so it's going to give
you some good feedback on that you also
have again i have to allude to search
console you can always look at a
particular page and search console see
if it has any errors as well so is it
duplicated meta description is it a
duplicated title tag is it any pages
missing title tags your meta
descriptions so when it comes to content
you can look at search console you can
lean on moz or you can lean on some of
these other paid versions like site
analyzer when it comes to traffic and
metrics look no further than google
analytics there is a free version of
google analytics as well as a paid
version so if i go into google analytics
it's going to tell me all of my website
behavior okay who's coming to my site
how they got to my site how they behaved
once they went to my site and are they
achieving the goals i set out for them
to achieve via conversions and so you
want to look at first in google
analytics how much traffic you're
getting so if i go to google analytics
if i go to acquisition all traffic
channels i should be able to see how
much traffic organic search is driving
over a period of time so i could see how
many users how many sessions then if i
click on landing pages i could see what
landing page they went to we're going to
talk about seo tips and tricks so let's
get started and throughout this series
we're going to have a few tips to share
with you and we'll start out with tip
number one opt for smarter ways to do
keyword research
and so
if you listen to any of our seo
tutorials in the past you know that
keyword research is the first step but
the most crucial step in starting seo so
when we do keyword research we want to
be able to
basically find keywords that we feel are
relevant to our business that we want to
be found on search for and so here are a
few tips that can help you do that
research in a more efficient manner the
first thing we want to do is identify a
list of keywords that are relevant so we
only want to focus on relevant keywords
for a business that's a given so what i
would suggest is as a best practice
maybe you know put down some of those
keywords in a spreadsheet so think of
them as a theme of keywords because when
you do research you're going to want to
include a theme of keywords related to
one another so you can pick the best
ones out of that theme and so as an
example
if we have a company that sells dried
figs in a spreadsheet as an example if i
show you a spreadsheet maybe we want to
focus in on just dried fig and maybe we
want to focus on dried fig recipes so go
ahead and put those in a column you know
some of these keywords that you know you
want to be found for so that's really
the first step they need to be relevant
so put them in a spreadsheet so that you
can build keywords around that list then
we want to choose keywords and when we
choose keywords we want to have some
criteria around choosing them and so we
always want to choose keywords with a
lot of volume and what i mean by volume
i mean how many people on average type
in that keyword or a related keyword per
month the second criteria is the key
word of product fit meaning you know is
the keyword relevant you always want to
stay true to relevancy the third is
commercial intent what is the intent of
the keyword is it trying to get us a
sale is it answering a question so what
is the intent of that keyword and then
last it's difficulty so we want to
definitely take a look at how difficult
a keyword is to rank for on organic
search so that's some of the criteria
you may have some additional criteria
that you want to use but this is the
criteria basically for choosing keywords
so again we want to prefer keywords of
high volume you want to be careful of
seasonality so remember seasonality in
this example christmas tree you're only
going to have a spike you know during
the winter or excuse me the october
november december months so be careful
of seasonality when choosing high volume
keywords and again keywords that are
relevant to your product even though it
doesn't have much search volume
relevancy always trumps uh volume or any
other metric commercial intent so we
want to look at keywords that for
example have buy in them they may have
low search volume but if somebody's
typing in that keyword then we can
insinuate that the consumer who typed in
that keyword is ready to make the
purchase so we want to look at what the
intent is of that keyword and then again
the difficulty always opt for keywords
that have low difficulty or competition
and so in order to get these metrics we
can use third party tools i'm going to
show you a couple of examples of
third-party tools you can use that will
give you some of this information so the
first tool i'm going to show you is
google ads keyword planner so if i'm
having a google ads account i could
simply go to tools and then choose the
keyword planner and from there i want to
find new keywords so if i choose the
keyword dried figs because that's the
keyword i put in my spreadsheet that i'm
interested in optimizing for and then
maybe drive fake recipes that was the
other keyword theme
so if i enter those two keywords in just
to begin with basically what google is
going to give me is the average search
monthly volume so here i can see dried
figs i have an average monthly search
volume 8 100. that means on average over
the last 12 months that's how many
people have typed in that keyword here i
can see a little bit of a trend i just
hover my mouse over that graph i could
see again for seasonality impact if
there is any seasonality what the volume
is on average per month then i can see
the competition is high and because this
is google ads because it's paid search
they're going to give me a sense or an
idea of what i should be bidding on that
keyword now that's another topic for
another day but it's good information to
have because if you're not ranking for a
keyword you could decide to bid on it
for paid search so don't discard the
bidding information go ahead and put it
in a spreadsheet for later use but for
now we're focused in on keywords that
are relevant how much volume how much
competition okay so once i get this
information here i can simply go back to
my spreadsheet and put that information
in there what's the volume for dried fig
what is the competition now for
competition notice that google ads gives
us a higher low now if we're trying to
measure
ratio between volume and competition we
want to get an actual sense of what that
competition is so what i always do as a
best practice is go into google search
if i go to google search and i type in
dried figs
i'm going gonna see the actual volume is
34 million five hundred thousand so i
could see that's the actual search
volume for this particular keyword
however if i add a syntax called all in
title before that keyword with the colon
space and then hit enter then i could
see the actual
volume reduces to 31 000 and basically
what this tells me is that 31 000
listings results have the keyword dried
figs in the title tag so if a web page
has dried fig our targeted keyword in
the title tag then ideally we can
insinuate that that page is trying to
rank for that keyword so therefore in
order for us to rank number one on
google we have to jump over 31 000
results so we want to be able to include
this information into our keyword
analysis so if i go into our keyword
analysis here and i
go ahead and enter in that information
so what's my keyword my keyword is dried
figs
okay my volume was 8100 my competition
was 31 000 and so that gives me a ratio
of 81 divided by 31 000 if i make that
into a percentage basically 26
so that's my keyword effectiveness index
or kei or ratio between volume and
competition and so that's an a way that
you can
gather information is by using google
ads enter the information into a
spreadsheet and then sort all your data
by kei you could sort it by volume you
get sorted by competition all these
metrics matter alternatively as another
tool you can use moz so moz has a
keyword explore tool okay so if i type
in the keyword dried figs focusing on
the united states i could see that moz
says hey look there's anywhere between 4
300 and 6 500 in terms of volume out of
100 the difficulty is 41. and so i can
expect a click-through rate of you know
41
and so basically the great thing about
moz's keyword explorer tool is i can
also look at the search analysis search
engine results pages what serp stands
for and i can analyze the serp for a
particular keyword in moz so i want to
be able to understand what my
competition is doing so here i can see
if i really want to try and optimize for
that keyword i could see what the other
pages are ranked for that keyword and
then on page one i can also
see what local results show up for that
keyword so here i can see that we have a
number of different sites listed here so
if we want to be number one these are
the sites that are basically above us
that we need to
climb over to be number one on google so
i find that the keyword explore tool in
moz is very helpful for understanding
your competition as well as getting a
alternative check on volume and
competition or difficulty if you will
and so remember we want to identify a
list of keywords that are relevant i
can't stress that enough we want to
choose keywords based on difficulty we
want to choose keywords based on volume
on commercial intent and more important
relevancy we can also identify trends
from a site search query like amazon and
know what your competitors are ranking
for so we can also go back into moz and
we can see just by typing in some of the
keywords we're focusing on we can see if
our competitors are ranking for the same
keywords just by using that keyword
explorer tool and then another thing we
want to look at is lsi or latent
semantic indexing so that's a fancy word
which basically means we want to find
keywords related to the topic of the
page you're trying to optimize so if
there are other keywords on that page
then you could sway in that direction
and so when it comes to choosing
keywords you want to choose always a
primary and secondary keyword and so if
we go back to our spreadsheet it doesn't
necessarily always have to be just one
keyword it doesn't necessarily have to
be dried figs we could choose another
keyword that has a good volume to
competition ratio so we want to choose
keywords that are always relevant and if
we're analyzing nothing but relevant
keywords then we want to be able to
choose keywords that have a good ratio
between volume and competition so you
always want to choose at least two
keywords per page we can also stay up to
date on industry news as we'll help you
learn new jargon so it doesn't hurt to
subscribe to sites like search engine
watch or search engine land they have
lots of good tips so here i'll show you
what that one of those sites look like
if i simply just go to search engine
watch dot com i find this is a good
resource to stay up on the latest news
when it comes to search engines here we
can see
why seo and front-end developers are the
perfect search marketing team another
article about optimizing your channel
youtube channel five easy steps so
there's a lot of information here on
search engine watch that pertain to seo
and keyword research we could also look
at other third-party sites like
wikipedia reddit and core for example so
if i go to quora i can do a search for
dried figs and i could see
what's being written about that topic so
that should give me some ideas to build
a keyword a list around so for example
the health benefits of dried figs okay
are dry figs safe for diabetes best ways
to eat dry figs so those are all good
keyword themes that we could build a
keyword list around and i did that
simply just by typing in drive figs on
core so that's a a good tip for you to
leverage when you're trying to build out
a keyword list okay let's uh talk about
tip number two which is publish high
quality content to get more traffic to
your website so
it's all about content so we've already
done the keyword research we still need
to
kind of merge the two when we talk about
merging the two it's not just building
content around those keywords it's much
more than that when it comes to seo and
so that's why we always talk about high
quality content so let's talk about some
of the tips that can help you create
high quality content so
first tip is we want to be able to
publish longer and engaging content
longer and engaging content tends to
rank higher in google why because you
have more content to work with and when
you have more content to work with you
can optimize it you can structure it you
can insert different assets like videos
and images and by keeping it long you're
gonna likely keep it engaging and so
google tends to lean in favor of content
that is well organized structured and
long because it is more likely to be
engaging for the end user we definitely
want to include those target keywords so
you want to be able to
you know insert those keywords into
those meta tag descriptions into those
title tags into those alt tags but you
want to work them in naturally you don't
want to force anything content should be
naturally written because if it's
naturally written it's going to be
engaging so we want to use lsi keywords
in the content so lsi or
basically latent semantic indexing
basically just means different terms and
concepts related to your target keywords
so feel free to use terms that are
similar to what you're currently using
these keywords can definitely be used
for seo because they create more
visibility and potentially higher
rankings because it gives you an
opportunity to use keywords that are
natural and work for different
variations and let's look at examples so
if you're optimizing an e-commerce
category page and your keyword is one
mix used for men so we want to use
keywords closely related to one mix used
for men for example running shoes for
men or sport running shoes for men
outdoor sport shoes or air cushion shoes
let's take a look an example of amazon
so if i go to amazon i could see the one
mix used for men page and if i look at
this page i can see a lot of product and
each product has basically some content
associated with it i.e the title of the
particular product and so you want to be
able to
use different descriptors for this
particular product for example men's
running shoes or breathable lightweight
gym sports shoes or lightweight casual
sneakers or walking casual sneaker all
of these are lsi related keywords
they're similar to what we're trying to
optimize for so you don't necessarily
always have to be brand heavy or stick
with one keyword you could definitely
show variation especially on the
e-commerce side if you're dealing with
different products so we want to make
the content readable with the help of
visuals subtitles and bullet points so
if you're e-commerce you want to make
sure that page is laid out properly easy
to read you hear i could see the
descriptor along with the title all kind
of merged together and so there's no
breakout of okay this is the product
name this description it's kind of one
all-in-one which i like it just makes it
more natural sounding okay and you can
see these are all broken out uh pretty
well laid out page and amazon is more or
less you know consistent in terms of how
their pages are laid out so make it
readable add visuals add subtitles add
bullet points it helps break out a lot
of the content especially if you have a
long amount of content or a large amount
of content so the use of subtitles
bullet points and visuals will help
break it out structure it and make it
more engaging for the end user you
definitely want to write an effective
and organized content in order to reduce
the bounce rate so there is correlation
between engagement and bounce rate the
more you structure the more you add
visuals the more you add subtitles the
more engaged somebody's gonna be the
less likely they are to bounce from the
pitch we also want to share customer
reviews and ratings so if you have a web
page you sell products even if you don't
sell products it's always good to have
testimonials or some type of customer
review so if we go back to our example
on amazon and we clicked on a product uh
one of the running shoe products we look
here we can see the image we could see
kind of the description well i may not
be so interested in buying this product
i want to know a little bit more about
it well that's where the breaking point
comes in that's where the decision
factor comes in where if i read other
reviews then i can possibly have my mind
made up to buy this product so here i
could see that not only there are
reviews but there's testimonials so i
could see that here you can see that
there's a lot of stars and you can see
the kind of the review title these
running shoes are very comfortable and
lightweight so you have a lot of
different feedback and so reading custom
reviews is always helpful because even
though you're making the decision it
kind of will help sway you in one
direction or another at least it does
for me so that's the the beauty of a
customer review and a rating we want to
be able to use those to our advantage
and then you want to be able to update
your content on a regular basis so and
that goes for testimonials and reviews
you want to make sure you're always
getting reviews if you're always getting
reviews then that's just adding to the
particular product and so if you're
always updating your content on a
regular basis as well then google's
going to be able to see that and google
likes fresh content okay we also want to
include the benefits of the product so
if you're selling a product any product
you always want to include the benefits
you want to do as much as you can to
make your product engage to the end user
enticing so that they can buy it so in
addition to customer reviews or adding
content about the product you want to
include benefits so if we go back to
amazon here we can see amazon lists a
lot of the benefits or one mix in this
case list a lot of the benefits so here
you can see
all the descriptors about the particular
product it's got rubber sole it's got a
breathable textile lining you get free
high quality socks with every shoe so
these are some of the features and if we
continue to scroll down we could see
some of the details about the fabric
type specifics about the fabric and a
lot of information on this product page
even a sizing chart so a lot of
different features that will help the
end user make the decision so don't hold
back add as much information as you
possibly can as much information as you
have available it doesn't hurt because
in the end what you're trying to do from
a product perspective is sell the
product and you can't really sell it
unless you have information that's going
to convince the user that this product
is what they want to buy so include the
warranty size recommendation return
policy and some offers so it should all
be listed on the page easy for the end
user to see so can't stress it enough
provide as much product information as
possible go back here here it has a
sizing chart what colors are available
again some of the descriptors if i
scroll down here i can see
some more of the benefits you know
waffle rubber outsole soft deodorant
insole
again fabric type it's got all sorts of
information it's got images about the
fabric itself the shoe itself how it's
structured so a lot of information about
this and it even does a comparison and
so there's a lot of information about
this particular product so don't hold
back add as much as you can to convince
the end user so in the case of the one
mix on amazon you know they had a sizing
chart you know they had an faq being
additional information what other
products that customers view from one
mix and then testimonials so these are
some of the basic bits of information
you want to add on your page if you
don't have customer reviews it's okay
add faq in its place again the end
result is to convince the customer to
purchase the product and then build a
comprehensive internal linking structure
of web pages so every product page
should link to similar products so if i
go back here here i can see other
products from one mix so you should
always have a linking structure so that
if the end user doesn't want to
particularly buy that particular product
then you have links available so they
can go to another page and then add
different varieties and related short
videos of the product so we go back to
our product page you know they have
different varieties that they're
showcasing here they have the size chart
they even have a size convertible chart
so if you're dealing with metrics you
can go over to u.s metrics feet vice
versa you can add a video you know show
a video of if you're selling running
shoes throw a video somebody working out
you know it doesn't have to be a
full-blown commercial per se but it
could be a short 30 second video of what
the shoe looks like on somebody else's
feet so that they could see somebody
walking with those shoes on so video
doesn't have to be a big production you
can do it right from your phone so
review your content before you publish
this goes without saying you want to do
that just you make sure you include
everything possible because when the
content does get published remember
google is going to index that content
when they index it it's going to show up
in the search results so we want to make
sure we have all the information readily
available not only for the end user but
for google as well we want to be able to
analyze our meta tags in url to improve
click-through rates so this is important
because the meta tags i.e the title tag
in the meta description and the urls
what shows up in google search results
so we have title tags but first that's
the first important element that's what
shows up in the search results so what
we want to do is we want to optimize the
title tag and when we optimize it we
want to use modifiers and when i say
modifiers i mean you know feel free to
use the word best or cash back or free
shipping or discount so for example if
you're selling running shoes 25 best
sneakers or up to 70 off or free
shipping or buy shoes on discount very
action oriented but you know it includes
these modifiers that are going to help
somebody click on that link so
some tips for optimizing the title tag
in addition to modifiers we want to
watch the title length and we want to
include those target keywords in the
title tag so remember you're likely
gonna have two keywords to work with you
wanna have at least one of those
keywords in your title tag so with the
modifier you know up to 60 to 65
characters in length with that targeted
keyword should get you a good title tag
that's going to get somebody to click on
it so let's look at an example so if i
type in the keyword best recipes for
dried figs you know here i can scroll
down here's my title tag stands out my
url is right underneath that and
underneath the url are is the meta
description and so here i can see some
modifiers 188 best autumn dried fake
recipes or 25 fantastic fig recipes or
10 best cooking dried fig recipes so
these are all modifiers are going to
help somebody get the click get them to
click on your link and go to your
website so when you don't hit the 65
character lemonade if you go over that
google's going to cut off the title text
so we want to avoid that at all possible
so the whole idea is you know like 10
best cooking dried fake recipes by emily
that's a good enticing title tag okay
takes into account a modifier includes
the targeted keyword and is under the 65
character count some additional tips for
writing meta description we always want
to provide a unique description for each
web page of the website so no duplicate
meta tag descriptions every page use
needs to be unique then we also want to
be specific about what we're offering so
if you have say you're selling
headphones and you have a particular set
of headphones from a different specific
brand include that in the meta
description if you have that particular
product from that brand on sale include
that in the meta description so you want
to be as specific as possible the whole
idea behind a meta description is to
describe the page but also to get the
end user to click on your link so here's
an example of using modifiers and
describing a page if we look at amazon
again we can see this example here and
if we look at it on google search
results so if i type in amazon bluetooth
headsets 10 are on sale here we can see
a lot of amazon listings in google
search here you can see the use of
modifiers in the title tag and also in
the meta description here we could see
that you know this particular headset
bluetooth headset is on sale 50 off so
if something's on sale feel free to
include it be descriptive about the page
let people know where they're going and
use those modifiers don't be afraid to
use numbers in the meta description even
if it's the price itself even if it's
not on sale but it is the price included
it's not going to hurt the more
information you can include in a meta
description the better chance you have
of somebody clicking on that link use
numbers symbols you know percentages off
always help use catchy words like
discount or cashback you're competing
with other listings on the page so if
you have something on sale if it's on
clearance list that it's on clearance
here i can see they even included the
coupon code so feel free to list as much
specific information about that page as
possible the whole idea is you're
competing with your own web pages but in
other cases with competitors so the meta
description along with the title tag and
the url helps separate out you from the
rest of the listings on search engine
results and we don't want to keyword
stuff we want to keep it within 160
something characters or 160 65
characters because google will break off
the meta description just like they do
with the title tag and so we want clean
natural written meta descriptions that
separate you from the competition so
that means including the keywords we're
making sure those keywords are naturally
included in the meta description so if i
go back
again to valleyfig.com and i could see
the meta description hey welcome to the
best resource online for dried fake
recipes savory sweet snacks are healthy
dried food recipes we've got it all okay
start cooking with figs and so it's
natural sounding it does include the
keyword it's not keyword stuffing it's
natural sounding that's hopefully going
to get that person to click on this
particular website let's turn our
attention to
the url so we want to make sure that the
url
is basically taken into account best
practices so if we take a look at this
particular url here it doesn't
necessarily look as attractive as we
would like so
first of all i don't understand some of
it so that makes it unpleasant boring
and messy to say the least so you want
urls that you know basically are clean
and understandable so in other words we
want to make them seo friendly because
if they're seo friendly somebody
understands the url
then they're likely going to click on it
so the old rule of thumb is if you can
read the url then the search engines can
read the url so here are some tips for
creating friendly urls for seo make it
readable you want to include the target
keyword in the url so if it's dried figs
the url should include dried figs if
it's dried fig recipes make sure it's
dried fig recipes now avoid using too
many subdirectories in the urls so we
want to keep it as close as possible to
the root directory and match the urls to
titles most of the time so let's go back
to our example here here we can see this
is valleyfig.com recipes not necessarily
dried fig recipes but recipes
nonetheless it's in the root directory
okay so at all cost now this is in some
cases unavoidable given that you may be
dealing with an e-commerce website
that's calling you know content from a
database so if that is the case you're
going to have some dynamic parameters in
the url which is fine just make sure you
avoid having too many of those dynamic
parameters it's understandable that
parameters but the role of dumb
generally is no more than two different
parameters in the url so prefer to
create short urls that's really the way
to go the shorter the better is the rule
of thumb and you know if you're going to
break up the url then use hyphens
instead of underscores it's just cleaner
it's a more understandable search
engines tend to read it a little bit
easier if it's hyphen so here's what a
friendly url looks like for
search you got your domain you got a
subcategory broken up with a hyphen and
then the product so that's just a clean
url for a particular ecommerce site that
has categories and subcategories so
again we got amazon.com your category
can be electronics your subcategory
could be earphones and your product
could be both earphones it's that simple
let's start with talking about rich
snippets this is tip number four so we
want to add rich snippets to improve
your website's visibility on serps so
tip number four is all about rich
snippets so let's start out by asking
ourselves what is a rich snippet so rich
snippet is simply just a term used to
describe structured data markup that you
as a website owner can add to your html
so hypertext markup language or html is
what is basically constructs a page so
if we can add more information to that
that will in turn allow search engines
like google to better understand the
information
that's on that web page so the more
google understands about that web page
the more they can put into the search
engine results page so rich snippets is
basically some structured data markup
that we can add to our existing html and
so if we want to add rich snippets to
search engines then how would you prefer
your products to be displayed well if we
have products then we want to make sure
that maybe we have reviews or maybe we
have so um other information in there
like uh
links to our site okay so there's a lot
of different types of rich snippets that
you know we can add that google can
recognize and add to the search engine
results so if you have a product then
there's a lot of things we can add like
specifically product reviews so we want
to be able to add more information to
the search engine results by working in
some rich snippets so basically the
whole idea is to set up the rich snippet
to drive targeted traffic okay so
because the more information in the serp
the more likelihood you're going to get
the click and the more likelihood that
click is specific traffic so some of the
benefits of structuring the data for
rich snippets are as i mentioned
increasing click-through rates you know
also increasing conversion rates so when
you get the traffic from organic search
to your website
if somebody's looking for specific
product and you have a number of
different good reviews showing up let's
just say 5 stars out of 5 stars and you
have 100 reviews showing 5 stars then
you know somebody's probably going to
send take some trust in your brand and
your conversion rate probability is
going to go higher it also helps improve
your search engine visibility because
you're adding more information so in
other words the more google knows about
your page the likelihood it's going to
rank that page and it's more likely that
that information that's contained in
that rich snippet is going to get
featured in either the knowledge graph
which is that graph on the right side or
in a featured snippet which usually
shows up at the top of search engine
results so in other words the more
information you give google the more
they can use that information on their
search results page and there's no
disagreeing that the more information
that you have in your search engine
result the likelihood of getting more
traffic increases so for rich snippets
you could always start with
images so some of the common properties
that you can add to your product page if
you have a product pages the page itself
is an image you can always start there
you can always add a description you can
always add in ratings and you can always
add in reviews so these are some of the
most common attributes you can add as a
rich snippet so if you add that google
picks it up it's going to include that
information in the search results okay
some others are offers prices site links
links to your site and product
availability so all that information can
be conveyed to google google understands
what you're trying to pass along it's
going to include that in the search
results so did you know that according
to ahrefs over
99.58 of featured pages that have
structured data already rank in the top
10 list of the google search results
page so in other words if you have rich
snippets in your page your chances of
ranking in the top 10 of a google result
is going to be very very very good okay
let's talk about tip number five
optimize your site structure for a great
user experience so let's go over some of
the tips that you would do for planning
a good website for seo and so tip number
one
is you want a url structure that follows
your site's navigation hierarchy so
obviously home page interior pages so
depending on what type of site you have
obviously the navigation needs to follow
that site's navigation that's site
hierarchy and it all starts with the
home page you want to optimize your home
page to drive traffic to your product
pages so the home page is nothing more
than a doorway into your website and so
the site's navigation
should link to all those different
products so if you have an e-commerce
site with sub categories or categories
subcategories then you want to be able
to
make sure your navigation reflects that
you want to build a comprehensive
structure for internal linking as well
because when you're from the home page
obviously you want to be able to easily
navigate to other pages however when
you're on other pages you want to be
able to have a link pointing back to
relevant pages and not necessarily on
the home page so this serves two
purposes one for the end user obviously
you want the end user to navigate
through your website seamlessly right
second for the search engines they're
following links they want to be able to
understand how your website flows and
links together so you don't want a
scenario where it's a one-way street
from the home page to interior pages you
want basically a home page to interior
interior to other relevant interior
pages and that could be a lateral or
that can be a situation where it's a
hierarchy for example home page category
sub categories sub sub category etc you
want to be able to make sure your site
is constructed in a manner in which the
search engine can read it so css or
cascading style sheets or hypertext
markup language html are your two most
common languages that's basically what
browsers load that's what search engines
like to index it just makes it easy for
them to understand what your page is all
about remember we talked about rich
snippets in the previous tip rich
snippets are nothing more than
supplemental html to describe what the
page is all about so that the search
engines can understand that page and
include reviews or include site links in
the search engine results so this is all
based on html so the more you provide
the search engines in a more structured
manner via html the more the search
engines are going to stay in the page
adding breadcrumbs to your product pages
is also a good practice if you have an
e-commerce site and you have a category
then a sub-category then a
sub-sub-category then a product page
it's probably not a bad idea to make
sure you have a breadcrumb so that was
that way somebody can easily go right
back from the product page to say the
category page or to the subcategory page
directly without having to hit the back
button or having to go through the
navigation some good examples i think
amazon is a good example of using
breadcrumbs giving the amount of
products they have on their site so go
check out amazon if you want a good
example for breadcrumbs and then
canonical tags we want to make good use
of canonical tags and that's in order to
avoid duplicate content so a canonical
tag is nothing more than a link element
basically or an html element that
basically prevents duplicate content
issues so in other words if we have a
canonical tag as a meta tag basically
we're telling the search engines this is
the preferred or canonical version of a
web page okay so use this webpage so it
signals to the search engines which page
they should basically index and pay
attention to and avoid at all the other
pages that have similar content so
that's the idea behind a canonical tag
so that's a good best practice and then
optimize your site for desktop and
mobile i can't stress the mobile part
enough most users begin their journey on
mobile so
if you're not sure about what the search
engines like or don't like you can
always refer to
google search console for an example so
if you go to google search console they
have a report called mobile usability so
if you click on mobile usability you can
see what pages they like what pages they
don't like from a mobile perspective and
if you have errors they're going to tell
you what those errors are so if your
website has text that's too small to
read they're going to tell you that
these are the pages with this error and
so that allows you to go and address
those errors because from a google
perspective if you have if a page has a
mobile usability error then google will
not index that page so leverage google
search console to get a sense of what
type of errors your site has from a
mobile perspective you also want to
prefer to keep your checkout page simple
so again from an e-commerce perspective
you want to keep the checkout page as
simple as possible for obvious reasons
you want the end user to have a good
experience and you obviously want the
conversion so when i say keep a checkout
page simple really now with today's
technology you can create a one-page
checkout process you want to optimize
your sitemap so when we talk about
sitemaps we want to make sure that it's
a file and xml file that basically
includes all of our urls and we can then
turn around and give that site map to
the search engines so if you have a
sitemap and xml make sure you go to
google search console so if i go to
google search console and i click on
site maps i can just simply just tell
google where my site map is located and
when they recognize that sitemap they're
going to be able to basically index the
urls from that sitemap so we can see
here how many urls they discover and how
many they index so make sure you create
the sitemap in an xml format submit the
sitemap via google search console and
then you can go back and see how many
pages they've indexed versus how many
you've submitted and you want to make
sure that sitemap is dynamic meaning
anytime you publish a url that url is
added to the sitemap fixing broken links
so broken links is not something you
want but it's something every website
has it's unavoidable you know people
publish pages all the time there's test
pages there's all sorts of reasons why
a site has broken links you want to be
able to address those and again going
back to google search console we can
basically see just by looking at some
reports what pages have broken links and
which ones don't so we could certainly
look at search console to get
information about basically what pages
are broken which ones aren't and then we
want to prefer predictive searches and
integrate product typographic errors on
your search bar so basically have a
search bar that's a best practice but
anticipate knowing what people are
typing in so that means maybe going into
google analytics and looking at the
search terms report so we can go into
analytics and look at search terms uh to
get a sense of what people are searching
for but you know when we talk about
integrating product typographic errors
we're talking also about fonts so we
want to make sure we're using the latest
fonts so that we don't run in any issues
on our website uh people not being able
to read based on a specific font that
you're using and then as a best practice
what i found and this is not necessarily
for everyone but using a live chat
widget sometimes helps in fact i would
even go beyond sometimes most the time
again depending on your business but i
see most businesses now have live chat
enabled and so basically
having live chat enables somebody who
has a question to immediately reach out
to somebody versus picking up the phone
versus sending an email it's just
instantaneous gratification in some ways
so inserting live chat on a website is
more common practice than not nowadays
given it it lends to a better user
experience tip number six improve your
page speed and reduce the bounce rate so
let's talk about page speed and how page
speed correlates with higher bounce rate
if it's a high page load and so
according to crazy page speed is an
important overlooked seo tactic because
for every second delay and page load can
result in
eleven percent fewer page views sixty
percent decrease in customer
satisfaction
seven percent decline in conversion rate
so you know you can see here regardless
of how specific the numbers are when you
have a page that loads slow you're going
to have lower user engagement and a poor
user experience so you have to pay
attention to page speed and so since
2010 google has been using page speed as
a factor for page ranking in the search
engine results so here's some tips to
focus on making sure your pages are
optimal in terms of speed so
enable browser caching okay you can
reduce plugins if you're using wordpress
as an example you know disable plug-ins
you're not using getting using a simple
website design going back to tip number
five stick with css and html don't do
anything fancy in terms of technology
because it's only going to complicate
matters optimize your code minify files
meaning hey if you're not using any code
just get rid of it because code has to
execute and that slows down page load
time so if your website has numerous css
and javascripts files basically minify
and combine them and that's what we're
talking about there you know you don't
necessarily need a lot of
you know javascript on your page you can
leverage google tag manager or you know
other features that help minimize the
number of javascript files you have and
so you can also get some of these ideas
by going into google analytics so in
analytics under behavior under site
speed under page timings you can
basically see how quick each page loads
and then if you click on speed
suggestions right below page timings
what happens is google is going to
actually give you some suggested ways to
increase speed so if we let this report
load we'll be able to see
some speed suggestions per page and so
here you can see for example the home
page has an average page load time of
4.89 seconds you can see right next to
that we have page speed suggestions
seven total so if we click on that
basically what it's going to do it's
going to launch another google product
called page speed insights and what page
speed insights is going to do
is it's going to analyze the page in
question whether that be the home page
or an interior page and what they're
actually going to do is not only analyze
the desktop version of your website but
also the mobile version and so now we
can see opportunities to improve our
page speed by making sure the images are
properly sized making sure server
response time is changed again defer
unused css not using css that's or
getting rid of css or minifying it so
there's lots of things you can do and
again this is desktop and mobile so on
the mobile side we could see some of the
other issues too that are causing high
page load and so analytics site speed
reports page speed insights are good
ways to get an idea really excellent
ways to really address page load time
issues so again these are just some of
the common issues with page load time
there could be other factors leaning on
those page speed insights reports will
definitely help reduce page load time so
basically according to google a website
should have you know time to first bite
lesser than 200 milliseconds
milliseconds is very very fast so in
case your website is slower than 200
milliseconds such as 500 milliseconds or
more you need to improve it so you don't
even have to measure it by milliseconds
you can even go by seconds which is what
most of us count time and again you
could see that simply going into the
speed suggestions report in google
analytics so ideally in terms of seconds
you want something that's about
you know four seconds or less three
seconds or less obviously as fast as
possible so case study walmart walmart
reported the following results so
walmart experienced a two percent
increase in conversions for every one
second of page speed improvement so
think about that there's definitely
correlation between page load time and
speed so in conversions and user
engagement so the quicker your page
loads the higher the engagement so with
that improvement they also experienced
an increment in revenue so meaning the
pages load people had a better user
experience they were able to check out
easier and that led to more revenue so
they were able to measure revenue
against milliseconds and that's
something you can certainly do in
analytics you can correlate revenue with
bounce rate you can correlate revenue
with page speed tip number seven
build quality links and increase their
domain authority of your website so
google's top three search ranking
factors includes link building so you
need to have quality links from quality
sites pointing to your site and so
that's a factor in terms of ranking so
that's falls under off page seo you need
to build references and links on quality
sites and so building quality links to
your content can give your product or
category pages or even content or blog
posts a boost in the serps so it's all
about quality over quantity so it's
always building quality links not
quantity so let's talk about what kind
of strategies you should implement so if
you implement these strategies then
you're going to likely see a lift in the
serps so earn backlinks from relevant
and authoritative web pages so what's
authoritative well authoritative is
subjective to some degree but it's also
measurement in others so you could use
moz as a good tool to measure page
authority or domain authority so if i go
into moz moz has a page and domain
authority score between 1 and 100 and so
you can actually see
what sites have good domain or page
authority just by entering in the domain
so relevant you obviously want to rank
to something that's relevant so if
you're in the food industry something
food related you want to promote your
content regularly on social media so
social media i always consider it all
low-hanging fruit when it comes to
backlinking you know there's so many
different social media platforms
available facebook linkedin twitter
there's so many varieties from images to
pinterest and instagram to video being
youtube so there's lots of ways to get
your content out on social media that
will allow you to not only promote your
ban build a community but also establish
a reference back to that page you can
opt for guest blogging okay so you can
reach out to another blogger and blog on
that platform and it could be reciprocal
as well a blogger can certainly you know
blog on your platform and have a link
back and it works both ways influencer
marketing so influencer marketing is
working with somebody who has a large
amount of followers who can influence
those followers to you know mention you
in a hashtag link to your particular
product or brand or even drive traffic
to your site so you want to take
advantage of social media platforms and
start your own page as well so
facebook's a good example it could be
having a youtube channel if you're into
video you can certainly set up a youtube
channel build a following around youtube
as well so always start your own page if
that's the platform of choice the last
thing you should do is set up a page on
social media and not keep it updated you
could certainly participate in forums
you can participate in other websites
like cora or reddit that's very you know
content based content driven user driven
i always recommend starting your own
blog blog is a good way to not only
generate content but it's a good way to
incorporate different types of content
so you could set up different types of
content and categories it's a good way
to incorporate different assets like
images and video it's a good way to
get users engaged by having comments or
having social share buttons it's a good
way to leverage that content onto other
social media platforms so there's lots
of benefits to blogging very few cons
the only con would be a time constraint
but it's better to have one blog post in
one month consistently than not blogging
at all so getting listed on high quality
link directories like yahoo directory is
still a way to add a link from a high
quality site and then make use of broken
link building so again on the last tip
we mentioned search console search
console certainly has reports available
for you that allow you to see what pages
on your site are no longer there
and allow you to see what pages they're
linking from okay you can also do
testimonials there's lots of ways to
generate quality links in a way you
almost have to get creative but creative
in a way that's going to generate
quality not quantity quality is the key
so even if it's one source whether that
be somebody else's blog so be it as long
as it's quality that's what counts today
we're going to cover search engine
optimization interview questions and
answers so thanks for joining again and
here's how it's gonna work so if you
have any questions to these questions or
answers feel free to just comment right
below this video and we'll get back to
you as soon as possible we're going to
go through a series of questions and i'm
going to answer those questions for you
okay so the first question that you
might be asking an interview is
differentiate between do follows and no
follows okay so if you take in or listen
to my seo courses on youtube for seo we
we talked a lot about do follows and no
follows and and simply put i mean do
follows are just signals to the search
engines to follow the link so there's a
link on site a pointing to site b
we're gonna basically tell google bing
and some of these other search engines
hey go ahead and follow that link now i
know file is just the opposite so no
follow link doesn't allow the search
engine crawlers to follow it so if we
have a link on our site
site a pointing to
site b we could put a nofollow tag in
there and what that's going to do it's
going to signal to the crawlers hey
don't follow this link so
in the end if the crawlers don't follow
the link then there's not going to be
any link juice passed and so google is
not going to give you credit or give
that site credit for having a link
pointing to it or pointing to another
site or from another site and so it's
all about linking so we can control if
there's links on our site whether we
want the crawlers to recognize those or
not simply with no follow tags so just a
reminder linked use is the reputation of
equity passed from one website to
another so if you have a link on another
website and that website is of high
quality meaning their page authority
their domain authority is high they have
a lot of content you know they're not
spammy they're really rich and they're
relevant then you may want to make sure
that the link pointing from that site to
your site is a nofollow so that way that
google can recognize the link from that
site to your site and basically that
reputation is going to be passed on to
you okay so that's a do follow versus a
nofollow and why would we do a nofollow
well it depends it really depends a lot
of social media platforms like facebook
have no follows if you have a lot of
content you may not want to be pushing
out a lot of do follows it could
actually look bad from an external
linking standpoint and so a lot of sites
are really particular about who they
want to pass link juice onto and give
credit for the link so it's a business
decision at the end of the day there's
really no hard fast rule here except
from an seo perspective if i have a site
and i have a lot of external links
pointing outward to other sites i'm
going to be particular about who i allow
the search engines to follow and what
links i allow not to follow so here's an
example of what they look like so do
follow is simply just the href notice
the nofollow has the the tag appended to
it the href tag with a nofollow so if
the search engine's crawling your site
and they see that no follow there
they're not going to follow that link
and vice versa if there's a link on
another site pointing to yours and
there's a no follow there you're not
going to get credit the search engines
aren't going to pick up that link okay
so question two what is 301 redirect and
how is it different from a 302 redirect
so
301 redirects tell users and the search
engine specifically that an original
page has been moved and this is the
keyword here permanently so permanently
moved we're going to explain that in a
minute so it's just moved from one page
to another and so if we
don't have a page anymore we have a new
page let's just say you built a new
website with new urls you want to make
sure the old page is pointing to the new
page with a 301 redirect so if a 301
redirect is permanent then a 302 is
temporary so we want the search engines
to
recognize that we have 301 permanent
redirects in place why because if we
have temporary then it might alert
google to
not keep that page in its search engine
rankings because it's temporary so why
would google want to keep a temporary
page or even a page that is pointing to
another page on a temporary basis so
they
may remove both pages from its index
okay but if we have something permanent
in place google may say okay this page
is permanently linking to another page
or redirecting to another page therefore
it's stable it's permanent we're going
to keep that new page in the index and
eventually remove the old page so really
something permanent is more stable in
the eyes of the search engine something
temporary may not be as stable in the
eyes of say google and if they don't see
it as stable then they may remove both
pages from the index okay so the ideas
we want to be found in google search
index and we get it sometimes pages go
away for a variety of reasons and if it
does go away just make sure you have a
new page for it and that new page is a
301 permanent redirect okay so question
three why are backlinks important in seo
well we kind of
hinted on that a bit with the nofollow
because if we have a link from another
website pointing to ours and that link
from that other website is really
relevant and and it has a high page and
domain authority then it's going to
benefit us and so backlinks are
important because if we have backlinks
from quite quality sites it's going to
improve the credibility of our site
especially if it's a do follow tag so
the search engines are gonna recognize
the relationship between the site that
has a link pointing to us okay so it's
just gonna build our credibility it's
gonna increase increase our domain
authority and then the net effect of
that is if we're credible and we have
high domain authority then that's going
to increase the rankings of our pages
and when the pages increase in ranking
then we're going to get more of a lion's
share of the traffic for certain
keywords that our pages are found for
and if our pages are found and getting
traffic then because we have increased
rankings we're likely going to have
increased traffic and then it's just a
snowball effect so more traffic leads to
more engagement and conversions so
the whole idea for seo is remember you
have an on-page strategy and an off-page
strategy building external links is part
of an off-page seo strategy and we want
to make sure that you know we are
relevant in the form of a link or in the
form of content on other high quality
sites being on a high quality site only
benefits us because again increases our
domain authority google sees this is
more relevant therefore pages are going
to benefit by ranking higher and
therefore when we rank higher we get
more traffic so it's a snowball effect
so having backlinks is important because
it snowballs all the way through to
conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on youtube
this is a great question really great
question given the importance of videos
especially with seo because videos are
found youtube in itself is a search
engine so if we have a video how are we
going to get it to rank on youtube well
first things first you never want to put
a video out there and want it to rank if
it's not engaging or informative so
make sure you go ahead and follow the
best practices of having engaging in
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing the video are
you want to choose a title that has high
search volume and low difficulty just as
you would keyword for example for web
page you want to choose a title with a
keyword in it that has high volume and
low difficulty i.e low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know when you want to choose a title
it's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high volume you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake of the title they're going to want
to probably get a sneak peek via the
description of what it is so again you
want to optimize that description but
make sure the description is is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on twitter or facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really short and to
the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant that's going
to grab somebody's attention and then
again we set it similar to the video
tags we want to use relevant hashtags
again just as you would with twitter and
facebook go ahead and throw some
hashtags in there that people could see
because people search via hashtagging
and then this goes about saying you did
all the work created a really great
video it's engaging it's informative you
optimized it feel free to promote your
video on other social media platforms
okay don't just stick with youtube per
se
so the benefit here is if you post it on
facebook or linkedin or whatever
platform of your choice and it gets
engagement people click on the link go
to youtube they're gonna like it and
then other people are gonna see that
engagement they're gonna see how many
people liked it or how many subscribers
you have so
promote your videos to help you with the
ranking of the video on youtube so that
does play into it so go ahead and
promote it so other people can watch it
like it comment etc and that's going to
engage other people to want to do the
same so what is mobile first indexing
this is a really important and timely
question mobile first indexing means
google's just using mobile friendly
content for indexing and ranking
websites so in other words google for
example has two bots they have the
traditional desktop bot and they have a
smartphone bot and eventually everybody
that has a website is going to be
migrated over
to the smartphone bot and so with that
smartphone bot goes to your website and
starts crawling what do you think
they're looking for their smartphone bot
they're looking for mobile friendly
content if it's not mobile friendly
meaning the page isn't designed for a
smartphone browser or let's just say the
images are way too large or you have to
expand the text just to read it you know
a lot of these these issues that
somebody would have just simply trying
to read something on a web page on their
mobile device google's not going to grab
that content so you want to make sure
it's mobile friendly so it gets indexed
and so if your website has a responsive
design google will rank your website
based on its performance on mobile
devices okay so you want to make sure
that your website is mobile friendly and
if you're in an interview and somebody
asked this question you could even take
it a step further and say look i'm going
to measure how friendly my wall my
website is for mobile devices in google
search console because google search
console has a report that will show you
what pages on your website are not
mobile friendly and it's not a guarantee
but i can tell you if i'm google and i'm
crawling your site with my smartphone
bop and that page or one of my pages is
not mobile friendly i'm probably not
going to index it or rank it so you want
to leverage that report in google search
console to see what pages are mobile
friendly so that's a little bonus for
you to really impress the interviewer
who asks you this question because how
are you going to know if one of your
pages is mobile friendly or not if you
don't look at a report so keep an eye on
google search consoles
mobile usability report okay number six
list down the most important local seo
ranking factors okay so
organic local ranking is just as
important as anything else in organic
search because if you have a local
business you want to use the likes of
say google my business to show up when
somebody types in you know looking for a
florist or
you're looking for a coffee shop so what
you want to do is you want to create a
web page for every product and service
okay you also want to opt for your
business listings on google my business
and and there are plenty of other local
business directories out there like yelp
for example or bing even has one so go
ahead and also make sure you have a
business listing as well but since
google in the united states has a huge
market share you want to start with
google first you want to update your nap
citations on your website maintain
consistency of your nap okay so nap is
name address phone number so
you want to make sure that that's
current and consistent so if you have a
number on your website make sure it's
the same number on google my business
okay you can embed a google map on your
website you could certainly optimize the
meta tags and content not only on your
web pages but within your google my
business directory so you can add your
business to other local directories like
i mentioned yelp and then also just as
important opt for reviews and ratings
okay so the more reviews the hat you
have the better off you are okay so i
always say this with the with local
search three of the main factors in
showing up for local search on say
google is obviously the key word the
second is the proximity of where that
person is and then third is the reviews
so you can't really control the
proximity but you can control the
keyword and you can control the reviews
to some degree so work hard at getting
reviews for your business but at the
same time you can certainly work in some
keywords let's just say for your product
and service pages on your website but
also you can translate that over to
google my business okay so working in
those keywords making sure your your
number your address your name they're
all consistent and and really just
spreading your the the business out on
other directors that's really all these
are really key factors for local seo
okay so question number seven how to
avoid duplicate content getting
penalized for duplicate content so for
example if you have two different
versions of a web page you may result in
a duplicate content issue so it's just
seo 101 you never want to have two two
or more pages with the same content so
what do we do well we can avoid this in
having google penalize us by again
setting up a 301 redirect remember three
or ones are permanent we can also use
what they call canonical tag and a
canonical tag basically alerts the
search engines as to which page is the
original okay so if we have an original
page we want to point to that page with
our canonical tag and then the third
option is opt for preferred domain in
google search console okay so if you
have multiple names make sure you set up
a primary one in search console so those
are ways to work around it of this three
i would always go with the canonical
tags because that's just a tag that's
gonna sit on the page it's going to
alert google as to what the original is
just in case they get their hands on the
duplicate so all the pages that have the
same content are going to have the same
canonical tag pointing to one page so
again three ones are permanent you can
simply just redirect one to the other if
you end up having duplication or you
could just tell search engines hey this
is the original page or you can go
through search console okay number eight
what are the tactics to increase a web
page speed okay so what are some of the
tactics well when you build a site
especially for mobile you want to keep
it as simple as possible and what i mean
by simple as possible really i mean hey
use a simple website design don't get
overly creative if you will most
websites all websites have images you're
not going to be able to get around that
but just make sure you optimize your
images in other words don't have such a
large image size if you don't need
something very large don't have it okay
you want to improve server response time
what do we mean by that well your site's
sitting on a server somewhere you could
own that server or you can be renting it
out from say amazon web services or
let's just say godaddy as your register
they also have web hosting well if you
have it on say godaddy's server you may
be sharing that server with other
businesses and at certain times of the
day other businesses may get a lot of
traffic and suck up a lot of bandwidth
what is that going to do that's going to
reduce the server response time for your
site and so you want to make sure you
have an idea of you know what server
your web page your website is on and you
want to be able to can have some control
over that because if your server
response is slow that's going to slow
down everything else in terms of loading
in the browser and that's not going to
be good for seo okay optimize your code
we mean by optimizing
when we see mimifying we mean get rid of
some of the redundant code if you have
css you know get rid of chop some of the
get rid of the javascript you're not
using so that's what we mean by
optimizing code reduce redirects okay
ideally you just want to have one
redirect in place you don't want to
create a daisy chain so to speak of
redirecting and redirecting after that
that's never gonna bode well and it's
gonna slow things down as well enable
browser caching so if you enable browser
caching basically if somebody comes back
to the page they've been on say two days
ago they're probably going to see a cash
version of that page and then off for
the content delivery network as well so
these are some of the ways to reduce
page speed now if you're curious about
the page speed of your website you can
always go to google's page speed
insights tool and all you have to do is
just google page speed insights or even
just something generic like google page
speed and you're going to get this tool
pagespeed insights and all you need to
do is just plug in a url when you plug
in the url google is going to analyze
the url for both mobile and desktop and
so here we could see google gives a
score so we could see the score from
mobile and we could see the score for
desktop just by clicking on desktop and
so here i could see
some of the issues that the site may be
having in terms of page load time for
their desktop if i flip over to mobile
you know here i could see some other
issues for example they have a server
static assets with efficient cash policy
now if you're not sure what the heck
that means you can always just click on
it and you can see some specifics here
anywhere you can just always google it
as well uh here you got to reduce the
impact of third-party code okay so
that's another thing uh reduced
javascript execution time so again going
back to a lot of some of the comments we
met about coding okay so sometimes too
much code or code not functioning as
well as it should will tend to slow down
the site okay so you can use pagespeed
insights you can always get a glimpse of
how pages are loading simply by also
going to for example google analytics
under behavior okay you can go to site
speed and if you click on overview okay
google what google does is they do a
sampling of pages over time and in this
case based on 89 page views they have an
average page load time and so you can
get a sense of how quick specific pages
load your site overall simply by looking
at the site speed overview report in
google analytics to get a sense of how
quick your pages are loading now
there are certain factors that do affect
load time so obviously the way the page
is built with the code the images etc
but also the browser each browser loads
differently okay so you want to take a
look at it by browser also by country
every country has a different network
you can be
in the united states and have worse
network service than you do say
in
you know
ivory coast in africa okay so really
depends on the network you're on so and
also the page every page is built
differently so you want to get a sense
of what pages are loading quicker and
which pages are not you can simply just
go to page timings and google analytics
and get a sense of what pages do not
load fast which ones do and maybe hone
in on the pages that aren't loading fast
and address those pages first okay so
you have two tools at your disposal one
google analytics and one page speed
insights okay so let's look at question
number nine here so when should an
individual target short tail and long
tail keywords okay so
remember short tail are usually one to
two keywords very broad in nature long
tail keywords maybe three four keywords
in a query or maybe an entire sentence
those are considered long tail keywords
so usually short tail keywords have
higher volume but also higher
competition longer tail keywords usually
have lower
volume but also lower competition but
the great thing about long tail keywords
the conversion rate will tend to be a
little bit higher than say a short tail
because it's less vague and more
specific so you can use short tail
keywords if you're trying to drive a lot
of visitors because those keywords are
going to be vague or broad in nature
long tail keywords are used for targeted
pages such as product pages and articles
so if you have a specific product with a
long name you could certainly
optimize that page for that product name
again the product name may have low
volume but if somebody types in exactly
that product name you show up the chance
of you them converting are going to be
very high so you don't have to always be
that specific with the product name but
try and be as specific as you possibly
can in order to get somebody to click on
your link in the search engine results
and get them over to your site to
convert okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for short tail keyword you're probably
going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may not be as high as
something say long tail where hey maybe
you're just toned in on a few set number
of products and you're not care you
don't care a lot about the traffic you
just care about getting the relevant
traffic to your site to convert okay
number 10 what are the important
elements to focus while developing a
website so we're talking in terms of seo
okay so if somebody asked me this
question in an interview what am i going
to focus on when developing a website
well the answers are right here yes we
talked about mobile mobile is so
important because a lot of websites are
going to be
indexed with google smartphone bot so
mobile usability is very important so we
need to make sure our website is
responsive for mobile just some basic
practices when it comes to site
architecture and navigation we want to
have a simple url structure okay no
overly cumbersome the navigation should
simply be clean and need okay if you
have five products okay maybe
you have uh in your navigation you have
something called products with all five
listed or you have all five products in
the main navigation the key is you just
want to make it clean and neat and easy
for somebody to find the the rule of
thumb is if it's good for the end user
probably going to be good for google but
if complicated for the end user it's
probably going to be complicated for
google you always want to create a site
map now what is that site map a sitemap
is simply just a formatted file with to
that includes all your urls and assets
your images and your videos they're
going to be sitting on your server as
well so you want google or these these
bots to be able to find your pages and
assets and by the way you want to take
it a step further and make sure you
upload that site map which is sitting in
the root directory meaning domain.com
sitemap.xml
okay you want to take that sitemap and
make sure you input that site map
location in google search console that
way google search console has a one-way
ticket to grab the elements in the
sitemap another important element to
focus on while developing a website is
having a robot's text file and all a
robot's text file is it's like a lock i
always say to a house so if you lock a
door in your house nobody's gonna be
able to get in that door so it's all a
robot's text file is you're telling
google and these other bots that are
coming across your site what's locked
and what's not logged meaning what they
have access to what they don't have
access to so you want to be able to make
sure you have a robot's text file if
you're trying to
not index specific pages of your website
because if you tell google don't crawl
these pages or this directory they're
not going to get crawled if they don't
get crawled they're not going to get
indexed so robots text file is an
important element to focus on while
you're developing your website and while
you're developing your website it could
be on a you know in a directory just
called new website so you probably want
to have new website as the directory in
the robots text file and just to let
google know don't go into this directory
because it's my new website i'm not
ready to go live yet so you don't want
it indexed so
there's a lot of reasons to have robots
text files that's the main reason
sitemap you want google to get these
pages and assets quickly okay you want
to make sure that your site architecture
navigation is in order you want to make
sure your site is mobile friendly and
you also want to make sure you have
content on your website that's the key
because that's what's going to keep
people on the website and engaged and
when i say content i don't necessarily
just mean words i also mean videos i
also mean images you know something
interactive okay you want to keep people
engaged that's the key behind it trust
me if if an end user finds your site
engaging google is likely going to find
your site engaging okay so those are
good brownie points to bring up if
somebody asks you this question in an
interview so just to recap here it's
important to have a better site
structure so the bots can easily access
and mix the content okay with a
responsive design helps to make your
website mobile friendly and user
friendly would also increase the amount
of time a user spends on your website
which may improve your site's ranking
sitemap is simply just a file that helps
search engine bots to understand the
structure of the website okay how many
pages are on your website and where they
located along with the videos and images
okay and then the robot's text just
instructs the search engine crawlers to
understand what pages should not be
indexed okay this is simply just a text
file and it's added to the root
directory again think like a door think
of a lock okay you can tell you can lock
whatever doors you want in your house
then give it that way and with that we
have come to the end of this video on
seo full course i hope it was
informative and interesting if you have
any questions about the topics covered
in this video please ask away in the
comment section below our team will help
you solve your queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
you